I THINK IT'S FITTING. WE ARE IN
MENTAL AWARENESS MONTH. WE'RE
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL INITIATIVES. REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE HOW WE'RE GOING
TO, TAKE, SUCH A HUGE LIFT OF
PROP ONE AND HELP THAT COME TO
FRUITION. SO REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATIONS.
ONE LITTLE CHANGE IN THE AGENDA
FOR, FOR ON THE ITEM ZERO 530
FOR THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. WE'RE
GOING TO ACTUALLY BE PUSHING
THAT AND NOT BE HEARING THAT
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO BE PUSHING
THAT TO, NEXT WEEK JUST TO GIVE
MORE TIME FOR ME TO READ THROUGH
THE REPORT THAT JUST CAME OUT
YESTERDAY. OKAY. WITH THAT IN
MIND, WE'RE GOING TO DO,
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. WE GOT DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION, OR
THE NEW TITLE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING ON IT, AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE STARTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOSPITALS AS WELL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE STARTING
IT OFF WITH A PANEL ON PROP ONE
AND WHAT OUR VISION IS. SO I'D
LIKE TO INVITE THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE SPEAKING ON THIS TO
COME ON UP. WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM DCS,
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CDF, LÀ, Þ,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE MH S
OAC. I ALSO LIKE TO WAKE UP.
WELCOME BACK UP. THE ED FROM OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
HOW ARE WE ALL HERE? OH YEAH.
DOCTOR THOMAS. DOCTOR VOSS. I'M
GUESSING THAT'S TOBY, NEXT.
THAT'S TOBY, AND THEN. ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE BEING BLESSED WITH
TWO MICHELLES TODAY. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL START OFF WITH DCS. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MICHELLE BASS,
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. I DON'T
KNOW HOW WE DO THE SLIDES. I
THINK WE HAVE A SLIDE DECK. OR
DO I DO IT? SO WE GOT. I THINK
WE MIGHT NEED YOUR HELP.
PRESENTATION AND SENATE-TV
HANDLES. OKAY, SO. OKAY SANITY.
OH, PERFECT. OKAY, GREAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SO THIS MORNING
GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
PROPOSITION ONE. AS YOU KNOW,
PROPOSITION ONE WAS PASSED BY
THE VOTERS IN MARCH OF THIS
YEAR. IT IS A TWO BILL PACKAGE
ESSENTIALLY REPRESENTING SB 3 TO
6 FROM EGGMAN LAST YEAR, AND
THEN AB 531 FROM IRWIN. I'M
REALLY PROPOSING A STATEWIDE
EFFORTS TO REFORM AND EXPAND
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM, SOME OF THE GOALS OF
PROPOSITION ONE WERE TO IMPROVE
STATEWIDE ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES, INCREASE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITY INFRASTRUCTURE, EXPAND
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. INCREASED INVESTMENT IN
EXPANDING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND EXPAND INVESTMENT
IN EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
WITH A FOCUS ON CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. TWO OF THE COMPONENTS OF
PROPOSITION ONE ARE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
BOND ACT. AND WE'LL SPEAK TO
BOTH OF THOSE AS PART OF THIS
PRESENTATION. THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT, OR HSA,
REPLACES THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OF 2020 2004. IT
REFORMS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
FUNDING TO PRIORITIZE. WE'RE
GOING TO BECAUSE WE DON'T SEE
THE SLIDES JUST YET. OH, I
HAVEN'T MOVED IT YET. OKAY.
SORRY. THIS IS JUST A QUICK
OVERVIEW OKAY. SO NOTHING SHOULD
BE SHOWN RIGHT NOW. IT'S NOT
DISPLAYING. IT'S NOT THAT COVER.
THERE WE GO. I DON'T KNOW. HANDS
ARE ON MY LAP RIGHT NOW.
PRIORITIZE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. ADDING THE ABILITY TO USE
THESE DOLLARS TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER NEEDS, EXPANDING
HOUSING AND INTERVENTIONS,
INCREASING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND THEN, JUST AS A
SUMMARY, THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE BOND ACT
AUTHORIZED ABOUT $6.4 BILLION IN
BOND FUNDS. SO WITH REGARD TO
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT, REALLY THE KEY PIECES, ONE
OF THE KEY, CHANGES, RELATED TO
THE HSA COMPARED TO THE MSAS, A
CHANGE IN THE REVENUE
DISTRIBUTION, UNDER HSA, 90% OF
THE REVENUE GOES TO OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AND 10% GOES TO
STATEWIDE INVESTMENTS. AND WE'LL
GO THROUGH EACH OF THESE IN MORE
DETAIL. BUT JUST AS A SUMMARY OF
THE LOCAL DOLLARS 30% TO HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS, 35% FOR FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS AND
35% FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES, AND SUPPORTS. AND THEN
AT THE STATEWIDE SIDE, STATEWIDE
INVESTMENTS, 3% STATE ADMIN,
GENERALLY ACROSS MANY
DEPARTMENTS, 3% 3% FOR WORKFORCE
AND 4% FOR PREVENTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, AND
THE NEXT SLIDE HERE IS JUST
REALLY A SAMPLE BèC ALLOCATION.
YOUR AGENDA INCLUDES INFORMATION
ON THIS AS WELL. JUST REALLY
REPRESENTING OF JUST FOR EXAMPLE
, 3.5 BILLION IN REVENUE. AND OF
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY 3.1
BILLION GOING TO OUR LOCAL
COUNTY PARTNERS. AND YOU CAN SEE
THE SPLIT OF THE ALLOCATIONS
THERE. I WON'T GO INTO THOSE
DETAILS, AS WE KNOW, THE WEIGHT
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
IN CRISIS ARE REALLY NOT CARRIED
EQUALLY, AND SO AS PART OF
H.S.A, WE REALLY ARE FOCUSING ON
ELIGIBLE ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS
WHO ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS IN OR AT
RISK OF BEING IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. REENTER THE COMMUNITY
FROM PRISON OR JAIL AT RISK OF
CONSERVATORSHIP OR AT RISK OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. AND THEN
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH,
FOCUSING ON THOSE WHO ARE ALSO
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS IN OR AT
RISK OF BEING IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. REENTERING THE
COMMUNITY FROM A YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM, OR ALSO AT
RISK OF INSTITUTIONALIZATION. WE
KNOW THAT THROUGH STRATEGIES
THAT ARE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE,
WE CAN REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. YOU
KNOW, WE ARE PART OF OUR EFFORT,
AND WE'LL GO THROUGH IN MORE
DETAIL, REALLY THINKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE REDUCE SILOS FOR
PLANNING AND SERVICE DELIVERY
AND SETTING CLEAR PRINCIPLES
THAT ARE ROOTED IN EQUITY, HOW
DO WE THINK ABOUT STRATIFYING
OUR DATA AND THE STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES? AS
WE LOOK AT OUR DATA AND PLAN FOR
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE VERY
SPECIFIC TO THE POPULATIONS THAT
WE WANT TO SERVE, REALLY
ADVANCING COMMUNITY DEFINED
PRACTICES AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW
TO REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AGAIN RECOGNIZING THAT TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS OR TARGETED
PROGRAMS ARE OFTEN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN IN REACHING SOME OF
THE POPULATIONS THAT MAY BE
EXPERIENCING DISPARITIES, AND
THEN ALSO JUST RECOGNIZING,
WANTING TO HAVE MORE DIVERSITY
AND MORE KIND OF, VAST
EXPERIENCES AS PART OF THIS
DIFFERENT ADVISORY GROUPS THAT
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED ARE A PART OF
THE HRSA. ONE OF THE KEY
FEATURES OF THE HCA IS THE
COUNTY INTEGRATED PLAN FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
OUTCOMES. TODAY, UNDER MHSA,
THERE IS A LOCAL ROBUST PLANNING
PROCESS THAT REALLY IS FOCUSED
ON MHSA FUNDS ONLY UNDER HRSA,
REALLY THINKING ABOUT ALL LOCAL,
STATE AND FEDERAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FUNDING. SO IT'S THE HRSA
DOLLARS OPIOID SETTLEMENT
DOLLARS, SOME OF THE FEDERAL
GRANTS REALIGNMENT DOLLARS, FFP
OR FEDERAL DOLLARS, AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FUNDING ON THE
MEDI-CAL SIDE AS WELL. SO AS
PART OF THE INTEGRATED PLAN FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES, OUR
OUR COUNTIES WILL BE WORKING
WITH A ROBUST SET OF PARTNERS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO THINK ABOUT
HOW TO COME TOGETHER TO PUT THIS
PLAN TOGETHER, TO CONSIDER WHAT
ARE THE COMMUNITIES OR THE
REGION'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. ALSO, THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES OF
OTHER PLANNING OPPORTUNITIES,
SUCH AS THE MEDI-CAL MANAGED
CARE POPULATION NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS, THE WORK THAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS DO
WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT PLANS, AND HOW THESE
PLANS CAN BOLSTER AND WORK
TOGETHER AND NOT BE IN SILOS AND
KIND OF WORK SEPARATELY FROM ONE
ANOTHER. EXCUSE ME THROUGH THE
CHAIR, IF I MAY. ONE OF THE
PARTNERS THAT THAT THAT I DIDN'T
HEAR YOU MENTIONED WAS JUST
PRIVATE INSURANCE. AND THE
PRIVATE MARKET, ARE THEY WE'RE
ALSO INCLUDING THEM BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALSO A FUNDING SOURCE THAT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME IN WITH
SOME OF THE POPULATION. YES. AND
SO AS PART OF THAT, WE ALSO HAVE
THE HCA ALSO HAS REQUIREMENTS
WITH REGARDS TO COUNTIES
MAXIMIZING, COMMERCIAL COVERAGE
AND MAXIMIZING OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONTRACT WITH EACH OTHER. AND SO
THEY ARE PART OF THIS. AND ALSO
THE REQUIREMENT FOR KIND OF EVEN
JUST THE TRANSITION BETWEEN, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE THE MORE MILD TO
MODERATE AND SPECIALTY AND HOW
THAT WORKS BOTH WAYS FROM
COUNTIES TO PLAN PLAN TO
COUNTIES. AND THAT IS A KEY
REQUIREMENT AS PART OF THIS
PLANNING EFFORT. OKAY, I DIDN'T
HEAR YOU MENTION THAT PART. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT'S IN
THERE. OKAY ANOTHER KEY PIECE OF
THIS IS REALLY AGAIN, JUST THE
OUTCOME AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMPONENT OF THIS. SO THAT THREE
YEAR PLAN THAT WILL BE USED TO
IDENTIFY HOW COUNTIES WILL USE
THEIR DOLLARS AS PART OF THE
THREE YEAR PLANNING PROCESS AND
THEN ANNUALLY AFTER THE FACT,
ESSENTIALLY REPORTING TO THE
STATE AND TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
HOW THESE DOLLARS WERE USED,
WHAT WERE THE FUNDING LEVELS
THAT WERE ACHIEVED, HOW DATA ON
WORKFORCE, FOR EXAMPLE, DATA ON
QUALITY METRICS, THE KIND OF THE
WORK THROUGH HOW STATE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
COUNTY LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES. WHAT WAS ACHIEVED WERE
THE BENCHMARKS ARE AND THEN ALSO
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE DO THIS
FROM IN KIND OF A STRATIFIED
DATA PERSPECTIVE AS WELL, TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
DISPARITIES AND THE OUTCOMES BY
POPULATION, OTHER THINGS, IF
THERE'S UNSPENT DOLLARS, PARDON
ME, WHAT HAPPENS IF THERE'S
UNSPENT DOLLARS? THAT WILL BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION. BUT
TODAY, I MEAN, IT'S JUST TO
ACTUALLY HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING,
THE TRANSPARENCY OF WHAT IS
AVAILABLE, WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH ALL THE,
THE DIFFERENT DOLLARS AND THE
SOURCES THAT CAN BE USED. AND SO
THEN THAT'S WHERE CONVERSATIONS
CAN BE HAPPENED, CAN HAPPEN.
THESE DOLLARS CAN EASILY ROLL,
POTENTIALLY ROLL OVER. RIGHT. OR
IF IS THERE AN ALLOCATION THAT
HAS TO BE SPENT ANNUALLY ON BèC
DOLLARS. YES. WELL, IT'S KIND OF
PART OF THE THREE YEAR PLANNING
PROCESS. AND SO UNSPENT DOLLARS
CAN GO INTO THE RESERVE OR CAN
BE KIND OF ROLL OVER IT. YEAH.
SO THERE'S KIND OF AND WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT IN A SECOND AS
WELL, OTHER DATA THAT WILL BE
INCLUDED AS PART OF, THE
OUTCOMES AND TRANSPARENCY REPORT
IS INFORMATION ON SERVICES
PROVIDED TO PERSONS NOT COVERED
BY MEDI-CAL, INCLUDING
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE AND
MEDICARE AND UNINSURED. SO
AGAIN, TO GET A BETTER
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING, WHO
ARE OUR COUNTIES SERVING AND
WHERE ARE MAYBE SOME FUNDING
SOURCES THAT MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK TO
MAXIMIZE AS WELL? I'M GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE FIRST ONE OF THE
FIRST BUCKETS IN THE LOCAL
ALLOCATION, THE HOUSING
INTERVENTION PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS, AS I MENTIONED,
30% OF THE LOCAL DOLLARS WILL BE
USED FOR HOUSING INTERVENTIONS.
AND THIS INCLUDES DOLLARS FOR
RENTAL SUBSIDIES, OPERATING
SUBSIDIES, SHARED AND FAMILY
HOUSING CAPITAL AND THE
NONFEDERAL SHARE FOR CERTAIN
TRANSITIONAL RENT, 50% OF THESE
DOLLARS ARE PRIORITIZED FOR
INTERVENTION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS, UP TO
25% MAY BE USED FOR CAPITAL
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE AN
EXEMPTION FOR SMALL COUNTIES
WITH REGARD TO THE 2629 PLANNING
CYCLE, DEPENDENT ON THEIR LOCAL
DATA IN THE HOUSING, HOUSING,
HOUSING AND HOMELESS SPACE. AND
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS OR PERSONS ENROLLED
IN MEDI-CAL. SO THIS IS KIND OF
THE BROAD POPULATIONS THAT THE
COUNTY SERVE. AND THEN ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
THE LARGER COUNTIES OR THE
MEDIUM SIZED COUNTIES AS WELL,
TO HAVE SOME EXEMPTIONS FROM
THIS 30% REQUIREMENT IN IN
FUTURE PLANNING CYCLES. A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON HOUSING AND
INTERVENTIONS, I WANT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WILL BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
COUNTIES AND VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS ON KIND OF DEFINING
THESE THESE AS WELL, AND HOW
THEY INTERPLAY AND INTERACT WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER HOUSING
EFFORTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY, AS
WELL. FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
REQUIREMENTS. SO THE SECOND
LARGE CATEGORY OF SPEND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS 35% FOR OUR FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS,
AND THIS INCLUDES SERVICES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES,
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES, SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES INCLUDING
MEDICATION AND ASSISTANT
TREATMENT, COMMUNITY DEFINED
EVIDENCE PRACTICES, ASSERTIVE
COMMUNITY TREATMENT. FORENSIC
ASSERTIVE ACADEMY TREATMENT. SO
THOSE ARE REFERRED TO AS ACT IN
FACT, SUPPORTIVE EMPLOYMENT.
HIGH FIDELITY WRAPAROUND. ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED AS PART OF WHAT FSP
MEANS TODAY. WE PLAN TO
ESTABLISH AND WORK CLOSELY WITH
OAC AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CARE AND FSP
TODAY, FSP IS GENERALLY NOT AS
STANDARDIZED AS WHERE WE WOULD
WANT IT TO BE. SO DEFINING
LEVELS OF CARE WITH FSP AND
RECOGNIZING, KIND OF THE NEED TO
BUILD OUT A BIT OF A CONTINUUM
FOR FSP TO ENSURE WE HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE SERVICES
PROVIDED TO INDIVIDUALS AND
DIRECTOR, WOULD YOU CALL ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU LISTED AS
TARGETED INTERVENTIONS WHEN YOU
I KNOW YOU USE THE TERM TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS A LOT. SO I WANT
TO MAKE MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND.
SURE. AND I THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THE COMMUNITY DEFINED EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES REALLY THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS. ASSERTIVE
COMMUNITY TREATMENT FOR EXAMPLE,
IS KIND OF A HIGH FIDELITY.
THAT'S THERE'S A PRETTY
PRESCRIBED KIND OF WHAT THAT
MEANS. AND SO IT'S SOME OF THESE
OTHER COMMUNITY DEFINED
PRACTICES, EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT ARE CAN BE BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TARGETED IN
TERMS OF WHAT POPULATIONS ARE.
WE ARE HOPING TO SERVE. DIRECTOR
IN THIS SECTION FOR FSP AT THE
BOTTOM I SEE SOME LIKE HOUSING.
SO WOULD YOU SAY IF THE 30% WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT ON THE, FOR
ALLOCATED FOR HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS, YOU CAN TAP INTO
THIS POT AS WELL TO USE FOR
HOUSING. THE HOUSING IS ACTUALLY
THE 30, 30. YES. NOT BUT UNDER
35. YOU ALSO HAVE TO SUPPORT
MAINTAINING HOUSING AS ANOTHER
ELIGIBLE SOME. SOMETIMES YOU
NEED SERVICES THAT MIGHT BE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT AN INDIVIDUAL.
SO IT'LL BE JUST A SERVICES
VERSUS THE FIRST 30% FOR
HOUSING. TRUE HOUSING, TRUE
HOUSING. AND WE'RE DEFINING THAT
AS ALL EVERYTHING TINY HOMES,
TRANSITIONAL PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AND THAT 30%
BUCKET. YES. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'LL STILL BE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO PUT A LITTLE BIT
MORE UNDERSTANDING INTO TO THOSE
TERMS. BUT YES, THAT'S THE BROAD
CATEGORIES. EACH OF THESE THIS
IS KIND OF YOU KNOW, WE'RE AT
THE POINT WHERE WE HAVE SOME
HIGH LEVEL UNDERSTANDING AND
KIND OF GOALS AND VISION, AND I
THINK IT'S THE NEXT LEVEL OF AS
YOU THINK ABOUT, WHAT DOES THIS
ACTUALLY MEAN AND WHAT IS
ALLOWED AND NOT ALLOWED, RIGHT.
BECAUSE THE FIRST 35% YOU TALK
ABOUT FOR HOUSING ULTIMATELY
MOST LIKELY IS AFFECTING THIS
POPULATION. YES THANK YOU. I
HAVE A QUESTION. YES. OKAY.
SORRY THANK YOU. AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR BEING A FEW MINUTES LATE. IS
THERE A TRADITIONAL PROCESS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW OR BECAUSE
OF THESE NEW ALLOCATED DOLLARS,
ARE WE GOING TO TRY TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY THAT ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN WHAT WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST? FOR ALL THE MONEY THAT
IS SPENT ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS? AND THE REASON WHY
I ASK THAT QUESTION IS BECAUSE I
WANT TO KNOW HOW THE RFP PROCESS
IS GOING TO WORK. DOES THAT GO
TO THE COUNTIES, TO THE STATE,
TO THE STATE, OR TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY, LIKE IF
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO COME AND
APPLY FOR SOME OF THESE FUNDS TO
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SERVICES, OR
IS THERE GOING TO BE AN RFP
PROCESS, DO YOU GUYS ALREADY
HAVE THE SELECTED VENDORS? IS IT
ALREADY PREDETERMINED? SO THESE
DOLLARS ARE ALL AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT GO
TO OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AND SO COUNTIES
WILL RFP OR CONTRACT FOR THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES AS THEY DO
TODAY. AND YOU KNOW, I THINK
PART OF THIS IS THAT LOCAL
PLANNING PROCESS ALSO BRINGING
IN MORE FUNDING SOURCES, MORE
PROGRAMS, MORE KIND OF WHAT I
CALL CONTRIBUTORS TO THE KIND OF
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM AS
THEY THINK ABOUT WHAT IS KIND OF
THE OVERALL VISION FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. AND SO RECOGNIZING I
THINK THIS IS A BIT OF A
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING IT THAN
TODAY, WHERE IT IS JUST THE DHS
OR THE MHSA PLANNING. THIS IS A
BROADER CONVERSATION THÀNH AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO IT'S SO
COUNTY FUNDS WILL BE ALLOCATED,
THE STATE WILL GIVE THE COUNTY
MONEY, AND THE COUNTY WILL
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS TO THE, THE,
THE SUPPLIERS OR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WILL TAKE ON THESE
SERVICES. YES. PROVIDE THE
SERVICE OR SERVICE PROVIDERS, IS
IT WHEN THIS RESOURCE REYES COME
OUT FROM PROP ONE, ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ALLOCATED FROM THE
STATE BASED ON SIZE OF THE
COUNTY? THE POPULATION OF THE
COUNTY? WHAT'S THE METRICS LIKE?
I KNOW THAT, AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
END OF THE DAIS OVER HERE, BUT
WE REPRESENT RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR INSTANCE, THE WAY THAT
THE STATE ALLOCATES
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS WE
MAINTAIN MORE HIGHWAY BETWEEN
THE TWO OF US THAN THE CITIES OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
ALTOGETHER. BUT WE GET THE
FEWEST DOLLARS. SO WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST MEDI-CAL POPULATION
BASE, THE HIGHEST, YOU KNOW,
RATES OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES BECAUSE OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PIECE. AND I
KNOW THEY'RE IN BIG CITIES, TOO.
BUT HOW IS THE ALLOCATION GOING
TO BE GIVEN TO THIS, THE
COUNTIES? IS IT BASED ON
POPULATION BASED ON SIZE BASED
ON MEDI-CAL RECIPIENT BASED ON
WHAT? SO THERE WAS NO CHANGE TO
THE KIND OF THE WAY THE DOLLARS
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO COUNTIES BY
HRSA OR MHSA TO BE H.S.A. AND SO
THERE WAS NO CHANGE IN THAT
ALLOCATION. I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ON SPECIFICALLY HOW THAT
WORKS, BUT THERE WAS NO CHANGE
TO THAT AS PART OF PROP ONE OR
BSSA. AND ALL CONSTRUCTION BIDS
FOR NEW HOUSING OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WILL BE STRICTLY COUNTY BY
COUNTY, CORRECT? OKAY THESE ARE
ALL LOCAL DOLLARS. SO THESE
DOLLARS WILL GO TO THE COUNTIES,
AND COUNTIES WILL USE THESE
DOLLARS TO DO THE PROJECTS THAT
THEY PLAN FOR. OKAY. AND THEN
LIKE IS THERE ANY RESTRICTIONS.
AND I GUESS THIS IS WHAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, I
DON'T WANT TO SAY I PUT MY NAME
ON PROP ONE BECAUSE I REALLY
DEEPLY CARE ABOUT THE VETERANS
THAT ARE OUT THERE ON THE
STREET. AND THERE WAS $1
BILLION. AND I BASICALLY MADE
THE COMMENT THAT Y'ALL CAN KEEP
SQUANDERING THE 6 BILLION, BUT
THE OTHER BILLION THAT'S OUT
THERE FOR THE VETERANS, I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR VETERANS
ARE TAKEN CARE OF. I'VE LOOKED
AT ORGANIZATION LIKE NONPROFITS,
TUNNELS, TOWERS, DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT LIKE BUY A
HOTEL ROOM NEXT TO A VA CLINIC,
AND THEY HOUSE LIKE 400 VETERANS
OFF THE SIDE OF THE STREET WITH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND THEY
HAVE MATCHING DOLLARS THAT COME
FROM FOUNDATIONS, ARE WE JUST
GOING TO OR IS THERE A WAY TO
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT VETERANS GET
THE HOUSING THEY DESERVE? OR ARE
WE STILL STUCK WITH, AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE NEGATIVE, BUT
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS AND YOU
CAN'T DO THIS AND YOU KNOW, ALL
THE, THE, THE ISSUES THAT
PREVENT US FROM BUILDING HOUSING
AND PROVIDING HOUSING, ARE WE
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX OR ARE
THERE RESTRICTIONS? SO THE
HOUSING DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AS PART OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BOND ACT. SO
THERE'S THAT THOSE DOLLARS AND
THEN THERE'S THE 30% THAT GO TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL. THERE WERE SOME
STREAMLINING EFFORTS THAT WERE
PART OF AB 531 TO REALLY TRY TO
STREAMLINE SOME OF THE
CONSTRUCTION THÀNH AND KIND OF
THE WAYS TO BUILD OUT HOUSING
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT,
AND SO THOSE ARE KIND OF, I
THINK, WAYS TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN, STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
TO BUILD OUT THESE, THESE
HOUSING AND TREATMENT SETTINGS.
SO DID I UNDERSTAND YOU RIGHT,
THAT ONLY 30% OF THE HOUSING
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO GO TO ALL
THE 58 COUNTIES, AND THE STATE
IS GOING TO KEEP 70? WHY DID YOU
JUST SAY 30? SO OF THE LOCAL
DOLLARS? YES AND MAYBE I'LL GO
BACK TO THE SLIDE. SURE SO, THE
SO THIS IS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT REVENUE DOLLARS,
90% OF THOSE DOLLARS GO TO THE
COUNTY. OKAY. AND OF THOSE
DOLLARS, 30% GO TO HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS. OKAY. AND THEN
10, GOES TO THE STATE FOR ADMIN,
FOR WORKFORCE AND PREVENTION. IN
ADDITION TO THESE DOLLARS, THERE
IS THE BOND ACT, WHICH HAS ABOUT
6 BILLION IN FUNDING FOR HOUSING
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES. AND I'LL SPEAK TO
THAT IN A MINUTE. I HAVE A
SUMMARY SLIDE ON THAT ONE AS
WELL. OKAY. AND THAT'S INCLUDING
THE BILLION DOLLARS FOR VETERANS
. THAT'S ON THE RIGHT. THAT'S ON
THE SLIDE OKAY. THE BOND SIDE
OKAY. I APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU.
OKAY. I THINK WE WERE HERE OKAY.
THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE ON THIS
THIS SLIDE NOW JUST CIRCLING
BACK ON FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
TREATMENT. NOT QUITE RIGHT I'M
SORRY. ALL RIGHT. WHERE IS IT?
THANK YOU. NOW THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU, JUST CIRCLING BACK ON
FSP, AGAIN, THESE ARE THE
SERVICES RELATED TO AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO MEETS THE
CRITERIA FOR FSP. AND WE PLAN TO
BUILD OUT THE LEVELS OF CARE
THERE, ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IN
THE AGENDA, JUST TO KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT, WAS THE KIND OF
TODAY, 51% OF MHSA REVENUES ARE
FOR FSP. THAT INCLUDES THE
COUNTING OF FEDERAL DOLLARS.
UNDER BSSA. IT IS 30. IT IS THE
REQUIREMENT IS ON, ON JUST THE
FSP DOLLAR. SO THAT 35. SO
THEREBY WE EXPECT MORE DOLLARS
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR FSP
SPENDING AS COUNTIES BUILD OUT
THIS PROGRAM. OKAY. PRIORITIES
FOR THE USE OF EARLY
INTERVENTION FUNDS. SO THIS IS
THE 35% BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND SUPPORT BUCKET
UNDER THE LOCAL DOLLARS. AND
THIS INCLUDES EARLY INTERVENTION
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
, OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT,
CAPITAL FACILITIES,
TECHNOLOGICAL NEEDS, AND
INNOVATIVE PILOTS AND PROJECTS.
THIS IS KIND OF WHERE A LOT OF
THE SERVICE DOLLARS WILL BE
ALLOCATED. A MAJORITY OF THESE
DOLLARS MUST BE USED FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES. AND THESE
THESE SERVICES REALLY DO ASSIST
IN THE EARLY SIGNS OF MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE MISUSE
DETECTION. AND A MAJORITY OF
THOSE DOLLARS MUST BE USED FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION FOR SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS FOR CHILDREN OR
PEOPLE 25 YEARS AND YOUNGER.
REALLY, THE IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
INTERVENTION RECOGNIZE AND
REDUCE NEGATIVE OUTCOMES. THAT
EARLY IDENTIFICATION THÀNH. AND
REALLY THE THINKING ABOUT HOW DO
WE REDUCE DISPARATE SES. WE KNOW
WE HAVE SOME PRETTY ROBUST
COMMUNITY DEFINED EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES, THAT, ARE WORKING
WELL TODAY. AND I THINK PART OF
THE WORK IS PART OF THE WORK
WITH OAC WILL BE TO IDENTIFY A
STATEWIDE LIST OF WHAT ARE SOME
OF THESE PRACTICES AND THEN
POTENTIALLY EVENTUALLY REQUIRING
OUR COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
STATEWIDE PRACTICES, AND SO
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE DEFINITION OF THESE AS
WELL. ÁP OF THOSE SLIDES. SORRY,
MADAM CHAIR. YES, OF COURSE,
DIRECTOR, ON SUCH TREATMENT, YOU
PREVIOUSLY WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT, CAPACITY BUILDING AND SO
FORTH. IT SEEMS LIKE WE NEED A
LOT OF CAPACITY BUILDING ON THE
TREATMENT SIDE. ARE WE LOOKING
AT PRIORITIZING CERTAIN THINGS
AND STREAMLINING THOSE OVER
OTHERS? HOPEFULLY MICHELLE HERE
SAYS YES. SO I WILL ALSO SAY AS
PART OF THE CONNECT OUR FEDERAL
WAIVER BEFORE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THE 2.4 BILLION IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SUBSTANCE
USE IS DEFINITELY ON THE LIST.
HIGH LIST OF KIND OF WE KNOW WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF SUBSTANCE
USE, PROFESSIONALS. AND SO
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE BUILD OUT
THAT WORKFORCE AS WELL. AND THEN
AS COUNTIES PLAN FOR THE USE OF
THESE DOLLARS, THEY DO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEIR LOCAL
DATA REFLECTS IN TERMS OF, YOU
KNOW, WHAT ARE THE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND HOW THEY
BUILD OUT WHETHER IT'S MENTAL
HEALTH, SUBSTANCE USE, KIND OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR CODE TYPE
SERVICES, THINKING ABOUT THE
POPULATIONS THAT THEY THAT THEY
NEED TO SERVE AND THINKING ABOUT
WHAT HOW THEY BUILD OUT THEIR
PROGRAMS AS WELL, A LOT OF IT.
SO DATA FLEXIBILITY ON THE
COUNTIES. YES RIGHT TO THEM FOR
THEM TO DETERMINE WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITY THEY
NEED TO BUILD ON. OKAY OKAY, AND
THEN IN TERMS OF THE QUESTIONS
RELATED TO CHANGES TO COUNTIES
ABILITY TO MANAGE THEIR PRUDENT
RESERVE Ã BèC FUNDING, JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW CHANGES.
UNDER H.S.A, THE PRUDENT RESERVE
WAS REDUCED FROM 33% TO 20,
EXCEPT FOR SMALL COUNTIES, WHICH
IS AT 25, ALSO, THE ABILITY TO
TRANSFER FUNDS TO THE PRUDENT
RESERVE FROM ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT LOCAL BUCKETS THAT I
JUST WALKED THROUGH, THE RESERVE
LEVELS MUST BE ADDRESSED DURING
THE THREE YEAR INTEGRATED
PLANNING PROCESS, AND ANY
CHANGES TO COUNTY REQUIREMENTS
THAT MUST BE MET FOR ACCESSING
PRUDENT RESERVE BALANCES WILL BE
DISCUSSED DURING THE REVENUE AND
STABILITY WORKGROUP. THIS
WORKGROUP IS WAS CREATED AS PART
OF HRSA AND IS REALLY BRINGING
TOGETHER, KIND OF COUNTY
PARTNERS TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
LOOK AT REVENUES OVER TIME. PROP
ONE OR PROP THREE, THE
PREDECESSOR REVENUES, YOU KNOW,
UP AND DOWN. GIVEN THAT THE
RELATION TO KIND OF THE TAX AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO UNDERSTAND
THE REVENUE AND PROVIDE SOME
STABILITY TO THE COUNTIES AS
THEY THINK ABOUT THEIR PLANNING,
AND THEN FINALLY WANTED TO NOTE
THE FLEXIBILITY COUNTIES HAVE TO
MOVE DOLLARS BETWEEN THOSE
DIFFERENT BUCKETS THAT I JUST
WALKED THROUGH, 77% FROM ONE
CATEGORY TO ANOTHER FOR A
MAXIMUM UP TO 14, REALLY. AGAIN,
TO ALLOW COUNTIES TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR LOCAL NEEDS ARE AND
DO A LITTLE BIT OF MOVEMENT OF
THOSE DOLLARS, DEPENDING ON THE
DATA AND COMMUNITY INPUT, AND
AGAIN, THOSE CHANGES WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO OUR THE DEPARTMENT'S
APPROVAL AND WOULD BE MADE
DURING THE THREE YEAR PLANNING
PROCESS. SO THERE'S COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF HOW
THOSE DOLLARS WILL BE USED AND
MOVED AROUND. AND THEN FINALLY,
JUST WANTED TO, HIGHLIGHT THAT
AS WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS, YOU
KNOW, A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
WORK, IT'S NEW WORK IN TERMS OF
KIND OF BRINGING TOGETHER MORE
PARTIES, THINKING ABOUT MORE
PROGRAMS, AND THINKING ABOUT
MORE REVENUE SOURCES, THE
ABILITY FOR COUNTIES TO USE
ADDITIONAL TWO AND UP TO 4% FOR
SMALL COUNTIES OF THEIR LOCAL
REVENUE FOR THAT PLANNING WORK,
AND KIND OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE INTEGRATED PLAN, AND SO,
WANT TO JUST KIND OF RECOGNIZE
THIS THIS IS, YOU KNOW, A NEW, A
NEW WORKLOAD FOR PLANNING AND
REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
WORK ON BUILDING OUT THAT
INTEGRATED PLAN. THEN IN TERMS
OF OUR OVERVIEW OF NEW SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES, AS I
MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING, HRSA
IS NOW ALLOWING THESE DOLLARS TO
BE USED FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE SUD ONLY NEEDS. AND AGAIN,
AS I MENTIONED, REALLY WORKING
WITH OUR COUNTIES AND OUR
COUNTIES, REALLY LOOKING AT
THEIR LOCAL DATA, THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT TYPES
OF PROGRAMS THEY NEED TO
DEVELOP. AGAIN, YOU KNOW, MH OR
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE ONLY
CO-OCCURRING TYPE PROGRAMS, ETC.
AND THINKING ABOUT HOW TO PLAN
FOR THAT AS WELL. WANTED TO
PROVIDE JUST A QUICK, HIGH LEVEL
TIMELINE IN TERMS OF THE
GUIDANCE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL BE RELEASING, THERE'S A LOT
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS, A LOT OF
NEW GUIDANCE, AND A LOT OF NEW
DEFINING THAT WE NEED TO DO AND
WORK WITH OUR COUNTIES,
PROVIDERS AND PARTNERS. AS WE
THINK THROUGH THAT, WE'VE
STARTED OUR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS,
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, WE HAD A
PUBLIC LISTENING SESSION SESSION
ON THE BOND. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE AT LEAST
MONTHLY PUBLIC LISTENING
SESSIONS ON BROAD TOPICS IN AS
PART OF H.S.A, WE ANTICIPATE
BOND FUNDING WILL BEGIN IN 2024.
SO IN THE COMING MONTHS, AND
PLANNING TO RELEASE GUIDANCE ON
KIND OF HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
THE ROUNDS AND THE RELEASE OF
THOSE DOLLARS, OUR FIRST KIND OF
BIG POLICY. GUIDANCE THAT WE
PLAN TO RELEASE IS RELATED TO
THE INTEGRATED PLAN, AND WE ARE
PLANNING TO RELEASE THAT IN
EARLY 2025. AND THE IMPORTANCE
FOR THAT IS COUNTIES NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY NEED TO PUT
TOGETHER FOR THEIR INTEGRATED
PLAN THAT STARTS JULY 2026. AND
SO GIVING COUNTIES 18 MONTHS
ADVANCE KIND OF POLICY,
DIRECTION ON WHAT IS INCLUDED IN
THAT PLAN, 18 MONTHS IN ADVANCE
SO THEY CAN START WORKING WITH
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE JULY 2026
COUNTY INTEGRATED PLAN. HOW MANY
ROUNDS FOR THE BONDS ARE WE
ANTICIPATING? WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THAT. AND WE
WILL, YEAH, WE'LL BE RELEASING
INFORMATION THÀNH, SOON ON THAT.
OKAY. WHO ARE THE STAKEHOLDERS
AT THE MEETINGS, LIKE WHAT'S
IDENTIFIED AS A STAKEHOLDER AND
WHO ARE THEY? STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDE OUR COUNTIES, PROVIDERS,
THOSE ADVOCATES, PERSONS WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE, VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS, OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT S HOW DO YOU BECOME A
STAKEHOLDER? IS THAT BY
INVITATION ONLY, WE WILL HAVE
DIFFERENT WORK GROUPS DEPENDING
ON THE TOPIC AT HAND TO REALLY
FIND OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
AND THINK ABOUT WHO NEEDS TO BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS AS WE
THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
KIND OF CATEGORIES, WE WALK
THROUGH ALL THE GUIDANCE THAT'S
NEEDED AS PART OF IT, ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE RIGHT
MEETINGS TO PROVIDE KIND OF THE
EXPERTISE THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR. WHO MAKES THAT
DETERMINATION, WHO THE RIGHT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE. IT'S THROUGH
KIND OF DISCUSSIONS LIKE THESE
AND DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR KIND OF
OUR YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LISTSERV WE'VE
BEEN DOING WITH ALL THE CAL AIM
WORK. WE HAVE KIND OF DIFFERENT
LISTSERVS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN PARTS OF DIFFERENT
WORK GROUPS. SO MY CONCERN IS,
IS THAT WE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON HOMELESSNESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND THAT
THE NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP, AND
NOW WE HAVE THIS NEW DOG, THIS
NEW DOG IN THE FIGHT, THE BOND.
RIGHT. THE BOND THAT THEY BARELY
GOT PASSED AND IT BARELY
APPROVED. AND THERE WAS A
PROMISE THAT WE WOULD NOT BE,
DOING THE STATUS QUO, I GUESS.
SO IF WE'RE STILL PICKING THE
SAME STAKEHOLDERS THAT MADE THE
BAD DECISIONS THAT CAUSED
HOMELESSNESS TO GO UP AFTER
SPENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEFORE, I THINK WE SHOULD
PROBABLY LOOK AT THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS, ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE
INPUT, AND ARE YOU GUYS DOING
THAT? ARE YOU USING THE SAME
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WERE INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS BEFORE TO ADDRESS
THE HOUSING CRISIS OR THE
HOMELESS CRISIS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA? SO THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE MEDI-CAL SPACE, SO I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE HOMELESS OR HOUSING
SPACE, BUT IN THE MEDI-CAL SPACE
WE HAVE, YOU KNOW, THE PARTNERS
ARE IMPLEMENTERS. YOU KNOW, AS
WE DEVELOP POLICY, WE HAVE
WHETHER IT'S THE COUNTIES,
WHETHER IT'S OUR MANAGED CARE
PLANS, THE INDIVIDUALS OR THE
ENTITIES WHO ACTUALLY DELIVER,
KIND OF IMPLEMENT THE POLICY AT
HAND. AND SO THOSE THEY WILL BE
OUR KEY STAKEHOLDERS AS PART OF
THIS, BECAUSE THEY ARE THE KIND
OF THE NEXT LAYER IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THE
POLICY. AND THEN, YOU KNOW, I
THINK WE COULD CONTINUE WOULD
WANT TO HAVE AS MANY INDIVIDUALS
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE AS PART OF
THE CONVERSATION AS WELL TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND, IS THIS GOING
TO MEET YOUR NEED? HOW ARE WE
THINKING ABOUT IT? AND THEN OUR
CONSUMER ADVOCATES, VARIOUS
GROUPS KIND OF REPRESENTING
PROVIDER ASSOCIATIONS AGAIN,
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THEM AS
IMPLEMENTERS OF SOME OF THESE
POLICIES AS WELL. BUT YOU KNOW,
OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS IF THERE ARE
GROUPS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONNECT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. TOBY. ARE ANY IS THE
COMMISSION PART OF THE
STAKEHOLDER? YES WE ARE. AND
I'LL ADD THAT THE COMMISSION
PROVIDES ABOUT $9 MILLION A YEAR
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY VOICES. AND
THOSE FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS. IF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS, WE PROVIDE
A LOT OF LEEWAY FOR THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS TO ELECT HOW TO
USE THOSE FUNDS. THOSE FUNDS
INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS, IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
GROUPS, TRANSITION AGE YOUTH,
LGBT COMMUNITY, REDUCING
DISPARITIES, ETC. AND SO. SO
WHILE WE DON'T DICTATE HOW THEY
PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S REALLY DRIVEN BY, YOU
KNOW, THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED, THOSE FUNDS ARE
ABSOLUTELY AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
THE OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE FORUMS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS STANDING UP, AND
THE COMMISSION IS THERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU. OKAY MADAM DIRECTOR,
I WAS JUST CURIOUS. YOU
MENTIONED THE BOND FUNDING AND
THE FUNDING PROGRAM OR PLAN. CAN
YOU JUST CLARIFY WHAT'S WHAT'S
YOUR CURRENT ESTIMATE FOR THE
ROLLOUT OF THE FUNDING SEQUENCE
AND THEN THE ROLLOUT OF THE
DOLLARS? I REALIZE IT'S A WORK
IN PROGRESS. YES. SO WE WILL BE
COMING OUT. SHORTLY WITH KIND OF
THE KIND OF THE PLAN FOR THE
BOND DOLLARS, WITH KIND OF WHERE
WE ANTICIPATE KIND OF OUR
RELEASES AND WHEN WE ANTICIPATE
MAKING AWARDS, ETC. SO THOSE
THOSE DETAILS WILL BE COMING OUT
SHORTLY, SORT OF LIKE BEADCHIP.
EXACTLY. YES. THANK YOU. AND
MAYBE WITH THAT, I WILL MOVE TO
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BOND
THROUGH BISHOP. OKAY, AS I
MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING, AB
531 CREATED THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE BOND ACT.
SO THIS IS THE $6.38 BILLION
WITH UP TO 4.4 BILLION IN GRANTS
FOR COUNTIES, CITIES, TRIBAL
ENTITIES, NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE
SECTOR, TOWARDS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT SETTINGS. SO
THESE ARE THE TREATMENT DOLLARS,
OF THAT 4.4 BILLION, 1.5 BILLION
WITH 30 MILLION SET ASIDE FOR
TRIBES WILL BE AWARDED THROUGH
GRANTS TO COUNTIES AND CITIES
AND TRIBES, WE HAVE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM. B CHIP IS WE'VE HAD
FIVE ROUNDS OF THAT AND KIND OF
USING THAT AS THE MODEL AS WE
THINK ABOUT, THIS, THESE BOND
DOLLARS DIRECTOR ON THE 4.4
TOTAL. SO THE FIRST POINT SO
NONPROFIT WILL BE ABLE TO
DIRECTLY APPLY WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE COUNTY. YES. THEY
CAN DO TODAY UNDER BISHOP WE DO
REQUIRE A LETTER OF SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT'S INCUMBENT ON KIND
OF THE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SERVICES. SO WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A CONNECTION
WITH THE COUNTY AS WELL. THANK
YOU, YOU REQUIRE A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FROM THE COUNTY.
CORRECT. AND ARE THESE DOLLARS
APPLIED FOR DIRECTLY FROM THE
STATE? YES. THESE. SO ALL OF
THOSE ENTITIES APPLY TO THE
STATE FOR THESE DOLLARS. AND
WE'VE DONE FIVE, FIVE GRAND
ROUNDS OF GRANTS UNDER BISHOP
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. THANK YOU.
AND YOU SAID FIVE ROUNDS OF
GRANTS. IS THAT LIKE FIVE GRANTS
OR FIVE ROUNDS OF ADDITIONAL
LIKE 20 GRANTS IN A ROUND OR
WHATEVER IT IS? YEAH. SO BISHOP
WAS 2.2 BILLION AND WE'VE I,
WE'VE AWARDED I THINK 1.7
BILLION I BELIEVE IN THOSE, IN
THOSE FIVE ROUNDS. SO FIVE
ROUNDS WITH MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
GRANTS AGAIN PROBABLY OFF THE
TOP OF YOUR HEAD. NOT NOT
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
MAY NOT BE ASKED, BUT, OR
CONSIDERED BEING ASKED IS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE 1.7 BILLION THAT
YOU JUST SAID YOU ALLOCATED DID
IT, IS THAT HOW IS THAT DIVIDED
UP LIKE BY CITY BY LOS ANGELES
GOT SO MANY BILLIONS LIKE BY WE
IT'S ALL AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. I DON'T HAVE IT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD, BUT IT'S, WE
HAVE A WEBSITE THAT LISTS EVERY
ROUND, EVERY GRANT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND. Ó. THANK YOU.
SO CURRENTLY, THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE HAVE FOR BISHOP WILL
STAY IN PLACE AND THE BOND
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO GO INTO THE
CURRENT BISHOP INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CONTINUE DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDS
THROUGH THAT ROUTE. YES. AND IF
I COULD ASK. THANKS. I FOUND MY
TRAIN OF THOUGHT WHEN THE TRAIN
WENT BY AND I DIDN'T CATCH THE
CARGO. WHEN YOU'RE SAYING PEOPLE
CAN APPLY DIRECTLY FOR THAT
FUNDING, BUT THAT SHOULD BE DONE
IN ASSOCIATION WITH THE FIRST,
LIKE, LOOK, WE'RE GOING TO DO
ABOUT WHAT WHAT EVERYBODY NEEDS
IN EVERY COUNTY. RIGHT. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT EVERYBODY'S CAPACITY
IS YET IN THE COUNTY. SO HOW IS
IT GOING TO MAN, WILL WE WHEN WE
MAP OUT WHAT CAPACITY IS NEEDED
FOR HOUSING? HOW DOES THAT THEN
FIT WITH THE SEPARATE PROCESS.
SO THESE ARE NOT THESE ARE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
DOLLARS. SO THE HOUSING DOLLARS
ARE AT DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. UNDER OUR
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. SO THE
FOUR POINT THE. YEAH. I THOUGHT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE BOND.
YES. SO THE BOND. SO WHAT BISHOP
IS ONLY DOING THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PIECES OF IT.
NOT DOING THE HOUSING PARTS OF
IT. OKAY, AS ANOTHER PROGRAM BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WILL BE
DOING THE, THE HOUSING RELATED
PIECES OF IT. SO IT'S A 4.4
BILLION OF THE 6.8 TOTAL, ONLY
BEHAVIORAL. CORRECT. BUT THAT'S
STILL WE STILL NEED TO KNOW IF
THE COUNTY NEEDS AS PART OF MÁS
OR AS PART OF BISHOP ROUND TWO
COUNTIES, WERE RECEIVE GRANTS TO
THINK ABOUT THEIR LOCAL
PLANNING. AND THAT'S HOW THEY'VE
ACTUALLY USED THAT INFORMATION
TO THINK ABOUT ROUNDS, THREE
ROUNDS FOUR, ONES FIVE. AND SO
USING SOME OF THAT IN JUST OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF KIND OF WHERE
WE'VE MADE AWARDS, WE HAVE THAT
ALL MAPPED OUT AND KIND OF
THINKING ABOUT WHERE ARE SOME OF
THE NEEDS THAT WE COLLECTIVELY
CAN IDENTIFY. BECAUSE I THINK,
YOU KNOW, JUST TO ECHO WHAT
SENATOR GROVE WAS SAYING, LIKE,
LIKE WE'VE WE'VE DONE A LOT, BUT
WE NEED TO WE NEED MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO KNOW THAT
WE'RE DOING IT ALL WITH A PLAN
AND ACHIEVING THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE ALL WANT. DIRECTOR, I THINK
WE'RE JUMPING AHEAD BECAUSE I
KNOW LATER ON WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT B CHIP A LITTLE
BIT MORE, BUT THAT WAS ACTUALLY
WHAT ONE OF MY QUESTIONS WAS
LIKE, HOW SUCCESSFUL WERE IN
WERE WE IN ROUNDS ONE THROUGH
SIX. BECAUSE THE DEFINITION, YOU
KNOW, THE B CHIP WAS TO ACQUIRE,
CONSTRUCT, REHABILITATE REAL
ESTATE. WE DO. WE HAVE A LIST OF
HOW MANY NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS CAME OUT OF THIS. WAS
THIS ONLY TO REHABILITATE. AND
WE PAINTED WALLS ON PLACES. THIS
WAS ALL NEW CONSTRUCTION, NEW OR
NEW CAPACITY, AND SO WE HAVE A
LIST OF EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW, IT
WAS SUCCESSFUL. IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THUS FAR. I WILL SAY,
YOU KNOW, HAVING EVERYTHING
OPEN, THESE PROJECTS ARE GOING
TO TAKE YEARS TO ACTUALLY BUILD
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT. WE
DID WE HAD, SOME HAVE OPEN, YOU
KNOW, ROUND THREE WERE THE KIND
OF SHOVEL READY PROJECTS LAUNCH
READY, LAUNCH READY. THAT'S A
BETTER WORD, AND SO THOSE WE
HAVE KIND OF, YOU KNOW, SOME
HAVE OPENED AND KIND OF STATUS
ON THOSE AND, BUT THESE DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO TAKE THESE PROJECTS
WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO ACTUALLY
OPEN AND FINISH CONSTRUCTION,
ETC. OKAY. ARE WE LOOKING AT THE
ENTITIES THAT PERHAPS IN ROUND
THREE FORLAUNCH READY OR OTHER
ONES TO SAY, HEY, WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING, WE'RE GOING
TO APPLY NOW FOR THIS ADDITIONAL
BOND MONEY TO FINISH THE PROJECT
THAT WE STARTED IN THE IN THE
PREVIOUS ROUNDS, OR ARE WE
LOOKING TO PRIORITIZE JUST BRAND
NEW? I THINK IT'S I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A PRIORITIZATION. I
THINK IT'S A MATTER OF CAPACITY.
AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK MANY
PROJECTS ARE THINKING ABOUT
CAMPUS STYLE EFFORTS WHERE, YOU
KNOW, ROUND THREE MIGHT HAVE
FUNDED ONE WING, ROUND FOUR
MIGHT FUND ANOTHER WING, THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS, AND THERE MIGHT
BE JUST NEW PROJECTS AS WELL.
AND SO I THINK, THIS WILL BE
PART OF KIND OF THE PROCESS AS
WE THINK THROUGH THE PROGRAM
GUIDANCE. AND AGAIN, SO IN
SCHOOLS THAT WANT TO APPLY FOR
THESE GRANTS OR THINGS THEY
APPLY FOR TO THE STATE, AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A SUPPORT
LETTER FROM THE COUNTY. LIKE FOR
INSTANCE, IN JUST EXAMPLES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TALKED TO ME ABOUT
SINCE PROP ONE HAS COME OUT,
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. ONCE THEY
HAD BOUGHT A PIECE OF PROPERTY
AND THEY WERE WORKING ON
PUTTING, 11 TINY HOMES THERE FOR
JUST VETERANS. IT'S RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM THE VETERANS
SERVICES DEPARTMENT. SO THEY
COULD HAVE, YOU KNOW, WRAPAROUND
SERVICES, AND SO WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO APPLY AS A NONPROFIT TO
THE STATE FOR THOSE RESOURCES.
AND DOES IT AFFECT THE WAY THEY
BUILD THESE TINY HOUSES, UNDER
CONSTRUCTION? THÀNH, I THINK,
AGAIN, IT DEPENDS ON IF IT IS
TRULY JUST A KIND OF IF THERE
ARE SERVICES OR IT'S KIND OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH, WHETHER IT'S
THIS, THIS, BUCKET OF DOLLARS OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, I THINK,
YOU KNOW, PROBABLY HAVE TO HAVE
AN UNDERSTANDING FOR, FOR WHERE,
WHAT KIND OF BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH TREATMENT. SO
THE GROUPS THAT I'M WORKING WITH
AND THE PEOPLE, THE NONPROFITS
THAT I'M TRYING TO HELP GET
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
WE HAVE FAILED OUR VETERAN
COMMUNITY THUS FAR. THESE PEOPLE
ARE PART OF THE VETERAN SERVICES
GROUP THAT ARE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT, THAT ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN, AND IT'S PLACING THESE
PLACES TO LIVE. SO THERE'S A
HOUSING PROCESS AROUND OR NEXT
TO MEDICAL CLINICS THAT SERVICE
VETERANS, LIKE THE VETERANS. THE
VETERANS SERVICES DEPARTMENT OR
THE, THE HOSPITAL RIGHT THERE
THAT GETS THAT IS AUTHORIZED TO
TREAT VETERANS AND VETERAN
SERVICES, SO THEY DO HAVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES, AND THEY
CAN JUST WALK ACROSS THE STREET
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO NAVIGATE A
BUS SYSTEM OR A TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. THERE'S A CROSSWALK THAT
THEY PUT IN PLACE THAT'S LIKE
FOR, YOU KNOW, IT'S FOR
CROSSWALKS WIDE, LIKE FOR
WHEELCHAIRS AND ALL THAT STUFF.
PLUS THEY HAVE THE ORDERLIES
THAT WILL COME OUT AND GET THEM
AND TAKE THEM THERE. AND THEY
HAVE ANOTHER PIECE OF PROPERTY
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT.
BUT IT'S A NONPROFIT. IT'S
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY, AND THEY
ARE SPONSORED BY THE VETERANS.
AND THEY JUST THEY'RE DOING
THEIR BEST TO BUILD, AND THEY'RE
PROBABLY HOUSING MORE VETERANS
THAN THE STATE HAS. I'M JUST
BEING HONEST. I'M VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH THE MONEY THAT
WE'VE SPENT IN. VETERANS ARE
STILL ON THE STREET. SO MY
QUESTION IS, IS THAT THIS WOULD
BE A BRAND NEW ENTITY WITH A
SUCCESS RATE BEHIND THEM, AND
THEY CAN APPLY TO THE STATE FOR
THESE DOLLARS, AND THEY'RE NOT
RESTRICTED FROM APPLYING. THEY
JUST HAVE A HAVE TO HAVE, THE
APPLICATION FILLED OUT AND A
SUPPORT LETTER FROM THE COUNTY
WHO IS VERY SUPPORTIVE. DOES
THAT MAKE SENSE? I MEAN,
GENERALLY SPEAKING, YES, THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY. I CAN'T
LIKE, YOU KNOW, NO, I SPECULATE
IN TERMS OF WHO WOULD GET A
GRANT, ETC. BUT YEAH, I MEAN
THAT'S IN THE WHO DETERMINES WHO
GETS THE MONEY AND IS THERE A IS
THERE A IS THERE A STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURE SO THAT IT'S
JUST OBJECTIVE FINDINGS AND NOT
SUBJECTIVE FINDINGS ON WHO GETS
THE GRANT, LIKE, YES, THERE'S
CRITERIA BY WHICH ALL OF THE
APPLICANTS ARE CONSIDERED FOR
SURE. OKAY. HOW DO YOU GET A
COPY OF THAT CRITERIA, I MEAN,
WE CAN SHARE KIND OF THE
FRAMEWORK FOR, FOR THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU. YOU CAN SHARE THE
FRAMEWORK, BUT THERE'S NO
CRITERIA ANYWHERE ON A WEBSITE I
CAN FIND. I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK
ON THAT. OKAY. THANK YOU.
GENERAL ROTH IS UP. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT. BUT, MADAM DIRECTOR, I
JUST WANT TO, YOU KNOW, I'M SORT
OF A COMMAND AND CONTROL KIND OF
GUY, AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE HAVING THE
SIDEBAR HERE, SO I'LL LET THEM
FINISH. IT IS MY CHAIR. SHE CAN
TALK ANYTIME SHE WANTS, I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
SOME CONTROL OVER THIS PROCESS.
AND YOU, YOU SPOKE ABOUT A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM THE
COUNTY. I ASSUME THAT EVEN
THOUGH SUBJECT TO BEING
CORRECTED, THAT EVEN THOUGH
UNDER THIS NEW PROCESS,
APPLICATIONS CAN COME IN FROM A
VARIETY OF DIRECTIONS, NOT
NECESSARILY FUNNELED THROUGH THE
COUNTY, THAT THE APPLICATIONS
WILL BE VIEWED AND EVALUATED IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE PLAN THAT THE
COUNTY DEVELOPS BASED ON THE
NEEDS IN THE COUNTY. SO THE IF
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
INTEGRATED PLAN, I'M REFERRING
TO THE BOND, THE BOND FUNDING
RIGHT NOW FOR THE, IN TERMS OF
THE PLAN THAT YOU JUST
REFERENCED, ARE YOU REFERRING TO
THE INTEGRATED PLAN? THAT'S PART
OF KIND OF THE BEHAVIORAL BOND?
I'M NOT. IS THAT INCLUDED IN THE
THREE YEAR INTEGRATED PLAN? THEY
HAVE TO INCLUDE THEIR FUNDING ON
BONDS AS WELL. SO I THINK THE
GOAL FOR US IS TO RELEASE THE
BOND DOLLARS BEFORE BEFORE THE
INTEGRATED PLAN IS AVAILABLE,
BECAUSE THE INTEGRATED PLAN
ISN'T DUE TO THE STATE IN 2022.
JULY 2026. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, GIVEN THE URGENCY OF
REALLY THE NEED FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FACILITIES,
WANTING TO ACTUALLY WORK ON THE
BOND MORE QUICKLY THAN, THAN
JULY 2020. WELL, REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THE TITLE OF THE COUNTY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS, SINCE THE
COUNTIES ARE GENERALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DELIVERY OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES, AT
LEAST AT THE, YOU KNOW, THE
SERIOUS LEVEL AND IN THE COUNTY,
I ASSUME THAT WE EXPECT THE
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP SORT OF A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT BASED ON THE
PARTICULAR NEEDS OF EACH OF THE
58 COUNTIES, AND THAT THESE
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE COMING TO
YOU FROM OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY,
BECAUSE THERE'S A NEED FOR A
COUNTY LETTER OF SUPPORT, THAT
THE COUNTY HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN ON WHETHER TO TRIAGE
THE PROJECTS AND THE NEEDS FOR
THE PROJECTS THAT THE COUNTY,
THE COUNTY, IN TERMS OF IF THEY
IF THEY WANT TO COMMUNICATE THAT
TO THE DEPARTMENT OR IF THEY
WANT TO KIND OF SAY, YOU KNOW,
THIS COUNTY MAY NOT HAVE OR THIS
PROJECT MAY NOT HAVE THE
SUPPORT. I KNOW, MICHELLE, IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT AS
WELL. BUT MY CONCERN IS YOU HAVE
PRIVATE SO YOU HAVE NONPROFIT
PROFIT TAX STATUS, YOU HAVE
PRIVATE OPERATORS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SUBMITTING APPLICATIONS
FOR PROGRAMS. AND THE COUNTY MAY
LOOK AT THEM AND SAY, WELL, WE
ALREADY HAVE 55 OF THOSE BEDS OR
55 OF THOSE FACILITIES THAT WE
FUNDED THROUGH STATE MONEY OR
HOWEVER THEY GOT THE MONEY. WE
DON'T REALLY NEED THAT. WHAT WE
REALLY NEED IS 35 OF THESE BEDS,
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT'S BEING
APPLIED FOR. HOW IS THAT
COMMUNICATED? AND HOW IS THAT
HANDLED AT THE STATE LEVEL,
GIVEN THE FACT THAT PROP ONE IS
PROBABLY I MAY BE EXAGGERATING,
BUT A ONCE IN A GENERATION
GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO ON
THE BOND SIDE, SITE SOME
TREATMENT FACILITIES OF ALL
SORTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
THAT THE COUNTY WOULD THEN NOT
SUBMIT A LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR
THAT PROJECT, AND THAT WOULD
WHAT, TERMINATE THE
CONSIDERATION AT THAT POINT, WE
I MEAN, WE REQUIRE A LETTER OF
SUPPORT. SO, YEAH, THAT'S JUST
I'M NOT BEING CRITICAL. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE THE COUNTIES
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
INCOMING INCOMING TO YOU AND
SAY, WELL, THAT DOESN'T FIT
WITHIN OUR PLAN. I REALIZE
SOMEBODY WANTS TO RUN THAT
BUSINESS AND OPERATE IT. AND
THEY'RE THEY FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THE VALUE OF IT. BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE OTHER VALUES THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE ADDRESSED. RIGHT
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT SPECIFIC? I
THINK IT'S, FAIR TO SAY THAT,
YES, COUNTIES, DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE B CHIP
PROGRAM, WHICH IS ONLY THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES TO SUBMIT A LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR ANY OUTSIDE
APPLICANTS. HOWEVER, CURRENTLY,
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INSIGHT
INTO HOW THOSE DECISIONS ARE
ULTIMATELY MADE. AND THE
CONSIDERATION ABOUT THE
CONTINUUM AS A WHOLE AND HOW IT
TIES BACK TO THE OTHER
PRIORITIES THERE, IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE MAY BE ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN BETTER
COORDINATING AND COMMUNICATING
WHAT THE ULTIMATE DECISIONS ARE,
BECAUSE THERE IS A SYSTEMS FLOW
DYNAMIC TO THIS, WHERE YOU NEED
STEP DOWN, YOU NEED ACUTE
LEVELS, YOU NEED KIND OF
OUTPATIENT. AND WHEN ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE WORKING REALLY
WELL, PEOPLE DON'T GET STUCK IN
BOTTLENECKS IN THE SYSTEM. OKAY.
THANK YOU. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION. OKAY. JUST
CONFIRMING I THINK WE'VE GOTTEN
ALL THE I ACTUALLY HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE WORKFORCE PART,
3% TO HCAI, THIS IS FOR THE HCAI
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE. SO THERE'S I THINK
TWO COMPONENTS. AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE HERE, BUT
THEY HAVE A COMPONENT. AND THEN
SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS WILL THEN
BE USED, AS PART OF THE MATCH
FOR THE CONNECT, 2.4 BILLION
THAT WE'RE GETTING WITH REGARD
TO THE WORKFORCE, ON THE KIND OF
THE MEDICAID SIDE. SO SOME OF
THOSE DOLLARS WILL BE USED AS
THE MATCH FOR OUR BE CONNECT
WORKFORCE. AND THEN HCAI HAS
ANOTHER KIND OF WORKFORCE
COMPONENT AS WELL. YES. YOU
KNOW, IN THE AGENDA BACKGROUND
ON IT'S APPROXIMATELY 105
MILLION ANNUALLY TO IMPLEMENT A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE. IT'S YOU KNOW, TO
RETAIN THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
WORKFORCE AND RURAL AREAS TO
INCREASE RACIAL, ETHNIC, AND
LINGUISTIC DIVERSITY. I'M
WONDERING IF WE'RE GOING TO
RECREATE THE WHEEL, BECAUSE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS HEARD SEVERAL
PRESENTATIONS TO DELAY
BEHAVIORAL WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES. AND ARE WE GOING TO
FUND TO START A BRAND NEW
PROJECT WHERE WE'VE HAD
INITIATIVES IN PLACE THAT ARE
BEING DELAYED, OR ARE WE JUST
GOING TO UTILIZE THIS MONEY TO
THEN SUPPLEMENT THE CURRENT
INITIATIVES THAT ARE IN PLACE
AND JUST STREAM THE DOLLARS
THROUGH THOSE SO WE CAN CHECK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND INFORMATION. I
THINK, YOU KNOW, THE GOAL WOULD
BE TO REALLY TO GET THESE
DOLLARS OUT BECAUSE WE KNOW WE
NEED TO DEVELOP THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE. AND I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE KIND OF WORKING
THROUGH THOSE DETAILS BECAUSE WE
HAVE WE'VE RECEIVED A LOT OF
APPLICATIONS FOR THOSE OF THEM,
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN, FOR THE
PREVIOUS BEHAVIORAL WORKFORCE,
THAT WE'VE HAD A DELAY. SO WE
HAVE APPLICATIONS IN QUEUE. I
WOULDN'T WANT US TO SPEND MONEY
ON CREATING A WHOLE NEW
INITIATIVE WHEN WE HAVE THOSE
READY TO GO AND JUST FUND THEM
AND LET AND PICK THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY IN QUEUE. BUT IT'S SO
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE, TO TRY
TO NOT ADD BUREAUCRACY FURTHER.
BUREAUCRACY. RIGHT? SO YES,
DIRECTOR, IF WE CAN GET IF YOU
CAN GET BACK TO US ON THAT, ON
THAT PART. AND I THINK THAT IS
IT. ON QUESTIONS FOR YOU, WE'LL
NOW MOVE ON TO C. YEAH. CDF NO
JUST KIDDING. NOT TOBY YOU
DOCTOR TOMAS. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS. I'M DOCTOR THOMAS
ARAGON. STATE HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. I'M
GOING TO MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS, AND THEN I'M GOING TO
HAND IT OVER TO KATIE.
ROSENQVIST IS GOING TO GO INTO
MORE DETAILS OF OUR COMPONENT.
SO WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS. B B B H.S.A, OPPORTUNITY
TO FOCUS ON PRIMARY PREVENTION
AND HEALTH IMPROVEMENT IN THIS
AREA. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR US
IN PUBLIC HEALTH, THIS IS AN
EMERGING AREA. IT'S VERY NEW
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA HERE
IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF ADVANCING
PREVENTION OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
DATA EXPERTS AND COMMUNITY
PRACTICE. PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE IMPACTS
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND TRAUMA,
AND WHY PREVENTION IS SO
IMPORTANT. DRUG OVERDOSE,
ALCOHOL RELATED CONDITIONS,
SUICIDE, HOMICIDE, AND MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS CONTRIBUTE
DIRECTLY TO MORTALITY MORBIDITY
THROUGH PREMATURE DEATH,
HOSPITALIZATION, AND YEARS LIVED
WITH DISABILITY. EXPOSURE TO
TRAUMA AND TOXIC. TOXIC STRESS
CAN HAVE LONG TERM IMPACTS ON
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT, RISK BEHAVIOR
, AS WELL AS MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH THROUGHOUT LIFE AND
ACROSS GENERATIONS. STRUCTURAL
INEQUITIES AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS, INCLUDING
EXPERIENCES OF RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION, CAN INCREASE
EXPOSURE TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND REDUCE ACCESS TO
SUPPORTIVE ASSETS AND SERVICES.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND POPULATION
HEALTH. POPULATION BASED
PREVENTION FOCUSES ON PRETERM
ACTIVELY ADDRESSING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS BY REDUCING
EXPOSURES TO RISK FACTORS AND
INCREASING PROTECTIVE FACTORS
THROUGH UPSTREAM AND EARLY LIFE
COURSE STRATEGIES TO PROMOTE
MENTAL HEALTH, WELL-BEING,
FOSTER HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES,
AND SUPPORT LIFELONG MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL RESILIENCE AND
WELL-BEING. EXAMPLES OF
PREVENTION INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
HEALTH, EDUCATION, AND PROMOTION
CAMPAIGNS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY RESPONSIVE,
AND AIMED AT INCREASING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT, REDUCING
STIGMA, AND BUILDING
UNDERSTANDING AND AWARENESS
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES AND HEALTHY
COPING STRATEGIES. OTHER
EXAMPLES ARE GOING TO BE
POLICIES THAT REDUCE ACCESS TO,
ILLEGAL DRUGS TO YOUTH AND
ADOLESCENTS WHOSE BRAIN IS
UNDERGOING, CONTINUOUS
DEVELOPMENT, EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS THAT RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS
OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND OTHER
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES ON YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH, LEARNING AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT. SO
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO BE MOVING
INTO THIS SPACE. IT'S A VERY
IT'S A VERY NEW AREA. I'M GOING
TO HAND IT OVER TO KATIE, WHO'S
GOING TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL OF
HOW THIS CONNECTS WITH THE
PROPOSITION. AND BILL. GREAT.
THANK YOU, THOMAS, AND THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, THE GSA STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS MANDATE THAT A
MINIMUM OF 4% OF THE TOTAL HSA
FUNDS ALLOCATED BE MANAGED
STATEWIDE BY CDF FOR STRATEGIC,
COORDINATED AND STATEWIDE
POPULATION BASED MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THESE
FUNDS, 51, WILL BE RESERVED FOR
PROGRAMS ADDRESSING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PREVENTION FOR
POPULATIONS WHO ARE 25 YEARS OR
YOUNGER. THE STATUTORY STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS ALSO OUTLINE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS SHOULD ENCOMPASS
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES OR
PROMISING COMMUNITY DEFINED
EVIDENCE PRACTICES, AND MEET ONE
OF THE FOLLOWING BENEFIT THE
ENTIRE POPULATION OF THE STATE,
COUNTY, OR PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
SERVE I SERVE IDENTIFIED
POPULATIONS AT ELEVATED RISK FOR
A MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. AIM TO REDUCE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH SEEKING HELP OR
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. SERVE
POPULATIONS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION. AND FINALLY
PREVENT SUICIDE, SELF-HARM, OR
OVERDOSE. BèC ALSO STIPULATES
SCHOOL BASED PREVENTION,
SUPPORTS AND PROGRAMS AND EARLY
CHILDHOOD POPULATION BASED
PREVENTION PROGRAMS SHALL BE
PROVIDED. SHOULD BE EXCUSE ME,
SHALL BE PROVIDED IN A RANGE OF
SETTINGS. IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL
POPULATION BASED PREVENTION
PROGRAMS MAY BE STATEWIDE OR IN
COMMUNITIES IN A COMMUNITY
SETTING, AND FUNDING SHOULD ALSO
BE USED TO STRENGTHEN POPULATION
BASED STRATEGIES AND NOT BE USED
FOR EARLY INTERVENTION.
DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES OR TREATMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS, OR SUPPLANT
FUNDING FOR SERVICES OR SUPPORTS
PROVIDED BY CURRENT INITIATIVES.
CDF WILL COLLABORATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND I'LL SAY THE OAC
HERE, BUT REFERRED TO IN STATUTE
AS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OVERALL
BèC INITIATIVE. SO THOSE ARE THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. THE CDF
BèC INITIATIVE INVOLVES A ROBUST
PLANNING PROCESS, INCLUDING
RESEARCH, STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH DIVERSE PARTNERS
TO DEVELOP SUSTAINABLE AND
IMPACTFUL STRATEGIES. INITIAL
FOCUS WILL BE ON ENGAGEMENT AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING THROUGHOUT
2024, TRANSITIONING TO
OPERATIONAL PLANNING IN 2025. IN
ORDER TO PREPARE FOR THE JULY
2026 IMPLEMENTATION, BUT QUICK
QUESTION. YEAH, HAS CDF NEVER
ENGAGED WITH STAKEHOLDERS BEFORE
THAT? WE HAVE A ROBUST
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS NEEDED
AND DO WE NEED TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AGAIN, WE ENGAGE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS FOR MANY OF
OUR PROGRAMS AND WORK. THIS IS
MHSA. WE'VE HAD ONE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY INVOLVED IN THE
MHSA FUNDS BEFORE THE HSA ACT,
AND WE HAVE MANY PARTNERS AND
WORK GROUPS AND COMMITTEES THAT
WE CAN BE CONVENING WITH ABOUT
THIS. BUT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
VERY FOCUSED WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY. SO THE SAME. I
WOULD I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHY WE HAVE TO DO THIS EVERY
SINGLE TIME. SO I'M JUST LIKE IS
WE CAN'T LOOK AT YEAH. SO MAYBE
THE OTHER STUDIES WE'VE DONE.
YEAH. SO MAYBE I'LL MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ON THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT. THERE'S SORT OF
THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS IS
BECAUSE BECAUSE SOME OF THE
PREVENTION DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
BE COMING TO THE STATE, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE REIMAGINING
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT REIMAGINING, WE
DO HAVE TO ENGAGE THE LOCALS,
PEOPLE WHO CURRENTLY ARE
PROVIDING SOME PREVENTION
SERVICES. WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT ARE WHAT ARE THEY DOING
THAT WE MAY WANT TO REPLICATE
AND SCALE AND GO AND GO BROADER,
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO BE THE,
THE ONE OF THE MAJOR REASONS,
THE OTHER MAJOR REASON WE WANT
TO WE WANT TO FOCUS ON IS THAT,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DOLLARS
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
SEVERELY MENTAL ILL OR ON THE
COURSE TO MENTAL ILLNESS. WE'RE
NOW TRYING TO MOVE UPSTREAM AND
FOCUS ON PRIMARY PREVENTION.
THAT'S A BIG SPACE THAT AND
THAT'S GOING TO THAT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE US TO REALLY GET
EVERYBODY TOGETHER AND SAY OF
THESE EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES
THAT WE THINK WE THINK ARE
REALLY GOING TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
ON BEHAVIORAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
MENTAL HEALTH ACROSS ACROSS THE
STATE. WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
PRIORITIZE, GUYS? AND THEN HOW
CAN WE HOW CAN WE WORK WITH HOW
CAN WE WORK WITH LOCALS SO THAT
THEY CAN SELECT FROM THAT AND
THEN THE OTHER THING WE WANT TO
DO ALSO IS THAT BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT PROBABLY THE NEED
IS MORE THAN THE RESOURCES WE
CURRENTLY HAVE, WE REALLY WANT
TO MOBILIZE AND INSPIRE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS, OTHER INSTITUTIONS
TO INVEST IN THIS AREA,
ESPECIALLY WITH EMERGING
RESEARCH THAT'S JUST COMING OUT
ON EARLY LIFE RISK FACTORS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THE WORD OUT. WE HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE IMPLEMENTING IT, I
HOPE THAT I HOPE THAT SO I FEEL
LIKE WE DO HAVE TO DO BECAUSE
THIS REALLY IS A NEW SPACE. WE
DON'T WANT TO JUST ASSUME WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT THE OLD WAY. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE BRING
EVERYBODY ALONG SO WE GET
EVERYBODY'S INPUT AND WE'RE
BRINGING NEW PEOPLE IN. THAT'S
WHAT YOU SAID YOU'RE BRINGING.
WE'RE BRINGING IN NEW PEOPLE WHO
PERHAPS FOCUS ON MORE
PREVENTATIVE VERSUS REACTIVE.
YES, BECAUSE YEAH. AND A GREAT
EXAMPLE I'LL JUST GIVE A REALLY
CONCRETE EXAMPLE. SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF YOU WANT TO PREVENT IF YOU
WANT TO FOCUS ON HEART DISEASE,
HEART DISEASE IN A CLINICAL
SETTING IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
FOCUSING ON HEART DISEASE AND
PRIMARY PREVENTION BECAUSE THERE
IT'S ABOUT NUTRITION PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY, REDUCING STRESS, BEING
OUTDOORS. AND SO IN ORDER
BECAUSE WE'RE MOVING INTO THAT
SPACE, WE NEED WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ENGAGE AS MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. SO THAT WE PICK
THE RIGHT THINGS. WE DON'T WANT
TO END UP WHERE WE ENDED UP
BEFORE, WHERE WE END UP SPENDING
A LOT OF MONEY AND NOT HAVING
IMPACT. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE DEEPEST RESPECT FOR YOU,
DOCTOR. ARGONNE, YOUR, YOU'RE A
DOER, LIKE, I MEAN, IF THEY WERE
GOING TO MAKE A DOER COMMERCIAL,
YOU'RE THE GUY THAT NEEDS TO BE
ON IT BECAUSE YOU'RE A DOER AND
YOU GET THINGS DONE. I, AND
YOU'RE VERY RESPONSIVE. I JUST
HAVE THE SAME QUESTION I ASKED
THE DIRECTOR. WHAT'S THE PROCESS
? AND IS THERE A PROCESS ON THE
WEBSITE, OR IS IT IN THE WORKS
NOW? AND HOW DO YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PROCESS? SO THOSE NEW
PEOPLE, THAT HAVE THESE
PHENOMENAL IDEAS THAT ARE
SOLVING PROBLEMS EVERY DAY
WITHOUT THE STATE'S HELP, CAN
GET STATE'S HELP SO THEY CAN
SOLVE MORE PROBLEMS. IS THERE A
PROCESS AND IS THAT PROCESS
AVAILABLE ONLINE? NO, WE HAVEN'T
WE HAVEN'T DEVELOPED THAT
PROCESS NOW JUST BECAUSE WE ARE
MOVING INTO THIS THIS CONCEPT OF
POPULATION BASED INTERVENTION,
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT HAS TO BE
DONE. WE HAVE TO CO-DESIGN WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MONEY IS GOING TO
HAVE TO FLOW LOCALLY. BUT WE
HAVE TO SORT OF FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE BEST,
BEST WAY TO BEST WAY TO DO THAT.
OKAY. AND THEN AS PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS
THAT ARE EXCITED ABOUT BECAUSE,
I MEAN, I WENT AND TOLD THEM
THEY PROMISED ME THEY WEREN'T
GOING TO THROW THIS MONEY AWAY.
THEY PROMISED ME IT WAS GOING TO
BE USED VERY WISELY. THEY
PROMISED ME THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO USE EVERY DOLLAR WISELY. WE
WOULDN'T HEAR ABOUT ANY $2
BILLION PROGRAMS WHERE SIX
PEOPLE WERE MOVED OFF THE
STREET. NONE OF THAT. NO MORE,
AND THESE NEW THESE IDEAS WERE
IT'S ACTUALLY WORKED IN THE
COMMUNITY. LIKE I SAID, I MEAN,
IT SEEMS SIMPLE TO ME THAT THE
STATE WOULD PUT, YOU KNOW, BUY A
HOTEL WITH 300 ROOMS AND PUT IT
RIGHT NEXT TO THE WILTSHIRE
VETERANS HOSPITAL. THAT SEEMS A
LOT LESS EXPENSIVE THAN, YOU
KNOW, PUTTING THEM ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF LOS ANGELES AND
TRANSPORTING THEM BY BUS. IF
THEY CAN EVEN GET THERE. I MEAN,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
MEETING, THE NEEDS OF THE LIVED,
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE ON THE
STREET, I THINK THAT WOULD BE A
THING THAT VETERANS WOULD TELL
YOU. WELL, I LIVE 26 MILES AWAY
FROM THE HOSPITAL IN LOS
ANGELES, AND, IT'S HARD TO GET
THERE. AND THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE BUILDING HOUSES,
MONNING AND APARTMENTS AND
TAKING OVER APARTMENTS AND
HOTELS. RIGHT NEXT TO VETERANS
FACILITIES. AND THAT'S WORKING
MUCH BETTER. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS, HOW DO THOSE PEOPLE
THAT YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW OR
DON'T ENGAGE IN, THEY'RE NOT
YOUR REGULAR TYPICAL PEOPLE THAT
PARTICIPATE AS YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS. HOW DO THEY GET
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS? YEAH,
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD THE WAY,
YOU KNOW, I THINK ABOUT IT. I'M
GOING TO KATIE, KATIE. HAS THE
DETAILS, BUT I'LL GO AHEAD AND
I'M GOING TO JUST REFLECT ON,
YOU KNOW, WHAT WE DID WITH COVID
IS THAT WE IT BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THE STATE'S SO LARGE, WE USUALLY
GO THROUGH THE CBOS AND CBOS AND
ASSOCIATIONS THAT REPRESENT
THOSE COMMUNITIES, AND WE WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH THEM. AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING REALLY CLOSELY
WITH THEM AROUND MANY, MANY
OTHER ISSUES, AND SO WE HAVE WE
HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE. THE TOPIC
AREA FOR US HERE IS NEW. AND SO
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO GET THIS
RIGHT AND WE'LL BASE IT OFF OUR,
OUR OUR EARLY EXPERIENCE. THE
OTHER THING I JUST WANT TO ADD
IS THAT SO THE POPULATION THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING RIGHT NOW, SO
PRIMARY PREVENTION APPLIES TO
EVERYONE INCLUDING US. RIGHT.
BUT AND IT ALSO APPLIES TO THEM
AS WELL. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ONE CONDITION, BUT WE WANT TO
STILL REACH YOU SOMEHOW BECAUSE
WE DON'T WANT WE WANT TO PREVENT
YOU FROM DEVELOPING ANOTHER
CONDITION. AND SO AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES OF PRIMARY
PREVENTION, IS THAT IT APPLIES
TO EVERYBODY, WHETHER YOU HAVE
WHETHER YOU'RE CURRENTLY ILL OR
NOT. SO I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
RESTRICTED DOLLARS TOO, BECAUSE
WE HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY
THAT HAS TREATS A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON THE STREET, AND WHEN THEY
COME INTO THE MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY, THE DOCTOR IS ALLOWED
UNDER STATE RESOURCES WHERE THEY
FILL OUT THE CODE SECTION TO
APPLY FOR DOLLARS, THAT
INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY'RE
TREATING, THEY CAN TREAT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH, BUT THEY CAN'T
TREAT THE GAPING GANGRENE WOUND.
THEY HAVE TO SEND THEM TO KERN
MEDICAL CENTER. SO IS THERE
GOING TO BE RESTRICTED DOLLARS,
OR ARE MEDICAL PROVIDERS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO TREAT THE WHOLE
PERSON? IN THIS SITUATION, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT TREATMENT, I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION. I'LL HAVE TO. THAT'S
OKAY. I MAY BE ASKING THE WRONG
PERSON. YEAH. JUST YOU BROUGHT
UP SOMETHING. IT MADE ME THINK
OF THAT. SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT AGAIN, IT JUST TO
TREAT THE WHOLE PERSON I, I
COMPLETELY AGREE. I THINK WE, WE
YEAH. THE MIND AND THE BODY.
UNFORTUNATELY, FOR REASONS THAT
I DON'T COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND,
WE TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY. BUT
THEY REALLY EVERY EVERYTHING IS
CONNECTED AND WE'RE MOVING MORE
IN THAT WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THIS WHOLE PROP ONE.
RIGHT. WE'RE TRYING TO EXACTLY,
EXACTLY INTEGRATE EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU AGAIN.
I'LL I'LL TURN IT BACK TO I
THINK I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE THING, JUST IN REGARDS TO
KIND OF BRINGING STAKEHOLDERS
THAT AREN'T NORMALLY PART OF THE
CONVERSATION, THAT IS THE WHOLE
GOAL WITH THE COUNTY INTEGRATED
PLAN. AND VETERANS ARE A
REQUIRED STAKEHOLDER GROUP AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO BUILD THAT
PLAN OUT. SO WHILE THE STATE
ALSO WELCOMES, YOU KNOW, NEW
VOICES, NEW GROUPS, I THINK IT'S
ALSO REALLY IMPORTANT THAT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT HAPPENS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE LOCAL
DOLLARS ACTUALLY GET ALLOCATED.
AND SO THE KIND OF THE KIND OF
THAT PARTNERSHIP AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND REALLY HAVING VETERANS
BE PART OF THAT LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS WHERE, YOU KNOW, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THESE, THE BèC
DOLLARS WILL BE ALLOCATED, I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT AS
WELL. THANK YOU. YEAH, SO JUST
CONTINUING WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT KEY PARTNERS. SO CDF WILL
WORK WITH LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ACADEMIC PARTNERS, YOUTH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS,
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO ENSURE A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF PERSPECTIVES.
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS WILL INCLUDE
CONDUCTING A LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS
OF EXISTING EFFORTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PREVENTION.
ALSO RECOGNIZING EXISTING
PREVENTION EFFORTS THROUGH MHC,
WHICH INCLUDES. THIS WILL
INCLUDE LISTENING SESSIONS,
MEETINGS, AND KEY INFORMANT
INTERVIEWS. CDF WILL BE
COORDINATING WITH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AND CAN PROVIDE MORE UPDATES
THROUGH THEM AS REQUESTED, AS
WELL BY LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS.
CDF IS ENGAGEMENT PLAN ALSO
INCLUDES LEARNING FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED WITH
EXISTING INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT, ALSO REFERRED TO AS
CRDP. LEVERAGING THE EXPERIENCE
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM CRDP
INITIATIVES TO ENHANCE THE
EFFECTIVENESS, INCLUSIVITY AND
INCLUSIVITY OF CURRENT AND
FUTURE PREVENTION PROGRAMS, THE
CRDP HAS LEARNINGS FROM THE
PROJECT, INCLUDING ITS
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT DESCRIBED
DESCRIBING THE EVALUATION OF
PHASE TWO AND AN UPCOMING PHASE
THREE REPORT, WHICH WILL BOTH
PROVIDE KEY INSIGHTS TO HELP
INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFICALLY OF THE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES. CDF VALUES THE
INSIGHTS, EXPERIENCES AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF A WIDE RANGE OF
PARTNERS. BY PARTNERING WITH
EXPERTS AND LEVERAGING THE
COMMUNITY AND YOUTH VOICE, CDF
IS PRIMARY GOAL IS TO IMPLEMENT
PREVENTION STRATEGIES THAT ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. AND AS WE WERE
ALLUDING TO, WE'RE BEGINNING
ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES AND WILL
CONTINUE IN A PHASED APPROACH
THROUGHOUT 2024. AND THE PROCESS
WILL BE ITERATIVE. IT WILL BE
INVOLVING CONTINUOUS DIALOG WITH
PARTNERS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS. WE'RE GOING
TO BE MOVING ON NOW TO MR. TOBY.
PROBABLY THE MOST DIFFICULT PART
OF MY TESTIMONY TODAY IS, MAKING
THE POWERPOINT WORK. I HOPE SO,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF THE, THE COMMISSION,
WHOSE NAME WE'RE STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COMMISSION, THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION, THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION, TOBY EWING,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. THANK YOU
FOR THE CHANCE TO JOIN YOU TODAY
, DIRECTOR BOSS IS VERY
GENEROUSLY OFFERED TO HELP WITH
THE POWERPOINT BECAUSE TALKING,
THINKING AND CLICKING IS
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY IS A
WOMAN OF MANY TRAITS. SHE IS
VERY TALENTED AND I HAVE SUCH
RESPECT, SO REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CHANCE TO JOIN YOU. YOU
KNOW, I WE WANT TO COVER A
COUPLE OF VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT ARE LISTED IN, IN
THE COMMITTEE'S, QUESTIONS THAT
CAME TO US THROUGH THE STAFF.
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF, FOR
THIS WORK, GENERALLY, PROP ONE
MAKES TWO FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES
FOR THE COMMISSION THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANT. IT, THE OTHER
CHANGES ARE MORE SORT OF TONAL
SHIFTS WHERE THE COMMISSION'S
ROLE IS CONSISTENT WITH THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW WE DO THAT, AND WE'RE WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PROP ONE
CREATES FOR THE STATE AS WE
THINK ABOUT MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT, AS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED, WE HAVE NOT BEEN AS
EFFECTIVE IN ADDRESSING AS WE'D
LIKE TO. SO I WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE TWO ON SORT OF THE PRIMARY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HAS
ASKED, A VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
FROM AN OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
IS THE MAKEUP OF THE COMMISSION
ITSELF THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
WHERE THE SUBSTANCE IS IN TERMS
OF HOW WE DRIVE TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE, BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT BRINGS SOME
ADDITIONAL VOICES TO THIS BODY
AS WE MOVE FORWARD, SO THANK
YOU, SO CURRENTLY UNDER THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT, THE
COMMISSION HAS 16 COMMISSIONERS
AND THE MEMBERSHIP WAS REALLY
DESIGNED TO START WITH CONSUMERS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS AND PROVIDERS
AND TO BRING WITH THEM
COMMISSIONERS WHO REPRESENT
PUBLIC SAFETY, EDUCATION,
NATION, EMPLOYERS AND LABOR, AS
WELL AS THE TWO CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, AS WELL AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY, THE BALLOT MEASURE
ADDED 11 NEW SEATS TO THE
COMMISSION. SO WE'RE GROWING
FROM 16 TO 27. AND I APPRECIATE
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM SOME
ON THE COMMITTEE TEAM ABOUT HOW
IN THE WORLD WE'RE GOING TO FIND
A SPACE, SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE WE
WILL MAKE THAT HAPPEN, THE NEW
ROLES REALLY EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF VOICES WHO ARE AT THE TABLE
WITH HEAVY EMPHASIS ON
REPRESENTATION REGARDING FOLKS
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER,
NEEDS OR FAMILY EXPERIENCES.
CERTAINLY A BEHAVIORAL COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
REPRESENTATIVE, EXPERTISE ON
HOUSING, ENSURING THAT THERE ARE
YOUNGER FOLKS APPOINTED TO THE
COMMISSION AND THEN AS OUTLINED
IN THE SLIDE, PEOPLE WITH
EXPERIENCE OR EXPERTISE IN
REDUCING DISPARITIES, SO, SO
THOSE ARE THE VERY SPECIFIC, YOU
KNOW, THE SPECIFIC ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE MEMBERSHIP
CHANGE ON THE COMMISSION. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS UNIT TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET FROM
WHERE WE ARE TODAY TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE WHEN THIS TAKES
EFFECT RELATIVELY QUICKLY,
PARTICULARLY AS IT AFFECTS OUR
ABILITY TO OPERATE UNDER
BAGLEY-KEENE RULES IN TERMS OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM AND BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT IN PERSON AS AS
IS RECENTLY BEEN REQUIRED, AND
SO WE'RE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
EXCITED THAT WE WILL HAVE THE
CHANCE TO BRING SO MANY NEW
VOICES TO THE TABLE, BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT IT IT, YOU KNOW,
THE PROCESS OF MAKING
APPOINTMENTS, ONE OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE ASKED FOR, AND WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL WAS INCLUDED IS
THE ABILITY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
MEMBERS TO APPOINT A DESIGNEE
THAT HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO
SCHEDULE. OUR MEETINGS AT A TIME
WHERE ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN
PARTICIPATE. GIVEN YOUR
SCHEDULES. THE ORIGINAL LAW
ALLOWED THE TWO CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS TO APPOINT A DESIGNEE,
AND SO WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE.
APPRECIATIVE, TO SENATOR EGGMAN
AND THE TEAM THAT PUT THIS
TOGETHER TO RECOGNIZE FROM A
VERY PRACTICAL PERSPECTIVE, IN
ORDER FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE IN AN
ACTIVE ROLE, IT MAKES SENSE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE, LEGISLATIVE
MEMBERS TO APPOINT DESIGNEES.
WHAT DOES A PEER YOUTH MEAN? SO
THE TERM PEER GENERALLY REFERS
TO SOMEONE WHO HAS LIVED WHAT WE
CALL LIVED EXPERIENCE, MEANING
THEY ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM FROM A
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE, AND IN
THIS CASE, A YOUNG PERSON. OKAY.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THE SORT
OF THE GENERAL SCOPE AND DUTIES
OF THE COMMISSION REALLY DON'T
DON'T CHANGE DRAMATICALLY,
ALTHOUGH THEY DO EVOLVE IN TERMS
OF OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, THROUGH NUMEROUS
ADVISORY ROLES, OUR WORK IS
STILL FOCUSED ON PROMOTING
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE. THAT'S
THE ORIGIN STORY OF THE
COMMISSION, WITH THE ORIGINAL
PASSAGE OF PROP 63, IT'S BEEN
RETAINED IN PROP ONE, OUR
RESEARCH EVALUATION AND OUTCOME
WORK IS THE SAME. WE DO
GRANTMAKING. MOST OF THESE
ELEMENTS OF OUR WORK ACTUALLY
HAPPEN THROUGH THE DECISION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAKES TO THE
BUDGET PROCESS. AND SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT DRIVES OUR CAPACITY
TO DO THIS WORK. WHILE THE
BROADER STATUTE LAYS OUT THE
KIND OF AUTHORITIES THAT WE HAVE
THAT, IN TERMS OF THINGS LIKE
ADVISING THE GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE, WE ACTUALLY
DON'T EXPECT TO SEE ANY CHANGE
IN THIS ARRAY OF FUNCTIONS,
ALTHOUGH HOW WE DO THAT IS VERY
LIKELY TO EVOLVE AS WE BEGIN TO
LEAN IN AND WORK MORE CLOSELY
WITH THE NEW FUNCTIONS THAT ARE
BEING STOOD UP WITHIN OUR SISTER
AGENCIES, FOR EXAMPLE, THE MHSA
HAS LONG HELD THAT COUNTIES HAVE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FUNDS, THAT ONE OF
THE LANDMARK ELEMENTS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT THAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA UNIQUE.
CERTAINLY AT THE TIME, WAS THAT
THERE WAS A SPECIFIC SET ASIDE
OF FUNDING FOR PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION BECAUSE SO
MUCH OF THE TRADITIONAL
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY IS
REQUIRED TO BE USED FOR DIRECT
TREATMENT SERVICES, RIGHT?
MEDI-CAL TYPICALLY DIDN'T WORK
UPSTREAM. THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS, AND THAT HAS CHANGED
OVER TIME. PART OF THE WORK THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE BROADER
ADMINISTRATION HAS REALLY BEEN
DOING IS OPENING UP PATHWAYS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT, FUNDING FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION AND EVEN PREVENTION
STRATEGIES OVER TIME. AND SO,
THE ALTHOUGH THE FINANCING MAKES
IT LOOK LIKE THERE ARE SOME
DRAMATIC SHIFTS IN FUNDING FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION, FOR EXAMPLE,
UNDER THE MHSA, ABOUT 19% OF THE
LOCAL DOLLARS WAS FOR PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION. THE NEW
PRIORITY, BECAUSE IT'S, YOU
KNOW, 35% OF 90 AND 51% OF THAT,
IT'S ABOUT 17% FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION. SO THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF NEW POLICY SHIFTS
AND IMPLEMENTATION PRACTICES, WE
HOPE TO SEE MORE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR EARLY INTERVENTION
IN CALIFORNIA, IN PART BECAUSE
OF EXPANDED AVAILABILITY FOR
FEDERAL REIMBURSE, EXPANDED
STRATEGIES TO ENGAGE COMMERCIAL
AND OTHER PARTNERS IN EARLY
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES, AND
THAT THE DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
ARE EXCLUSIVELY FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION, WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PICKING UP THE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE ARRAY OF COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
FUNDED THROUGH MHSA WILL BE
SUSTAINED BECAUSE OF THE VERY
CLEAR RESOURCE SHIFTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED UNDER PROP ONE. ONE OF
THE AREAS OF CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING WITH THE COUNTIES
AND WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HOW MIGHT WE
FACILITATE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE COUNTIES TO USE THE BALANCE
OF MHC INNOVATION FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION FROM THE
FUNDING STRATEGIES THAT ARE IN
PLACE TODAY, TO THE FUNDING
STRATEGIES THAT NEED TO BE IN
PLACE AS PROP ONE TAKES EFFECT.
BUT PART OF THAT IS REALLY
WORKING IS THAT THE ONLY BUCKET
OF THE CURRENT MHC FUNDING THAT
PERHAPS WOULD BE UNSPENT,
INNOVATION WAS ESSENTIALLY JUST
SWEPT, ON A COUNTY, NO, NOT
NECESSARILY. IT MAY BE. RIGHT,
JUST RECOGNIZING THAT COUNTIES
DO HAVE EXPENDITURE TRENDS THAT
MAY BE MORE DIFFICULT TO SHIFT,
BUT THEORETICALLY, CONCEPTUALLY,
COUNTIES COULD USE SOME OF THEIR
ADMIN FUNDS UNDER THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO SUPPORT
THAT KIND OF WORK. BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE ARE, UNALLOCATED
DOLLARS. WHAT WE DO KNOW, WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. WE
ESTIMATE IT'S ALWAYS TRICKY, BUT
THERE'S AS MUCH AS $250 MILLION
OF MHC INNOVATION THAT IS STILL
COMING IN THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
COMMITTED BY COUNTIES UNDER THE
CURRENT RULES, COUNTIES RECEIVE
THE FUNDS THEY HAVE TO SET IT
ASIDE. THEY CAN ONLY SPEND IT
WITH COMMISSION APPROVAL. WE
ESTIMATE $250 MILLION OF
UNUTILIZED MHC FOR INNOVATION
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR INNOVATION
PURPOSES THROUGH THE START OF
THE H.S.A AND THE WAY H.S.A WAS
WRITTEN, IF THOSE DOLLARS ARE IN
A COMMISSION APPROVED INNOVATION
PLAN THAT USE IS GRANDFATHERED
IN. IN OTHER WORDS, THE TIMELINE
FOR USING THOSE DOLLARS CAN
EXTEND BEYOND THE START OF THE
NEW HRSA SPENDING REQUIREMENTS.
WE ALSO ESTIMATE THAT THERE IS
AS MUCH AS $800 MILLION OF MHC
INNOVATION FUNDS IN ALREADY
APPROVED INNOVATION PLANS THAT
COUNTIES ARE OPERATING TODAY,
AND WE RECOGNIZE WE'VE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED COUNTIES TO BE TO BE
WILLING TO REPRIORITIZE DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T WANT TO CREATE
A SCENARIO WHERE THEY COMMITTED
TO AN INNOVATION PROJECT AND
THEY LEARNED WITHIN THE IT'S A
FIVE YEAR PLAN, AND IN YEAR ONE,
THEY FIGURED OUT IT'S NOT
WORKING. WE AND SO WE CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTIES TO
CANCEL INNOVATION PROJECTS AS
THEY MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S, YOU KNOW, SUGGEST
IT'S WORKING OR NOT, WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT SOME OF THAT $800
MILLION OR SO COULD BE
REPURPOSED EAST IF A COUNTY
CHOSE TO. IN BOTH OF THESE
INSTANCES, THE UNAPPROVED
INNOVATION FUNDS AND THE
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED INNOVATION
FUNDS WOULD, OF COURSE, HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS AND BE APPROVED BY
COUNTY BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS SO
THE STATE CANNOT IMPOSE THAT ON
THEM. LAST WEEK, THE COMMISSION
MET AND WE TALKED ABOUT WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
COUNTIES TO IDENTIFY TO SORT OF
FACILITATE PRIORITIES FOR
COLLECTIVE COUNTY INNOVATION
INVESTMENT, TO SUPPORT SOME OF
THE AREAS OF GREATEST CONCERN AS
THE LOCAL AGENCIES MAKE THIS
TRANSITION, SO AS OUTLINED ON
THE ON ON HERE, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE A CONSULTING ROLE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OR AT EARLY
INTERVENTION, AROUND BEST
PRACTICES. ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
WE'VE HAD SOME REALLY
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS, PRIMARILY
THROUGH, SUPPORTING COUNTIES
AROUND HOW THESE INNOVATION
FUNDS IS IDENTIFYING EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES AND HELPING TO SCALE
THEM, SCALING EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES CONSISTENT WITH SOME
OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU'VE
MADE THIS MORNING, CAN BE VERY
CHALLENGING FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, BUT WE'VE HAD SOME
SUCCESS THERE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON FSP STANDARDS,
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AROUND THE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
CAN ALSO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AS AS THEY STAND
UP, THIS VERY EXCITING
POPULATION BASED PREVENTION
PRACTICE. AND THEN OF COURSE,
STIGMA AND DISCRIMINATION,
STRATEGIES. WE DO HAVE THREE NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO HELP YOU AND
HELP THE COMMISSION BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S
NOT WORKING, INCLUDING,
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW WE CAN
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
TO SUPPORT EXCELLENCE. WHERE,
WHERE, WHERE WE WHERE WE'RE
LEARNING, RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVING THESE, YOU KNOW, AGAIN
, STATE LEVEL STANDARDS, BECAUSE
IT IS ABOUT SCALING AND ABOUT
GETTING BETTER OVER TIME. AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, THE SECOND AREA
THAT I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHERE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IS
INNOVATION. AND SO OUR THIRD NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENT IS ON THE
INNOVATION PARTNERSHIP FUND, THE
HISTORY OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. THERE'S NO DUE
DATE ON THE FIRST REPORT. OTHER
TWO HAVE A DUE DATE, I DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT. THIS IS
OUTLINED IN THE STATUTE. AND SO,
WE'RE HAPPY TO. IT'S OUR FAULT
WITH THE. WELL CARDINAL RULE AS
A PRESENTER AND A BUDGET
COMMITTEE. NEVER SAY IT'S THE
CHAIR'S FAULT. THE SENATOR
EGGMAN'S FAULT, I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT, HONESTLY, AND
SO. BUT YOU KNOW, WE SO, SO
TYPICALLY IN OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE, ALSO RECOGNIZING
THAT WE HAVE LEGISLATORS ON THE
COMMISSION, WE WORK HARD TO
ACTUALLY MEET YOUR NEEDS
INDEPENDENT OF WHAT THE STATUTE
REQUIRES IN TERMS OF A DATE.
THANK YOU. SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU TO PUT A DATE IN
THERE. WE'D BE EVEN, YOU KNOW,
MORE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE
MOST HELPFUL AND JUST MEET THAT
GOAL. THANKS. IN THE INNOVATION
PARTNERSHIP FUND, SO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT WAS UNIQUE
AGAIN, BECAUSE OF THIS MANDATORY
SET ASIDE FOR INNOVATION. YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA WAS FIRST IN
THE COUNTRY TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
NEED TO CREATE A FISCAL
INCENTIVE AS WELL AS A POLITICAL
AND COMMUNITY BASED INCENTIVE
FOR CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT. AND
WE HAVE WORKED VERY HARD AND
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS. THERE IS IN THE RANGE
OF $1 BILLION OF INNOVATIONS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT
NOW. THERE ARE DOZENS OF REALLY
EXCITING INNOVATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES. THE CHALLENGE HAS
BEEN SCALING THOSE RIGHT, IN
PART BECAUSE AS INNOVATIONS,
THERE'S TREMENDOUS FLEXIBILITY
IN HOW THEY USE THOSE DOLLARS.
BUT THAT FLEXIBILITY ISN'T
ALWAYS SUSTAINED IN TERMS OF
MOVING THOSE PROGRAMS FROM
INNOVATIONS TO CORE PRACTICES
THROUGH, YOU KNOW, REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY OR WHATEVER THE
FUNDING SOURCE THAT A COUNTY
MIGHT PURSUE AND THAT HAS
ACTUALLY CONSTRAINED THE ABILITY
OF COUNTIES TO THINK OUT OF THE
BOX AS AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER,
IN PART BECAUSE FOR VERY
UNDERSTANDABLE REASONS, WE DO
REQUIRE A SUSTAINABILITY
STRATEGY. IF THIS WORKS, HOW
WILL YOU SUSTAIN IT? AND THAT
HAS MEANT THAT IT HAS LIMITED
THE ABILITY OF COUNTIES TO SORT
OF MOVE BEYOND SORT OF PRACTICE
IMPROVEMENTS OR SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS. THE INNOVATION
PARTNERSHIP FUND, UNDER THE
H.S.A, REPLACES THE 5% SET ASIDE
FOR THE FIRST FIVE YEARS IS $20
MILLION A YEAR TO THE COMMISSION
. AND IT STIPULATES THAT, YOU
KNOW, DURING THAT TIME OR AFTER
THAT TIME, IF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS, WANT TO EXPAND
THOSE FUNDS, THAT THAT IS YOUR
PREROGATIVE. IT ALSO ALLOWS THE
COMMISSION TO INTEGRATE THE
INNOVATION, THE 20 MILLION FOR
INNOVATION FUNDING IN WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH WELLNESS ACT,
FUNDS. IT'S AN ADDITIONAL 20
MILLION A YEAR THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. THE GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO PUBLIC,
PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT PARTNERS
TO REALLY DRIVE INNOVATION INTO
THIS SYSTEM. YOU KNOW,
RECOGNIZING THE BROAD CHALLENGES
THAT ARE THAT ARE BOTH AT THE
POPULATION LEVEL AND AT THE
PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LEVEL.
AND SO WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING SINCE THE CONVERSATIONS
AROUND THE BILL TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGY TO MAKE BEST USE OF
THOSE FUNDS, WE ARE TALKING WITH
ORGANIZERS AROUND THE WORLD TO
LOOK AT COMPARABLE STRATEGIES TO
REALLY LEVERAGE INNOVATION TO
DRIVE CHANGE IN INDUSTRY, IN
HEALTH CARE, IN, YOU KNOW,
SCIENCE AND RESEARCH. AND WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITY TO
LEVERAGE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT. TO BEGIN TO LEAN IN
AND SUPPORT STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC SECTOR GOALS.
THERE ARE COMPANIES AND VENTURE
CAPITAL INVESTORS AND OTHERS WHO
WANT TO ACTUALLY HELP ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN PUBLIC SECTOR
GOALS. THEY ARE GENERALLY
REPORTING OUT TO US THAT
GOVERNMENT IS A BLACK BOX. THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO TO CALL. AND
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND WE ARE ALREADY
STARTING TO PUT TOGETHER A
STRATEGY FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AROUND HOW TO DO
THAT. TOBY, CAN YOU GIVE US A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT EXCITING INNOVATIONS? IN
TERMS OF THINGS THAT HAVE
CURRENTLY ALREADY HAPPENED OR
THINGS THAT ARE EITHER, YOU
KNOW, ONE OF MY FAVORITES IS
SOLANO COUNTY RECOGNIZED VERY
EARLY ON THAT, THEY WERE
STRUGGLING VERY MUCH TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR, LATINO, FILIPINO
AND LGBTQ POPULATIONS, THEIR
DATA SUGGESTED THAT ON A ON A
PENETRATION RATE PERSPECTIVE,
LATINOS AND FILIPINOS WERE THE
LEAST WELL REPRESENTED. AND THEY
DIDN'T HAVE GOOD DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA ON LGBTQ, BUT THEY KNEW
JUST FROM ANECDOTE HOW
PROFOUNDLY, DIFFICULT IT WAS TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS, WORKING WITH
RESEARCHERS AT UC DAVIS, THEY
UNDERTOOK A MULTIYEAR INNOVATION
PROJECT TO FUNDAMENTALLY RETHINK
HOW THEY ENGAGE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND THEY SAW LIKE
300% INCREASES IN ACCESS TO CARE
FOR THESE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IN RESPONSE TO THAT
, WE FUNDED THE UC DAVIS
RESEARCHERS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SOLANO COUNTY AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH KVDA TO GREENLIGHT ANY
OTHER COUNTY THAT WANTED TO
INVEST IN A SIMILAR STRATEGY TO
REPLICATE THAT PROGRAM. AND SO
THAT'S THAT IS CURRENTLY IT IS
EXCITING. IT IS VERY EXCITING.
THAT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU. AND THE
BEAUTY OF THIS PROGRAM IS THAT
AT UC DAVIS, THERE'S A GLOBALLY
RECOGNIZED CENTER OF EXCELLENCE
THAT FOCUSES ON REDUCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES. AND SOLANO WAS ABLE
TO REACH OUT, PULL THEM IN USE
INNOVATION FUNDS TO TRY
SOMETHING NEW. RIGHT NOW THAT
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT IT IS
SCALED TO EVERY COUNTY. AND SO
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO. AND SO THIS IS YOU KNOW,
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE AS A
STATE THINKS ABOUT STANDARDS,
PARTICULARLY ON THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SIDE. WE SEE PROFOUND
CHALLENGES ACROSS THE STATE AS
COMMUNITIES OFTEN REPORT THAT
THEY DON'T FEEL THAT THEY ARE
ENGAGED. RIGHT. AND WE SEE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE VERY
SINCERE IN POINTING OUT HOW HARD
THEY WORK TO ENGAGE COMMUNITIES.
AND SO THIS IS, YOU KNOW, ONE
PARTICULAR EXAMPLE, ANOTHER, YOU
KNOW, EXAMPLE IS OUR EARLY
PSYCHOSIS WORK. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, BASED ON SOME RESEARCH
THAT THE COMMISSION DID AS MUCH
AS TEN YEARS AGO, WE IDENTIFIED
HUGE UNMET NEEDS IN RAPID
RESPONSE TO PSYCHOSIS AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ANOTHER
RESEARCH INSTITUTION AND A
HANDFUL OF COUNTIES, LAUNCHED A
MULTI COUNTY LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE. SO, BUT BUT YOU
KNOW, SO WE RECOGNIZE THERE'S
PROFOUND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN. WE'RE, WE'RE CURIOUS
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE IN THE LAW
THAT REQUIRES COUNTIES TO BE
INNOVATIVE IN AN ONGOING MANNER.
HOW WE CAN SUPPORT THAT. RIGHT.
WE THINK THAT WILL BE
CHALLENGING GIVEN ALL OF THE
TASKS THAT COUNTIES HAVE TODAY
TO TRANSITION. GIVEN THE NEW
FUNDING RULES FROM WHERE THEY
ARE TO WHERE THEY NEED TO BE.
BUT WE ARE ACTIVELY IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO
SUSTAIN THAT ABILITY. BUT TO
MARRY IT WITH STRATEGIES ON THE
ON THE PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE, ON
THE COMMERCIAL INSURANCE SIDE,
ON THE RESEARCH SIDE, WE'RE
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF LARGE RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN BRING THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS AVAILABLE IN
UC BERKELEY AND UCLA AND UCSF
AND, YOU KNOW, UC DAVIS, ETC,
INTO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE FACING, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
IS, WE'RE WORKING TO STRENGTHEN
THIS GRAPHIC, BUT BUT THIS IS A
SORT OF THIS WATERFALL METAPHOR
THAT YOU'VE HEARD REPEATEDLY.
AND, IS, AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE OF THE NOW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
THAT PRIORITIZES REDUCING
HOSPITALIZATION, HOMELESSNESS
AND INCARCERATION. WE THINK OF
THE PROFOUND ECONOMIC IMPACTS
THERE. WHAT ARE THE KEY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INTERVENTION?
AND SO THIS IS WHERE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH DHS AROUND
STRATEGIES FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION BECOMES REALLY
CRISP. WE HAVE FOCUSED ON FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE LANGUAGE AND
THE LAW MOVES FROM REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR MINIMUM
INVESTMENTS IN FSPS TO STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS, WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
LEAN IN. WE BELIEVE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE THE SAFETY NET
SERVICE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
CATCH AND HUG AND HOLD AND
SUPPORT AND LOVE FOLKS WHO ARE
AT HIGH RISK UPSTREAM FROM THAT
IS EARLY PSYCHOSIS. WE HAVE
INVESTED A LOT OF FUNDS TO
SUPPORT ALL KHÓ CENTERS. THE
COMMENT EARLIER ABOUT, CAN YOU
DEAL WITH THE DEPRESSION AND THE
GANGRENE? THESE ARE INTEGRATED
PRIMARY CARE, PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND PRIMARY CARE, MENTAL HEALTH
TARGETING TEENS AND TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH. IT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
ELEGANT, SIMPLE BEALL PEOPLE
WALK IN, THEY GET SERVICES, NO
QUESTIONS ASKED KIND OF MODEL.
IT IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
FUND BECAUSE BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
IT'S NOT BUILT AROUND A, A PRE
ENROLLMENT PRE-AUTHORIZATION
KIND OF MODEL. AND THEN OF
COURSE OUR SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH,
WHAT WE'RE MOSTLY EXCITED ABOUT
IN THIS GRAPHIC IS TO ASK THE
QUESTION, WHERE AREN'T WE
INVESTING IN TERMS OF
OPPORTUNITIES OR AREAS WHERE
EARLY INTERVENTION CAN BE MOST
SUCCESSFUL. AND SO PART OF THAT
WORK, AND WE'RE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IS HOW
CAN WE BUILD A, A SORT OF AN
ANALYTIC AND RESEARCH CAPACITY
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE COST
DRIVERS AND THE AREAS WHERE
THERE'S THE GREATEST OPPORTUNITY
FOR RETURN IN TERMS OF
PREVENTING THE ESCALATION OF
SYMPTOMS AND THE ESCALATION OF
COSTS IN IN WAYS THAT WE CAN
REALLY BEGIN TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF EXPENDITURES THAT THE
STATE IS MAKING THROUGH OUR
STATE HOSPITALS AND OTHER DEEP
END INSTITUTIONS. WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT WE THAT WE DON'T
NEED INSTITUTIONAL CARE. WE'RE
SAYING WE NEED IT. WE NEED TO BE
WORKING TO NEED IT LESS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, OUR NEXT SPEAKER, I THINK
WE'RE GOING ON TO I LOST MY
CLOSES OUT HERE. MICHELLE. YES
AND I ALSO HAVE A POWERPOINT
PRESENTATION. OH, MY GOODNESS.
ARE YOU SERIOUS? OH MY GOD,
THANK YOU. MICHELLE. SO NICE.
WOW. I'M REALLY GETTING THE STAR
TREATMENT TODAY, GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
MICHELLE CABRERA WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION, TODAY I'M GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF
THE CHANGES OUTLINED IN
PROPOSITION ONE, INCLUDING SB
326 TO THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SAFETY NET, AND WILL
ADDRESS THE VARIOUS QUESTIONS
POSED BY THE COMMITTEE. I DO
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT THIS IS
ALL VERY FLUID BECAUSE AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY, THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SECONDARY
GUIDANCE THAT STILL NEEDS TO BE
DEVELOPED. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION WITH COUNTIES IN
DEVELOPING THAT GUIDANCE. THESE
ESTIMATES AND PROJECTIONS THAT
I'LL SHARE TODAY ARE SOLELY
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW AS OF
TODAY, AND DO NOT REFLECT THE
EITHER POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF FUTURE POLICY
DIRECTION. I'LL START OUT IF WE
CAN GO TO THE FIRST SLIDE, BY
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE CHANGES OF THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THE HRSA FUNDING CATEGORIES,
RELATIVE TO THE CURRENT MHSA
DISTRIBUTIONS AS REQUESTED. AS
YOU WILL SEE ON THIS SLIDE,
THERE ARE SEVERAL KEY
DIFFERENCES WORTH NOTING. AND
THE CURRENT MHC, SORT OF SPLIT
IS ON THE LEFT SIDE WITH THE HSA
PROPOSED SPLIT ON THE RIGHT
SIDE. AND I APOLOGIZE. I KNOW
THE NUMBERS ARE TINY, BUT
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE THE HARD
COPY, THE BIG CHANGE THAT YOU
CAN SEE IS THE ADDITION OF A NEW
HOUSING CATEGORY, WHICH IS NOTED
HERE IN PURPLE. HISTORICALLY,
THE MHSA HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
PAYING FOR HOUSING TO SOME
EXTENT FOR OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CLIENTS IN DIFFERENT WAYS
. WE HAVE THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
BOND, WHICH COUNTIES ARE
FINANCING WITH LOCAL DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION, MHSA HAS BEEN USED TO
PAY FOR HOUSING, BUT OFTEN IN
THE FORM OF HOUSING FOR FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PARTICIPANTS
AND BOARDING CARE RATE SUPPORT.
WHILE FUNDING FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION AND FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS APPEARS VERY
SIMILAR, ON THIS CHART, IN THIS
CHART IS BROKEN OUT IN A WAY
THAT'S INTENDED TO FACILITATE
THAT APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON
ACROSS THE OLD AND THE NEW
CATEGORIES. WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OUR ANALYSIS AND MODELING IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
SHIFTS TO BE MINDFUL OF IN
MAKING ROOM TO EXPAND, AND ALSO
WHICH PLACE LIMITATIONS ON THE
TYPES OF HOUSING THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO FUND. OUT OF THOSE PURPLE
SLICES. AND IF WE CAN GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE, THIS IS SIMILAR. THE
SAME INFORMATION JUST PRESENTED
IN A DIFFERENT WAY IN THIS VIEW,
AND THE PRIOR, YOU CAN SEE THAT
THE DARK ORANGE SLICE OR BAR
HERE, WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR WHAT
TODAY IS CALLED COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND WILL
BECOME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS. THAT
SLICE IS REALLY WHERE WE SEE A
MAJORITY OF THE DROP. WHILE THE
STATE HAS INDICATED THAT THIS
POT WOULD POTENTIALLY BE
AVAILABLE TO FUND AN ARRAY OF
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES LIKE
TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS,
WORKFORCE DOLLARS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL, OR INNOVATIONS TODAY,
THIS COMPONENT OF THE MHSA IS
ACTUALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING FUNDING TO CORE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SUCH AS OUTPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, CRISIS SERVICES, PEER
RUN WELLNESS CENTERS, AMONG
OTHERS. IN ADDITION, WE SEE THAT
OUR FUNDING FOR FSP ACTUALLY
DROPS UNDER THIS PROPOSAL. WHILE
I WAS HEARTENED THAT OUR EARLY
INTERVENTION FUNDS ARE
RELATIVELY COMPARABLE TO CURRENT
LEVELS, INCLUDING THE ALL
IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH UNDER AGE 25, I WILL
NOTE THAT IN EARLY MODELING
EXERCISES, COUNTIES HAVE
DETERMINED THAT BECAUSE THEY
WILL NEED TO MOVE SOME OF THEIR
CORE CS SERVICES, THOSE ONES IN
DARK ORANGE AS APPROPRIATE, INTO
THE EARLY INTERVENTION BUCKET TO
SAVE THESE VITAL PROGRAMS. THEY
WILL THEN BE LIMITED IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO FUND,
WITH IMPLICATIONS ACROSS
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION, AS WELL AS OUR
CURRENT GENERAL SERVICES
ACTIVITIES THAT FALL UNDER THE
CS COMPONENT COUNTIES MAIN
CONCERN CURRENTLY IS
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT OF THE
FUNDING FOR NEW PROGRAMS, WHILE
ALSO IMPORTANT PURPOSES WITH
WHAT PROGRAMS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN OR PRESERVE, AND WHICH
PROGRAMS WE MAY NEED TO CONSIDER
PHASING OUT AS WE MAKE THIS
TRANSITION. ONE ASPECT COUNTIES
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO IS THE
PUSH TOWARDS GREATER INTEGRATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES, WHICH IS FACILITATED
BY THE HRSA. IN FACT, CBD'S
RECOMMENDATION FOR MHSA REFORMS
GOING BACK TO 2019 INCLUDED
ADDING GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO
ALLOW MHSA FUNDS TO BE USED FOR
SUD ONLY SERVICES. THIS HAS BEEN
A LONG TIME COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR PRIORITY.
HOWEVER, IF WE CAN GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE THIS IS NOT WHAT IS
REQUIRED, BUT IT'S A VISUAL
THAT'S USED TO SORT OF MAKE THE
POINT THAT IF WE WERE TO EVENLY
DISTRIBUTE BY BY CATEGORY
FUNDING ACROSS MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS, 50 OVER
50 FUNDING LEVELS FOR OUR
CURRENTLY FUNDED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SUPPORTED THROUGH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT,
WOULD DROP PRECIPITOUSLY BY
BRINGING IN. AND IF WE CAN GO TO
THIS NEXT, THANK YOU. BY
BRINGING IN A NEW COMMITMENT TO
FUNDING HOUSING WITH MHSA
DOLLARS, COUNTIES WILL PURSUE
BOTH REVENUE MAXIMIZATION
STRATEGIES LIKE THOSE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY, AS WELL AS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE NEW CATEGORIES TO SHIFT
CERTAIN CORE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS FROM ONE COMPONENT. IN
THIS CASE LIKELY FROM COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS INTO EARLY
INTERVENTION WHERE POSSIBLE, IF
IT'S APPROPRIATE. COUNTIES ARE
ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE VARIOUS
OPTIONS INCLUDED IN SB 326 THAT
MAY ALLOW FOR DCS APPROVED
TRANSFERS BETWEEN BUCKETS UP TO
7% BY CATEGORY, OR 14% IN TOTAL.
WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WILL
BE LOCAL IMPACTS, PARTICULARLY
TO OUR MORE GRASSROOTS,
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
TRADITIONAL, MEDICAL MODEL OR
INSURANCE REIMBURSE SERVICES.
AND WHERE THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY
TO DRAW DOWN MEDICAL MATCH
MEDI-CAL MATCH. EXCUSE ME?
EXAMPLES OF THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES INCLUDE OUR PREVENTION
OR EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
THAT ATTEMPT TO ENGAGE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
MORE CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE, LESS
CLINICAL INTERVENTIONS, SUCH AS
OUR LGBTQ SERVICES OR SERVICES
TARGETING IMMIGRANT OR REFUGEE
POPULATIONS, WHICH MAY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IN
ACCESSING TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
MODEL INTERVENTIONS. I WAS ALSO
ASKED TO SPEAK TO VARIOUS
ELEMENTS OF THE HRSA TRANSITION,
WHICH ARE STILL VERY MUCH UNDER
CONSTRUCTION, SO TO SPEAK. FOR
EXAMPLE, WE DO NOT KNOW MUCH YET
ABOUT HOW THE STATE ENVISIONS
COUNTIES WILL INTEGRATE OUR
TRADITIONAL MHSA COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND PLANNING
PROCESSES INTO THE MANAGED CARE,
POPULATION NEEDS ASSESSMENT OR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT PROCESSES. WHAT
I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES FEEL STRONGLY A STRONG
SENSE OF OBLIGATION TO THE
COMMUNITY RELATIONSHIPS THAT
WE'VE BUILT OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES, ENGAGING OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AROUND OUR MHSA
SPENDING, IN ADDITION TO THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD A DIRECT
HAND IN DEVELOPING TO MEET THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS, WE NEED TO KNOW
MORE, SOONER. FRANKLY ABOUT HOW
WE WILL NEED TO THINK ABOUT
FUTURE FUNDING REQUIREMENTS AND
THE TYPE OF COMMUNITY PLANNING
AND ENGAGEMENT WILL NEED TO DO
IN ORDER TO BEGIN PLANNING THIS
YEAR. FOR WHAT THE NEW
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS WILL NEED TO
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE. VÀ.
REGARDING THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
INHERENT VOLATILITY, AND WE CAN
GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. THIS SLIDE, IS THIS
IS AN ISSUE WHICH WE DID RAISE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION EARLY ON
IN THE PROCESS OF DISCUSSING
THEIR GOALS WITH HRSA, AND THIS
SLIDE IS JUST A COMPARISON OF
THE RELATIVE, FLAT OR STABLE
FUNDING SOURCES THAT WE HAVE
WITH 2011 AND 91 REALIGNMENT
VERSUS THE STRUCTURAL VOLATILITY
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT FUNDS. IT'S EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING FOR COUNTIES TO PLAN
OVER TIME, STABLE, CONSISTENT
PROGRAMING WHEN WE'RE TIED TO
PERCENTAGES OF THE STATE'S MOST
VOLATILE FUNDING STREAM.
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
PROGRAMS ON A THREE YEAR
PLANNING CYCLE BASED ON
PROJECTIONS OF FUTURE FUNDING
THAT ARE HISTORICALLY, OFTEN
THÀNH OFF BY A MARGIN OF ROUGHLY
30, MEANING THE ACTUAL REVENUES
THAT WE GET IN A YEAR ARE
TYPICALLY AROUND 30% LOWER OR
HIGHER THAN WHAT WE HAD BEEN
TOLD IN ESTIMATES, AND BUILT OUR
LOCAL PLANS AROUND IT. AND YET
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO SPEND DOWN.
MADAM CHAIR, IF I COULD ASK
MAYBE TOBY OR WILL. WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT PUTTING SOMETHING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO FLATTEN OUT
THAT VOLATILITY. WE COULDN'T DO
IT IN THE LEGISLATION, BUT THERE
WAS A PLAN TO COME BACK TO THAT.
YES. SO WE WILL BE ESTABLISHING
A REVENUE STABILITY WORKGROUP
THAT WILL INCLUDE THE LAO,
VARIOUS PARTNERS HERE TO DO THAT
WORK. I MEAN, WE, WE AGREE 100%
WITH WHAT MICHELLE JUST SAID
ABOUT THE INSTABILITY OF THIS
REVENUE SOURCE AND THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO THINK ABOUT
SMOOTHING IT OUT, OR HOW TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE PREDICTABLE FOR
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS. AND SO
THAT, I KNOW WAS AN ISSUE THAT
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT. YEAH. AND
THE, THE SORT OF DEGREE TO WHICH
THOSE ESTIMATES ARE OFF IS BY IS
NO FAULT WHATSOEVER OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LIKE THEY
ARE LITERALLY JUST TRYING TO
PINPOINT WHERE THE MILLIONAIRES
WEALTH WILL FLUCTUATE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR. AND THAT'S IT JUST
TURNS OUT THAT'S A REALLY
DIFFICULT THING TO DO. THE STOCK
MARKET IS NOT PREDICTABLE. WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ACKNOWLEDGING
THIS CHALLENGE AND FOR PULLING
TOGETHER THIS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED WORKING GROUP TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE WILL ADDRESS
THIS MOVING FORWARD. CBA LOOKS
FORWARD TO BEING A PART OF THAT
PROCESS, AS WELL AS IT REALLY
IMPACTS THE PLANNING, THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE SPENDING
AND THEN ULTIMATELY THE QUALITY
OF THE REPORT. IT'S ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THOSE DOLLARS,
RIGHT GUARDING FUNDING FOR
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS. THERE
STILL IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
SECONDARY GUIDANCE THAT WILL
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED IN ORDER TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF HOW ANY
EXISTING PROGRAMS MIGHT QUALIFY,
OR AROUND THE TYPES OF HOUSING
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO BE FUNDED.
WHAT I WILL LIFT UP IS THAT WE
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE THROUGH OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY, TO DRAW FROM
, AS WELL AS OPPORTUNITIES UNDER
THE UPCOMING CALAIM WAIVER TO
BRING IN NEW FEDERAL MEDI-CAL
FUNDING TO HELP HELP OFFSET SOME
OF THE ONE TIME TEMPORARY RENT
NEEDS OF OUR CLIENTS. WHILE WE
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF FOR BEING
ABLE TO MOVE OUR HOUSING COSTS
OUT OF THE FSP COMPONENT IN THAT
SOMEONE'S ENROLLMENT IN AN FSP
PROGRAM WILL NO LONGER BE A
REQUIREMENT FOR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THEIR HOUSING. THE
H.S.A WILL OTHERWISE BE MORE
RESTRICTIVE FOR HOUSING THAN
WHAT COUNTIES ARE CURRENTLY ABLE
TO FUND. UNDER THE MHSA, CBA
WILL PRIORITIZE WORKING WITH DCS
TO DISCUSS THE VARIOUS
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES OUR TEAMS
FACE EVERY DAY IN TRYING TO
HOUSE OUR CLIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE,
THE FACT THAT IN PRACTICE,
HOUSING FIRST LAWS AND
PRINCIPLES ARE DIFFICULT TO
ENFORCE, AND OFTEN THE VERY
CLIENTS WHO WERE WORKING WITH
AND TRYING TO HOUSE ARE SCREENED
OUT BY HOUSING PROVIDERS DUE TO
STIGMA AND, FRANKLY, COMPETITION
FOR SCARCE LOW INCOME HOUSING
RESOURCES. ON THE TOPIC OF
WORKFORCE, COUNTIES ARE IN NO
WAY GUARANTEED TO BE RECIPIENTS
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE FUNDING, WHICH IS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO THE STATE TO BE MANAGED
THROUGH DCS AND HCAI. CBA
STRONGLY RECOMMENDS THAT BOTH
AGENCIES PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS OF
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SAFETY NET AHEAD OF OTHER
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND IN
PARTICULAR, PRIVATE SECTOR
MODELS. WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
STATE ADDRESS, REGIONAL AND
RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES
BUILDING ON A REPORT CBA
RELEASED IN 2023 AND WHICH WE
JOINTLY COMMISSIONED WITH THE
UCSF HEALTH FORCE CENTER, WHICH
ANALYZES BOTH GAPS ACROSS THE
STATE AND REGIONAL NEEDS,
INCLUDING RACIAL, ETHNIC
DISPARITIES. IN ADDITION, WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATE
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN THE
SORT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND SUD
CARE INTEGRATION, WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS COMPELLED THROUGH THE
HSA. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROP ONE SLASH SB 326. THIS IS
REALLY THE BEGINNING OF A
MASSIVE SHIFT THAT WE HOPE TO
SEE USHER IN A NEW RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STATE IN DRIVING ITS
PRIORITIES FOR OVERSIGHT,
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND IMPROVED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIA SAFETY NET. WE'RE
AWARE OF THIS. I'M ASSUMING
WE'RE AWARE OF THIS REPORT THAT,
YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE 2023.
PERFECT. I WANT TO ASK YOU SOME
QUESTION. WE'VE BEEN ASKING
EVERYBODY REGARDING LIKE, YOU
JUST WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
DIFFERENTLY, THE STATUS QUO. WE
WERE CHANGING THIS. AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT COME UP IS, HEY,
THE COUNTY AND I'M SPEAKING TO
L.A. COUNTY SPECIFICALLY, ALWAYS
PARTNERS WITH THE SAME
ORGANIZATION. GRANTS GO TO THE
SAME ORGANIZATIONS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. ARE WE LOOKING AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND SAYING, HEY,
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING THESE
GRANTS JUST TO THESE THESE
NONPROFITS? NOT TO SAY THEY'RE
NOT DOING GREAT WORK, BUT WE
WANT TO EXPAND AND PROVIDE AND
OPEN THIS TO OTHER KIND OF
NONPROFITS TO HELP WITH THIS
WORK. YEAH I MEAN, I THINK THAT
THE SORT OF SHAKING UP THE
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS TO
PULL COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTO THE MANAGED CARE PLAN
PLANNING PROCESS INTO PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL, BY NATURE, REALLY
CHANGE THOSE DYNAMICS, AS WELL
AS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER PROVIDERS AND
SERVICES TO BE MORE CONSIDERED
UNDER THIS PLANNING PROCESS,
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT ROUGHLY
HALF OF MHSA FUNDS TODAY ARE
USED AS A SOURCE OF NONFEDERAL
SHARE FOR MEDI-CAL. IT'S ONE OF
OUR MAIN THREE REVENUE STREAMS.
AND SO WE USE IT TO PAY FOR
EPSDT SERVICES FOR KIDS FOR, YOU
KNOW, BASIC OUTPATIENT OR CRISIS
SERVICES TO MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES. AND SO THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE HAVE WITH
PROVIDERS ARE OFTENTIMES ABOUT
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
MEDI-CAL NETWORKS TO SERVE OUR
MEDI-CAL POPULATION. THAT'S
REALLY ALWAYS BEEN PRIORITY
NUMBER ONE, AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE THE DISCRETIONARY SIDE OF OUR
FUNDING. WE THINK THAT WE'RE
REALLY SHIFTING MORE OF THAT
INTO HOUSING AND LESS OF IT INTO
SOME OF THOSE EARLY PREVENTION
TYPE PROGRAMS THAT SOMETIMES WE
FUND TODAY WITH GRASSROOTS
NONPROFITS. AND THOSE ARE THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO NEED TO ENGAGE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
SEE IF OR HOW THEY CAN CONTINUE
SOME OF THOSE MORE MOM AND POP
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION TYPE OF
SERVICES, WOULD YOU SAY LIKE
PROMOTORAS LIKE THAT? EXACTLY.
LIKE PROMOTORAS. YEAH. OKAY
MADAM CHAIR, IF I MAY, ON THAT
TOPIC, WE REALLY HAVE BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY WORKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO A BETTER JOB ON
OUTCOME BASED REPORTING. SO THAT
THE DRIVERS OF DECISIONS AROUND
FINANCE ISN'T HISTORY AS MUCH AS
IT IS IMPACT. AND THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE THE STATE HAS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE. AND IT'S
REFLECTED IN THE HRSA. RIGHT.
THERE ARE SOME CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS THAT THE STATE WILL
ENHANCE THE ABILITY TO USE
EXISTING DATA SYSTEMS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT THAT WE'RE
HAVING. AND SO, YOU KNOW, WHILE
THE CONTRACTING PROCESSES IS
IMPORTANT, IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO REALLY BE CLEAR AND, YOU
KNOW, HAVE SOME COMPELLING
INCENTIVES AROUND THE IMPACT
THAT WE HAVE. AND WE HAVE WE DO
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT.
AND WE'VE TALKED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, WE'VE TALKED
WITH THE COUNTIES ABOUT HELPING
TO SUPPORT THIS TRANSITION. BUT
PART OF THAT IS RECOGNIZING THE
OFTEN VERY EXPENSIVE AND ONEROUS
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE IN PLACE TODAY THAT DON'T
ACTUALLY SUPPORT COURT DECISIONS
AROUND IMPACT. AND HOW MIGHT WE
USE PROP ONE TRANSITION TO
RETHINK WHAT THE STATE REQUIRES
SO THAT WE DON'T MOVE AWAY FROM
COMPLIANCE ORIENTED REQUIRING,
BUT WE MOVE TOWARDS REPORTING?
THAT GETS TO THE ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE RAISING AROUND OUR
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT, AND
CHANGE THOSE INCENTIVES IN WAYS
THAT MAKE SURE THAT IT ISN'T
JUST ABOUT SORT OF MATCHING THE
DOLLARS PROP ONE IS DESIGNED TO
GROW THE DOLLARS THAT COME INTO
THE SYSTEM THROUGH EXPANDED
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY. AND SO
IT SHOULDN'T BE AN APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON OF THE STATE
OF THE HRSA OVER TIME. IT REALLY
SHOULD BE. WE NEED LESS DEEP
END, VERY EXPENSIVE CARE THAT IS
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING MORE EARLY
INTERVENTION PREVENTION CARE
THAT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. AND SO THE SO THE
SO THE THIS ALTHOUGH THE
PORTIONS OF THE PIE AS OUTLINED
IN THE PIE CHART MAY NOT LOOK
THE SAME, THE REAL OPPORTUNITY
IS TO GROW THE PIE SO THAT THE
ACTUAL DOLLARS ARE COMPARABLE TO
THE HISTORICAL FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN AVAILABLE UNDER THE MHSA,
AND BEING ABLE TO SCALE THINGS
UP, LIKE THE EARLIER EXAMPLE YOU
USED FROM UC DAVIS AND THE THREE
POPULATIONS. THANK YOU. ONE LAST
QUESTION. I THINK, I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
DIRECTOR, WE BRIEFLY TALKED
ABOUT BEADCHIP AND THE WE DIDN'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT BRIDGE HOUSING
, BUT ARE WE LOOKING IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE ADDING SOME OF THE
BOND DOLLARS INTO THE BEADCHIP
INFRASTRUCTURE? AND RIGHT NOW
THERE'S AROUND SIX PROPOSED FOR
DELAY. ARE WE LOOKING AT THESE
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO BE USED AS
IF FOR ROUND SIX. AND SAY AND
SCORE ON THAT GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS AS NATE WILLIAMS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, YEAH. SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DIDN'T
MAKE ANY ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE
PASSAGE OF PROP ONE. SO THE
BUDGET INCLUDES THE DELAY. WE
ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING KIND OF
ALL OF THE COSTS AND THE PROGRAM
SPECIFICS AS IT RELATES TO PROP
ONE IN GENERAL. AND WE ARE
PREPARED TO AND HOPING TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE, AT
THE MAY REVISION. OKAY. WELL, DO
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO COMMENT ON
THIS WHOLE TOPIC? I'M GOING TO
HAVE MY COLLEAGUE RYAN MILLER
COME UP AND SPEAK TO
SPECIFICALLY B CHIP. OKAY.
RAIMES BEEN WAITING IN THE CROWD
ALL DAY. I SEE. READY TO JUMP UP
. THANK YOU. YOU CAN MOVE THAT
CLOSER. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATOR EGGMAN. SO IN
ASSESSING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN GENERAL AND IN OUR
OFFICES, WE'RE KIND OF TRACKING
REVENUES. OVER RECENT MONTHS,
OUR OFFICE HAS SAID THAT WE
THOUGHT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE
WISE TO START LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL SOLUTIONS, WITH THAT
IN MIND, AND TRYING TO, YOU
KNOW, KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR IDEAS
THAT MAY BE, SAY, LESS PAINFUL
THAN LOOKING AT PROGRAM CUTS AND
, YOU KNOW, CUTS TO EXISTING
SERVICES, OUR OFFICE ACTUALLY
DID RECOMMEND THAT IF PROP ONE
WAS PASSED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER, REPLACING SOME OF THE
GENERAL FUND THAT'S STILL
EXPECTED TO BE SPENT WITH BOND
FUNDS. SO AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
RECOMMENDATION IF HELPFUL. I
OBJECT. WHAT WERE THE ITEMS? WAS
IT JUST ON THOSE TWO PROGRAMS, B
CHIP AND BRIDGE HOUSING? WAS
THERE SOMETHING ELSE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT? B CHIP IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE, AND IF I
MAY EXPAND JUST A LITTLE BIT,
YOU KNOW, TOTALLY UNDERSTANDING,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE PERSPECTIVE
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
ALSO TRYING TO LOOK AT, YOU
KNOW, WHAT SORTS OF THINGS MAY
BE LESS DISRUPTIVE IN THE NEAR
TERM, WHEREAS AS WE KNOW WITH,
WITH THE PROP ONE FUNDS, THERE'S
POTENTIALLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A SWAP WITHOUT REALLY
CHANGING THE NEAR-TERM PLANS IN
TERMS OF HOW ROUND SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT AND SO FORTH WOULD ROLL
OUT. THE LEGISLATURE, OF COURSE,
LATER ON COULD REVISIT WHETHER
THERE WOULD BE A NEED TO, YOU
KNOW, ADD GENERAL FUND AT THE
END OF THE PROP ONE BOND PERIOD,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, THE DIRECTOR,
DIRECTOR OF BOSS EARLIER STATED
WOULD TAKE, YOU KNOW, YEARS TO
UNDERSTANDABLY TO GET ALL THE
FACILITIES KIND OF FUNDED
THROUGH VARIOUS ROUNDS AND BUILT
OUT. AND SO YOU KNOW, I THINK
PART OF OUR THINKING WAS IT
SEEMED LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER A SWAP THAT WOULD
CREATE A LOT OF GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS. NOW, THAT COULD EITHER
PROTECT PROGRAMS OR, YOU KNOW,
MAKE TRY TO, YOU KNOW, REACH
SOME BETTER TRADE OFFS. AND THEN
IN THE LONGER TERM, THE STATE
MIGHT BE IN A POSITION TO
REPLACE THE FUNDING, YOU KNOW,
IN THE FUTURE. SO SENATOR
EGGMAN, IF YOU WANT TO EXPAND ON
YOUR. YEAH, I JUST, IT'S NOT THE
DISAPPOINTMENT TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I THINK IT'S MORE
DISAPPOINTMENT TO THE VOTERS.
RIGHT. WHO BARELY PASSED THIS.
AND I THINK WITH THE ASSUMPTION
OF NEW MONEY NOT REPLACING MONEY
THAT WE'D ALREADY SET ASIDE FOR
THIS. SO I JUST THINK THAT'S
DISINGENUOUS FOR THE VOTERS.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND, YOU
KNOW, THE OTHER THING IS, IF
WE'D KNOWN THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE SOME SUPPLANTING HERE, WE
MAYBE WE WOULD HAVE INCREASED
THE AMOUNT OF THE BOND. AND THEN
THE FINAL COMMENT IS, SINCE
WE'RE DEALING WITH CAPITAL
PROJECTS, RIGHT? GIVEN THE COST
OF CONSTRUCTION AND THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION TODAY VERSUS THE
COST OF CONSTRUCTION IN 5 OR 10
YEARS, WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO
BE BUYING A LOT LESS IN TEN
YEARS. AND WE COULD DO TODAY.
AND I THINK MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ARE VERY SENSITIVE TO
CUTS AND THE PROGRAMS THAT COME
BEFORE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THREE
AND IN TERMS OF THE SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE STATE. SO THIS
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE.
BUT I THINK THOSE CONSIDERATIONS
CERTAINLY HAVE TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN WE MAKE DECISIONS
LIKE THAT. CAN YOU, RYAN,
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE? YOU
SAID IT'S THERE'S A POSSIBILITY.
K¾T FOR EXAMPLE, THE BOND
DOLLARS ARE COMING LATER THIS
YEAR. RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO
START BRINGING THOSE OUT. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY ROUNDS
THERE'S GOING TO BE THAT WE
UTILIZE. IF I HEARD YOU
CORRECTLY, UTILIZE SOME OF THAT
FUNDING AS IF IT WAS THE NEXT
ROUND THAT WE WERE GIVING. AND
THEN IN A COUPLE OF YEARS, IT'S
ABOUT LIKE THREE, FOUR.
HOPEFULLY OUR BUDGET SITUATION
IS BETTER AND THEN REALLOCATE
THE AMOUNT THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO ALLOCATE FOR THIS LAST ROUND,
AS IF THAT'S THE IS THAT WHAT
YOU SAID, LIKE WE DID WITH ADAP,
MA'AM? IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING? THAT CERTAINLY IS AN
OPTION. YEAH, I THINK
ESSENTIALLY THE CONCEPT IS
REPLACING WHAT IS CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED TO BE GENERAL FUND
WITH BOND FUNDS. YEAH. OKAY
THANK YOU. SENATOR I JUST WANTED
TO. MAYBE I'LL GET A MIC ON.
THERE WE GO. TOOK ME 12 YEARS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUSH THE
BUTTON. SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
WOULD DO WITH YOU. I THOUGHT I
WOULD GIVE THE OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS TO SOME
OF THE OTHER COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE JUST AFTER YOUR
PRESENTATION. WITH YOUR
PERMISSION, MADAM CHAIR. OF
COURSE, IF WE'RE. YEAH, I MEAN,
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE COMMENTS
ON THE REVENUE MAXIMIZATION
STRATEGIES TO HELP BUFFER ANY
POTENTIAL SERVICE CUTS, AS
MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS, WE ARE
ALL IN ON THAT PROPOSITION. I DO
THINK THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT, EVEN TODAY, TO GET
MEDI-CAL TO REIMBURSE FOR
PREVENTION AND COMMUNITY DEFINED
EVIDENCE PRACTICES. THE SORT OF
BEAUTY OF THE MHSA IS THAT IT
HAS ALLOWED US TO REALLY GO
OUTSIDE OF TRADITIONAL WHAT WHAT
IS RESTRICTED IN TRADITIONAL
INSURANCE AND TO FUND THINGS
THAT ARE SUPER IMPORTANT BRIDGES
TO BRINGING IN THOSE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THE CHALLENGING
PART ABOUT THAT BEAUTIFUL
PROPOSITION IS THAT IT, IT MEANS
THAT SO MUCH OF THE GOOD WORK
THAT WE DO IS OFF BOOK TO
MEDI-CAL, MEANING DCFS CAN'T SEE
IT IN THE CLAIMS. AND SO IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO, ANALYZE OR
CAPTURE DATA ABOUT ALL OF THOSE,
REALLY TREMENDOUS SUCCESSES IN
REACHING PEOPLE. AND I CAN
PROVIDE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES, BUT
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT IN THIS SORT
OF RESHIFTING REPRIORITISATION
WE'RE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT,
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO BRING IN
MEDI-CAL FOR THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. AND IT'S REALLY NOT
LIKELY IN THE NEAR FUTURE THAT
CMS WILL CHANGE ITS OPINION ON
SOME OF THOSE THINGS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THEY'RE BY
DEFINITION, NOT TRADITIONAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES OR BY
DEFINITION, THINGS THAT MEDICAID
HASN'T PAID FOR OR WON'T, THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATOR, THÀNH,
HAS BEEN REALLY WONDERFUL IN
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE AND TRYING
TO GET CMS TO APPROVE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE NOT TRADITIONALLY
BEEN ABLE TO DO RIGHT. AND SO
THERE IS SOME POTENTIAL UPSIDE
THERE. PART OF WHAT I'M TRYING
TO FLAG IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO CALL IT TO BUILD OUR
FIRST PLAN BEFORE MANY OF THOSE
NEW WAIVERS OR PERMISSIONS OR
INITIATIVES ARE UNDERWAY. AND SO
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF A SORT
OF HOLDING ON TO WHAT WE CAN
THAT WE MUST, FOR THE PURPOSES
OF OUR MEDI-CAL COMPLIANCE,
DOING WHAT WE NEED TO COMPLY
WITH ALL THE NEW RULES IN THE
HSA, AND THEN ANALYZING WHAT'S
LEFT OVER AND OF THOSE THINGS,
DO WE NEED TO TRY TO FIND NEW
FUNDERS, LET THEM GO, OR GIVE
THEM ENOUGH OF AN OPPORTUNITY?
K¾T A HEADS UP, FRANKLY, THAT
WE'RE THE COMMUNITY GROUPS THAT
WE'RE FUNDING WITH THE MHC, THAT
WE'RE ABOUT TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER YOU. AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS, THE WEIGHT OF
THAT RESPONSIBILITY SITS PRETTY
HEAVY ON THEM RIGHT NOW. THEY'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING
THOSE COMMUNITY GROUPS ENOUGH
LEAD TIME SO THAT THEY KNOW WHAT
TO EXPECT, BECAUSE WE'VE SPENT A
LONG TIME BUILDING UP, BUILDING
UP THAT TRUST. THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES RIGHTFULLY RELY ON
MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. OKAY. ANYTHING ELSE?
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH, EVERYONE.
I LÀ JUST I KNOW YOU YOU CAME UP
HERE FOR A BIT, BUT IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD ON THIS
WHOLE PROP ONE? YOU KNOW,
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD, BUT YOU
KNOW, WE'RE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS AND WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OKAY MOVING ON TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. I WAS LIKE, TOBY,
DON'T GO TOO FAR. DO YOU NEED
MICHELLE? I CAN COME DOWN THERE
AND RUN IT FOR YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND I'M ASSUMING
THIS IS ON THE AGENDA ITEM ON
THE REAPPROPRIATION ISSUE. A
QUICK OVERVIEW, ISSUE ONE, QUICK
OVERVIEW. ISSUE ONE. SORRY, I
MEAN, I MEAN, YOU GAVE A, YOU
GAVE AN OVERVIEW. I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS. COME ON
. THE COMMISSION BEFORE WE GO
INTO THE REAPPROPRIATION, I
DON'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO SHARE IN TERMS OF
THE QUICK OVERVIEW, BUT I'M
CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, HAPPY TO,
YOU KNOW, THAT'S FINE. CERTAINLY
EXPRESS MY DEFICITS AND PUSHING
BUTTONS AND MAKING MICROPHONES
WORK. YOU KNOW, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, I SORT OF THE BROADEST
ISSUE HERE IS, YOU KNOW, THE
COMMISSION REALLY WAS FORMED TO
SHARPEN OUR ABILITY TO HAVE THE
IMPACT THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
VOTERS, PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CLIENTS AND FAMILIES WE
SERVE EXPECT AND, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO BE
VERY INTENTIONAL IN, IN WORKING
WITHIN THE NEW OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT CREATES TO BE
EFFECTIVE. WE'RE ACTUALLY REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT A COUPLE OF AREAS.
SO ONE OF THEM IS THE IS THE NEW
PREVENTION ROLE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AS
DIRECTOR HAGAN POINTED OUT,
RIGHT. THIS THIS IS A, AN AREA
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
HISTORY AND THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING, THE FACT THAT IT'S
ONGOING FUNDING, THE FACT THAT
IT'S POPULATION BASED. RIGHT. I
THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S AN
AREA WHERE WE WANT TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL IN SUPPORTING THE
DEPARTMENT TO THINK ABOUT HOW TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE WAYS, RECOGNIZING
THAT PREVENTION HAPPENS IN AREAS
OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL
JURISDICTION OF CDF. AND WE'RE
VERY HOPEFUL THAT AS THE STATE
STANDS UP, A STRATEGY TO MAKE
USE OF THOSE DOLLARS, THAT IT
REALLY LEVERAGES OPPORTUNITIES
IN K-12, IN HIGHER ED, IN
WORKFORCE, IN THE TYPE OF
TRAINING WE DO FOR OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE, AS WELL AS OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. THE
TYPE OF TRAINING WE DO FOR
TEACHERS BECAUSE THE EYES AND
EARS FOR PREVENTION, THE WAYS IN
WHICH WE SUPPORT PREVENTION ARE
OUR HISTORY OF PREVENTION IS
MENTIONED ON HEART DISEASE, YOU
KNOW, ISN'T THROUGH TRADITIONAL
CLASSIC CLINICAL BASED CARE.
IT'S THROUGH THE BEHAVIORS,
ACTIVITIES AND THOUGHTS THAT
THAT EVERYBODY HAS EVERY DAY.
AND SO SIMILARLY, ON EARLY
INTERVENTION, WE THINK THIS IS
AN AREA OF PROFOUND SIGNIFICANCE
, RECOGNIZING NEW ROLES FOR THE
STATE TO REALLY BE AGGRESSIVE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE'D LOVE TO,
REALLY UNDERSTAND FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S PERSPECTIVE, YOU
KNOW, AND THIS IS RELATED TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE, IT WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL TO IDENTIFY THE
HALF DOZEN TO A DOZEN PRIORITIES
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO REALLY
MOVE BEYOND THE COMPARISON OF
THE PIE CHARTS. Ã TO BE AND
REALLY MOVE TOWARDS RECOGNITION
THAT WE SHOULD BE PULLING
DOLLARS OUT OF OUR DEEPEST, MOST
EXPENSIVE INSTITUTIONS. CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, STATE HOSPITAL
SYSTEM, RIGHT? AND PUSHING THEM
INTO THOSE EARLY INTERVENTION
POTS. SO WE'RE NOT PUTTING
COUNTIES IN THIS UNTENABLE
POSITION OF TRYING TO
REDISTRIBUTE VERY SCARCE, TOO
LIMITED RESOURCES IN WAYS THAT
ARE, YOU KNOW, NOT HAVING THE
IMPACT THAT THEY NEED TO BE WITH
THAT. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT QUESTION. THE
COMMISSION ON THE OVERSIGHT OR
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR CYBER I, THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE IS THERE A
REPORT THAT THESE THE GRANTEES
SUBMIT TO THE COMMISSION, OR IS
IT JUST A ONE TIME APPROVAL OF
THE GRANTS? AND THEN HOPEFULLY
THE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING WELL,
SO, THERE'S A COUPLE ANSWERS TO
THAT. SO WE HAVE AN EXPLICIT
ROLE IN SAIBAI THROUGH BOTH THE
INCLUSION OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT AS $20
MILLION A YEAR FOR TO FUND LOCAL
PARTNERS BETWEEN LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES, COUNTY BEHAVIOR,
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS, COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH STRATEGIES. SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY A GRANT PROVIDER AND A
PARTNER IN SAIBAI. IN DOING
THAT, THERE IS A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT IS DUE TO YOU. WE ALSO
NGUYEN SAIBAI WAS STRUCTURED AND
THE LEGISLATURE SET ASIDE A
PORTION OF FUNDS FOR THE
COMMISSION TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THE EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
FUNDING. WE HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
WITH DCS. WE ACTUALLY
ADMINISTERED THE COMPETITOR OF
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR ROUNDS
FOUR AND FIVE, FOCUSING ON YOUTH
DRIVEN AND EARLY INTERVENTION.
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS, A PORTION,
ARE BEING DEDICATED TO BUILD OUT
THE STATE STRATEGY ON EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION, AND SOME
OF THOSE TO BUILD OUT THE YOU
KNOW, THE ROUNDS WENT OUT
ALREADY ON. YES OKAY. YES. ROUND
SIX HAS NOT GONE OUT. BUT THE
OTHER ONES, ONE THROUGH FOUR
HAVE GONE OUT. DCS WOULD NEED TO
GIVE YOU MORE DETAILS ON THE
BACKGROUND ON THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YOU HAVE YOU SAID ROUND
ONE THROUGH FOUR HAS GONE OUT,
FIVE HAS GONE OUT. WHERE'S ROUND
SIX OF THE FUNDING DO WE. SO WE
STILL HAVE FUNDING IN THIS POT
FOR THE LAST ROUND FOR CBH. WE
DO STILL HAVE FUNDING FOR ROUND
SIX. I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU ON THE SPECIFICS OF WHETHER
WE'VE RELEASED THE, THE, YOU
KNOW, RFAS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, BUT I CAN GET BACK TO YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE. DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE? I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL ITEMS HERE.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET THIS
WHOLE YEAR IN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S LEFT IN THIS INITIATIVE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR. YES. AROUND
SIX HAS NOT YET GONE OUT. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR, THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SOLUTIONS.
SORRY. AUTUMN BOYLAN WITH DCS. I
DIDN'T SAY THAT PART, TO DESIGN
THE STRATEGY FOR ROUND SIX,
WHICH WOULD BE FOCUSED ON
COMMUNITY DEFINED EVIDENCE
PRACTICES, SPECIFICALLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS, COMMERCIAL
PLANS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROMOTE THE
ADOPTION OF COMMUNITY DEFINED
EVIDENCE STRATEGIES WITH
COMMUNITIES LOCALLY AND FUNDED
THROUGH OUR HEALTH PLANS. OKAY,
SO THERE IS STILL FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THAT. ABOUT $30
MILLION WAS ALLOCATED FOR THAT
ROUND. AND THE FUNDING HAS NOT
YET BEEN, THE RFA HAS NOT YET
BEEN ISSUED. OKAY. THANK YOU,
AND THEN, TOBY, I'M SORRY, I
USUALLY LIKE TO CALL YOU BY YOUR
TITLE, SO I DON'T KNOW. PLEASE,
TOBY, SO YOU SAID A REPORT IS
DUE TO US SOON ON SIB. IS IT
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE EFFICACY
OF EACH PROGRAM WITH EACH
GRANTEE, OR WHAT WOULD WHAT
WOULD WE BE SEEING IN THAT
REPORT? SO TO CLARIFY, WE ARE
NOT. SO THERE ARE MULTIPLE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITHIN
PSI. WE HAVE A SMALL SLIVER OF
THAT OKAY. RIGHT. AND SO, WE AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACT PREDATES PSI. BUT
IT WAS INCORPORATED IN BECAUSE
THERE WERE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES DEDICATED
TO THE SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
STRATEGY AS PART OF PSI. IT
DWARFED THE, YOU KNOW, THE
ORIGINAL $300 MILLION THAT THE
COMMISSION RECEIVED TO SUPPORT
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH. SO
WE HAVE JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE ARE
NOT REPORTING ON EVERYTHING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING IN
TERMS OF CRB. WE DO HAVE SOME
REPORTS. I'M SORRY, I DO NOT
KNOW THE DATE THAT IT IS DUE AND
WE HAVE SOME OTHER OVERSIGHT
REPORTS DUE TO YOU AROUND FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS, AND WE ARE
PREPARING OTHER INFORMATION FOR
YOU. FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING A, A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO IDENTIFY THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN ENSURING THAT
PEOPLE WHO DEVELOP PSYCHOSIS
HAVE ACCESS TO EVIDENCE BASED
CARE IN AN EARLY MANNER. AND AS
PART OF THAT ONE, WE'RE WORKING
WITH SOME PARTNERS TO DO THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT ANALYSIS OF WHAT
IT WOULD COST TO GET FROM WHAT
WE BELIEVE IS ABOUT A 10% ACCESS
RATE TODAY TO A TARGETED 90%
ACCESS RATE, WITH SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT EARLY EVIDENCE THAT
IT WOULD ACTUALLY COST US LESS
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE TO
THOSE STRATEGIES. SO THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. YOU KNOW, I WAS,
CHAIRING SUB ONE WHEN WE DID THE
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT, AND WE WANTED A BUNCH MORE
MONEY. WE WOUND UP WITH 50 AND
THEN LATER OTHERS TOOK IT TO NEW
HEIGHTS. WHERE DO WE GO THEN? TO
GET A REPORT ON HOW THIS IS ALL
COMING TOGETHER? IF YOU ONLY
HAVE A PIECE OF IT. I MEAN, THE
GOAL WAS AND PART OF THIS CAME
ABOUT, I THINK, BECAUSE WHEN I
WOULD ASK SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS
IF THEY WERE ON THE LOCAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BOARD, MOST OF
THEM WHO CAME BEFORE US IN
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
HAD NEVER HEARD OF IT, AND THEY
CERTAINLY DIDN'T HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. AND HAD NEVER
RECEIVED ANY RESOURCES FROM THE
COUNTY OR ANYWHERE ELSE. IT'S NO
FAULT OF ANYBODY'S, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, OUT OF SIGHT, OUT OF MIND.
THE GOAL WAS TO PUT THEM ALL AT
THE TABLE AND SEE IF WE COULD
DIRECT SOME RESOURCES THROUGH
THE COUNTY TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF SERVICE AT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEN
REFERRAL TO MILD TO MODERATE TO
SEVERE WHEREVER THE STUDENTS
NEEDED TO GO. HOW DO WE WHERE DO
I GO TO FIND OUT HOW SUCCESSFUL
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN? ARE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REPORTING
THROUGH THEIR STOVEPIPE OR THE
COUNTY'S REPORTING, MAYBE MY
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER.
I WANT TO KNOW THAT'S COLLEAGUES
WHO KNOW THIS SUBJECT MUCH
BETTER THAN I KNOW, BUT I DON'T
KNOW. SO IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION
TO YOU, IT IS A FAIR QUESTION TO
ME. AND YOU KNOW, I CANNOT SPEAK
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION IN, IN
TERMS OF THE BROADER IMPACT OF
SAIBAI. AND I WOULD CERTAINLY,
YOU KNOW, WANT TO DEFER TO
FINANCE OR THE LAO OR THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT. I CAN,
YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN SHARE IS
THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY THE RIGHT
QUESTION. RIGHT? THAT THE, THE,
THE, THE WAY IN WHICH THE MENTAL
HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES ACT WAS
IMPLEMENTED, PARTICULARLY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE PANDEMIC, WAS
TO REALLY FACILITATE THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. SENATOR ROTH, THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT. RIGHT. AND SO
AS THE COMMISSION PUT THESE
DOLLARS OUT AND IT WAS NOT A LOT
OF MONEY, IT WAS 2.5 MILLION TO
SMALL COUNTIES, 4 MILLION TO
MEDIUM SIZE, AND A WHOPPING 6
MILLION TO LARGE COUNTIES LIKE
LOS ANGELES. IT WAS NOT A LOT OF
MONEY. AND SO OUR PRIMARY FOCUS,
OUR GOAL WAS TO FACILITATE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN LEE'S
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION, WHICH MEANT THAT
EACH APPLICANT HAD THE RIGHT TO
SORT OF DESIGN THEIR STRATEGY
THAT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT WASN'T ONE SIZE
FITS ALL, THOUGH. YOU KNOW, THE
UNIFORMITY THAT WE WERE LOOKING
FOR WAS COLLABORATION. BUT WHAT
THEY COLLABORATED ON THERE WAS
TREMENDOUS VARIATION IN TERMS OF
BRINGING CLINICAL CARE INTO A
SCHOOL, DOING TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS, FOCUSING ON SUICIDE OR
SUICIDE PREVENTION. SO LOTS OF
VARIATION. NOW WE'RE AT THE
STAGE WHERE WE BELIEVE THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IS TO BEGIN TO BUILD
OFF OF THE BASE OF COLLABORATION
THAT IS NOW VERY ROBUST. THERE'S
LOTS OF VERY POSITIVE STORIES
ABOUT, STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THESE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE NOT
ALWAYS COORDINATED OR
COMMUNICATED FOR, FOR, YOU KNOW,
OFTEN FOR VERY GOOD REASONS, AND
BEGIN TO PUSH THE SYSTEM TO BE
MORE CONSISTENT IN TERMS OF
STANDARDS OF CARE AND
STRATEGIES. SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
TO GUIDE OVER THE LONG TERM, THE
SCALING OF EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTIONS IN ALL OF THE
DOMAINS THAT OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
HAVE RECOGNIZED ARE IMPORTANT,
WHICH INCLUDES TEACHER TRAINING,
SUICIDE PREVENTION. WORKPLACE
MENTAL HEALTH FOR SCHOOL STAFF,
RIGHT? AS WELL AS ACCESS TO
CLINICAL CARE FOR STUDENTS,
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT STRATEGIES,
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
IN ORDER TO DO THAT. ONE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE BEEN HAVING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IS, HOW
CAN WE ACTUALLY SUSTAIN
LEADERSHIP ON SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH OVER TIME, RECOGNIZING
THAT SAIBAI IS A SUNSETTED
PROGRAM WITH, YOU KNOW, ONE TIME
FUNDING, VERY GOOD USE. OF ONE
TIME FUNDING, BUT IT'S ONE TIME
FUNDING. AND SO I WOULD SAY, YOU
KNOW, THE TRAIN IS MOVING TO USE
YOUR EXAMPLE. AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO TO ACTUALLY MAKE
SURE IT'S HEADING IN THE
DIRECTION THAT THAT HEALTH US
LEARN FROM THE EXPERIENCES THAT
WE'VE FUNDED SO FAR TO SHAPE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL PARTNERS,
DO THIS IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS US
TO SCALE EFFECTIVE PRACTICES,
AND INCLUDES THE ABILITY TO
RESEARCH AND UNDERSTAND WHERE
IT'S WORKING AND WHERE IT'S NOT,
SO THAT WE AREN'T SIMPLY
REPLICATING DISPARITIES ACROSS
THE STATE AS HAS COME UP IN SOME
OF THE CONVERSATIONS TODAY.
WELL, WE SEEM TO BE FORTUNATELY
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF
MULTI-AGENCY COORDINATION, OF
EFFORT IN AREAS SUCH AS THIS,
WHICH THEN, OF COURSE,
FACILITATES APPROPRIATE
REPORTING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WHEN WE'RE NOT MOVING IN A
STOVEPIPE WAY, BUT INSTEAD
ACROSS THE BOARD WITH A COMMON
SET OF GOALS AND OBJECTIVES.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL SEE SOME,
COORDINATED REPORTING GOING,
IT'S A SHAME. THE PROGRAM
SUNSETTING. HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
WHEN THE MONEY BECOMES AVAILABLE
AGAIN, WE CAN FIRE IT BACK UP.
BUT IT'S EVER MORE IMPORTANT
THAN TO HAVE COORDINATION ACROSS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS. SO WE
MAXIMIZE THE MONEY THAT IS
AVAILABLE IN THE SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE THE MOST TO THOSE WHO
NEED IT THE MOST. SO THAT'S ALL
I HAVE TO SAY, BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. SENATOR. I
WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT THAT AS
THE STATE THINKS ABOUT THE,
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT REPORTING
ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
EXPENDITURES, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IS, ARE WE INCLUDING
THE RESOURCES REYES THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH THE LEAS TO
SUPPORT THOSE GOALS, RECOGNIZING
THAT WE SHOULD NOT AND CANNOT
SEPARATE OUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUPPORT
THROUGH OUR LEAS FROM THE CORE
PROGRAM, IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT. BUT BUT WE NEED TO THINK
MORE HOLISTICALLY ABOUT THE
UNIVERSE OF FUNDING AND HOW WE
LEVERAGE IT. AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO WITH
DCS AND THE ADMINISTRATION, BOTH
ON THE REVENUE REPORTING SIDE AS
WELL AS THE OUTCOME AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SIDE. RECOGNIZING
THAT PREVENTING SCHOOL FAILURE
CONTINUES TO BE RECOGNIZED AS A
CORE GOAL OF THE HRSA. WELL, AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
ANECDOTALLY THAT ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE RAISED IN THE WAY
BACK, I MEAN, I'VE BEEN HERE FOR
A LONG TIME, WAS THAT PERHAPS WE
SHOULD OUR MEDI-CAL PLANS,
COUNTY PLANS, SHOULD BE MORE
INVOLVED ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SITES FOR A WHOLE VARIETY OF
REASONS, BOTH AS NAVIGATORS AND
TO GET PEOPLE ENROLLED WHO
FAMILIES ENROLLED, WHO WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE BE ENROLLED. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AT LEAST IN
SOME COUNTIES, THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND THAT EFFORT NEEDS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE MEASUREMENT AS
WELL, BECAUSE THAT'S A SERVICE
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE TO BE
FUNDED BY SOMEONE ELSE. THAT'S A
GREAT. OFFICIALLY, MOVING ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON THE REPORT
PORTION, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, THE COMMISSION RECEIVES
FUNDING THROUGH THE MENTAL
HEALTH WELLNESS ACT. THAT'S $20
MILLION A YEAR. AND THOSE FUNDS
ARE, ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMISSION UNDER THE GUIDELINES
OF THAT ACT THAT SAYS IT IS TO
PREVENT SUPPORT, PREVENTION OR
INTERVENTION OR RESPONSE TO
CRISIS, WE DID AN ANALYSIS OF
WHERE WE HAD BEEN INVESTING
THROUGH THE LENS OF THE LIFESPAN
AND RECOGNIZED THAT WE WERE
DEFICIENT IN THE VERY YOUNG AGES
AND FOR OLDER ADULTS. AND SO, IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING, WE
PRIORITIZED FUNDS TO SUPPORT
THESE TWO INTERVENTIONS THAT
TARGET THE NEEDS OF OLDER
ADULTS. AGAIN, BASED ON GUIDANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING,
ONE OF OUR COUNTIES THAT
RECEIVED FUNDING THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENT HAS
RECENTLY NOTIFIED US THAT THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO USE THE
FUNDS. SO THERE'S $1 MILLION
LEFT OVER. IT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
WINDOW THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
REAPPROPRIATE IT. AND SO OUR ASK
IS TO ALLOW US TO REAPPROPRIATE
THAT TO BOLSTER THE FUNDING THAT
WE HAVE PROVIDED TO THE OTHER
PARTNERS, JUST TO EXTEND THE
IMPACT. THESE ARE EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT OLDER ADULTS
TO STAY IN THEIR HOME AND TO,
YOU KNOW, LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
THEIR THEIR JUST Kò PROGRAMS
THAT IDEALLY WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SCALE WELL. BUT RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE DEPENDENT ON THIS
TYPE OF GRANT FUNDING. AND SO
THEY ASK IS TO REAPPROPRIATE
THOSE DOLLARS SO WE CAN REINVEST
THEM INTO THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE. THERE WILL
BE NO DELAY IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN, BECAUSE THE WAY WE WROTE
THE PROCUREMENT IS THAT
UNALLOCATED FUNDS WOULD BE
REDISTRIBUTED TO THE EXISTING
GRANT RECIPIENTS. AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT THERE WERE NO
APPLICANTS WHO WERE NOT FUNDED.
AND SO IT'S NOT. SO THE MONEY
WOULD NOT BE TAKEN AWAY FROM
ANYBODY. IT'S MONEY THAT WAS
VOLUNTARILY RELINQUISHED. RIGHT.
OKAY. WELL, ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM, WILL OWENS
WITH THE LAO, WE HAVE NOT RAISED
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
OKAY. NATE WILLIAMS, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, NOTHING TO ADD.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. NOW MOVING MOVING
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES
.
NEW FACES. WOULD YOU LIKE US TO
JUMP IN WITH ISSUE ONE? YES
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. YES. GOOD
IT'S TIME TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M PAULA WILHELM. I'M THE
INTERIM DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES, AND WE HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM CHANGES
RELATED TO OUR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH AND OUR DRUG MEDI-CAL AND
DRUG MEDI-CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEM PROGRAMS FOR, CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR AND COMING FISCAL
YEAR. SO, AS YOU ALL ARE AWARE,
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO CHOOSE FROM
AND HIGHLIGHT, AND I'M GOING TO
FOCUS MY REMARKS ON A COUPLE OF
OUR CORE MULTIYEAR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVES. SO THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCING AND
INNOVATING MEDI-CAL INITIATIVE,
OR CAL AIM, BEGAN BACK IN
CALENDAR YEAR 2022, AND THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO PHASE IN
THOSE POLICY CHANGES OVER TIME.
DHS IS ALSO CURRENTLY SEEKING
APPROVAL FROM OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AT THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
FOR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZED
NETWORKS OF CARE AND TREATMENT
DEMONSTRATION, ALSO KNOWN AS
CONNECT. AND, IF APPROVED, SOME
COMPONENTS OF CONNECT MAY BE
IMPLEMENTED BEGINNING IN JANUARY
2025, SO I'LL PROVIDE JUST A FEW
UPDATES ON CAL-AIM AND THEN
PREVIEW THE CONNECT POLICIES
THAT WE PROPOSE TO IMPLEMENT
BEGINNING IN 2025, AS YOU MAY BE
AWARE, OUR CORE CAL-AIM
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVES
ARE MEANT TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
WHOLE PERSON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE AND IMPROVE QUALITY
OUTCOMES. AND WE WANTED TO
ACHIEVE THIS IN PART BY REDUCING
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY ACROSS
OUR SPECIALTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. SO THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO MONITOR
AND SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION OF
SOME OF THE KEY POLICY CHANGES
FROM THE PAST FEW YEARS,
INCLUDING UPDATES TO THE
CRITERIA FOR ACCESSING OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
SERVICES IMPLEMENTATION OF
STANDARDIZED SCREENING AND
TRANSITION TOOLS FOR MEDI-CAL
MEMBERS WHO ARE SEEKING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
UPDATES TO OUR CLINICAL
DOCUMENTATION POLICIES,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PAYMENT
REFORM, A NEW MODEL TO PAY OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS.
THE NO WRONG DOOR POLICY, WHICH
IS MEANT TO ENSURE THAT MEDI-CAL
MEMBERS CAN ACCESS TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES REGARDLESS OF THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN WHICH THEY
FIRST SEEK CARE, SO IN ADDITION
TO THOSE ONGOING INITIATIVES IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR, THE
DEPARTMENT IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANS AND OUR COMMUNITY BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS HAVE
ALSO FOCUSED ON EXPANDING
MEDI-CAL PEER SUPPORT SERVICES
AND OUR RECOVERY INCENTIVES
PROGRAM AND IMPLEMENTING MOBILE
CRISIS RESPONSE SERVICES. SO TO
DATE, 51 OUT OF 58 COUNTIES HAVE
OPTED TO COVER MEDI-CAL PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES. AND MORE THAN
1800 MEDI-CAL PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALISTS HAVE NOW BEEN
CERTIFIED TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA,
TURNING TO OUR RECOVERY
INCENTIVES PROGRAM, WE HAVE 19
OF OUR DRUG MEDI-CAL ORGANIZED
DELIVERY SYSTEM COUNTIES THAT
ARE NOW ABLE TO OFFER
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT, WHICH IS
AN EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER, AS YOU MAY BE AWARE,
WE ARE PROUD OF THIS PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
IN THE NATION TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
APPROVAL TO COVER CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IN MEDICAID THROUGH
AN 1115 MEDICAID WAIVER
AUTHORITY, AND SO AT THIS POINT,
WE'RE ABOUT A YEAR INTO PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION, AND 88% OF OUR
MEDI-CAL MEMBERS LIVE IN ONE OF
THOSE COUNTIES THAT HAS AT LEAST
ONE, CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
PROVIDER IN OPERATION. SO ALSO,
ALL 58 COUNTIES ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO IMPLEMENT MEDI-CAL MOBILE
CRISIS SERVICES, B BY THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR. SO 46 COUNTIES
WERE REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT BY
DECEMBER 31ST OF 2023. AND THE
12 REMAINING COUNTIES, SMALLER
RURAL COUNTIES THAT WE GAVE A
LITTLE MORE RUNWAY TO WORK OUT
REIMBURSEMENT MODELS ARE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT BY JUNE
30TH OF 2024. SO LOOKING AHEAD
TO THE COMING FISCAL YEAR, DHS
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
PLANNING AND DESIGNING OUR
CONNECT INITIATIVE. ON OCTOBER
20TH OF LAST YEAR, WE COMPLETED
A MAJOR MILESTONE BY SUBMITTING
OUR APPLICATION TO CMS FOR THE
COMPONENTS OF CONNECT THAT WE
NEED TO IMPLEMENT THROUGH
ANOTHER MEDICAID SECTION 1115
DEMONSTRATION WAIVER. BEACH
CONNECT IS REALLY DESIGNED TO
COMPLEMENT AND BUILD ON THE
ARRAY OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW, OUR GOAL SORT OF
ACROSS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES IS
REALLY TO STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND
THE FULL CONTINUUM OF COMMUNITY
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO OUR
MEDI-CAL MEMBERS WITH
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. AND WE ALSO ARE STRIVING
TO IMPROVE ACCESS HEALTH EQUITY
AND QUALITY OF CARE. SO BEFORE I
CLOSE, I WILL TOUCH ON A FEW OF
THE INITIATIVES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN CONNECT, FIRST, WE
PROPOSE TO IMPLEMENT MEDI-CAL
COVERAGE FOR SEVERAL NEW
EVIDENCE BASED THERAPIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIGNIFICANT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. AND
THESE INCLUDE ASSERTIVE
COMMUNITY TREATMENT, COORDINATED
SPECIALTY CARE FOR FIRST EPISODE
PSYCHOSIS, CLUBHOUSE MODEL
SERVICES, SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT,
AND TRANSITIONAL RENT. DCS WILL
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
SERVICES, IN PART BY
ESTABLISHING CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE, SO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE HUBS TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS WITH
TRAINING AND IMPLEMENTATION SO
THAT THEY CAN IMPLEMENT THE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES WITH
HIGH FIDELITY AND WILL OFFER. WE
ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO OFFER
INCENTIVE FUNDS TO COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS FOR
IMPLEMENTING AND SCALING THE NEW
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES, AND
THEN ULTIMATELY DEMONSTRATING
IMPROVEMENTS IN HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
ACCESSING THESE SERVICES. AS, AS
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE AGENDA
TODAY, WE ARE ALSO SEEKING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE, WHICH WILL
ADMINISTER, IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION, OR HCAI.
WE'RE SEEKING TO SUPPORT BOTH
LONG AND SHORT TERM INVESTMENTS
IN THE WORKFORCE, AND PROBABLY
DON'T NEED TO TELL ANYBODY THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE SORELY
NEEDED IN ORDER TO LIFT UP THE
NEW SERVICES WE'RE PROPOSING TO
COVER HELP REALIZE THE PROMISE
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE, ETC.
WE CANNOT DO THAT WITHOUT A
ROBUST AND REPRESENTATIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE,
CONNECT ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL
COMPONENTS INTENDED TO SUPPORT
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM, WHO
ALSO HAVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS. SO A COUPLE OF PROGRAMS
WE'RE EXCITED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH INCLUDE ACTIVITY FUNDS,
WHICH WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO PAY
FOR ACTIVITIES AND SUPPORTS THAT
PROMOTE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
WELL-BEING, AND SUPPORT,
CHILDREN WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED,
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
EFFECTS FROM TRAUMA. WE'RE ABLE
TO ADMINISTER THAT THAT FUNDING.
IS IT COMING OUT OF SCHOOLS OR
HOW WOULD A CHILD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT GREAT QUESTION. SO
THAT'S, ONE OF THE PIECES THAT
WE ARE SEEKING FEDERAL APPROVAL
ON NOW. AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT,
WHETHER IT WOULD BE DCS OR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ADMINISTERING DIRECTLY, BUT THAT
IS TO BE DETERMINED. AND THEN,
WAS ALSO GOING TO MENTION THE
CROSS SECTOR INCENTIVE PROGRAM,
AND THAT WOULD BE A INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO FACILITATE,
COLLABORATION AND DRIVE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES ACROSS AGENCIES THAT
SERVE THE CHILD WELFARE INVOLVED
POPULATION. SO THESE WOULD BE
INCENTIVE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS,
WORKING IN CONCERT WITH OUR
MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
OUR CHILD WELFARE AGENCY IS SO
AVAILABLE TO ALL THREE ENTITIES,
AND FINALLY, I'LL MENTION THAT
BEACH CONNECT ALSO INCLUDES AN
OPTION FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANS TO RECEIVE MEDICAID
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED DURING SHORT TERM STAYS
IN FACILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED AS INSTITUTIONS FOR
MENTAL DISEASE, BUT THIS IS ONLY
AVAILABLE IF THE COUNTY AGREES
TO COVER THAT FULL ARRAY OF NEW
EVIDENCE BASED THERAPIES. Tð,
AND TO REINVEST ANY DOLLARS
GENERATED THROUGH THE
DEMONSTRATION INTO COMMUNITY
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHILE MEETING NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS. SO AGAIN, WE ARE
NEGOTIATING THE TERMS OF THIS
PROGRAM WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS. RIGHT NOW, WE HOPE TO
OBTAIN APPROVAL BY THE END OF
THE CALENDAR YEAR, AND THEN
WOULD BE ABLE TO BEGIN ROLLING
OUT THE COMPONENTS IN 2025. SO I
WILL CLOSE THERE. BUT HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT THE MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES
. WE GOT APPROVED FOR A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD. ARE WE LOOKING
AHEAD OF POST 2027, AND YOU KNOW
, A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS LOVE
THIS ABILITY, TO BE ABLE TO, GET
THIS FEDERAL MATCH FOR MOBILE
CRISIS. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TOO
EARLY TO START HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I FEEL LIKE IT'S
NEVER. BUT JUST WANT TO GET
FURTHER INSIGHT ON THAT. YES.
SO, WE HAVE ADDED MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES AS A MEDI-CAL BENEFIT,
SO WE ENVISION THAT CONTINUING
TO BE AVAILABLE AFTER THE PERIOD
WHEN THE ENHANCED FEDERAL MATCH
IS AVAILABLE. AND WHAT'S I MEAN,
WHAT'S THE SUCCESS RATE? AND DO
WE SEE THESE AT EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY? I DON'T THINK MAYBE
EVERY SINGLE COUNTY HAS IT, BUT
AT WHAT POINT WILL WE START
GETTING FEEDBACK ON ON THIS
PROGRAM? YEAH. AND WHEN YOU
ANSWERED THAT ALSO, IS THERE
STANDARDIZATION BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS. SO I
THINK THEY LOOK DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT PLACES. YEAH. THOSE
ARE GREAT QUESTIONS, SO RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE 31 COUNTIES THAT
HAVE FULLY IMPLEMENTED THE
BENEFIT IN A MANNER THAT IS
COMPLIANT WITH OUR GUIDANCE. AND
SO THAT INCLUDES, YOU KNOW,
BEING ABLE TO COVER THE COUNTY'S
WHOLE GEOGRAPHY, BEING ABLE TO
HAVE THE SERVICE AVAILABLE 24
OVER SEVEN, AND THEN WE HAVE 15
COUNTIES THAT ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK TO BE BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
IN THE WAY THAT IS REQUIRED TO
GET THE ENHANCED FEDERAL MATCH.
SO IN THOSE 15 COUNTIES, THEY
MAY HAVE SOME MOBILE CRISIS,
CAPACITY, AND THEY MAY BE
RESPONDING, AS THEY'RE ABLE TO,
BUT THEY'RE NOT ALL THE WAY TO
MEETING THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
ENHANCED FEDERAL MATCH, AND THEN
THE REMAINING FINAL 12 COUNTIES
HAVE UNTIL JUNE 30TH TO
IMPLEMENT, AND THEN TO THE
STANDARDIZATION. ARE THEY ALL.
YEAH. SO WE HAVE A PRETTY
EXTENSIVE GUIDANCE ON WHAT WE
EXPECT. MOBILE CRISIS RESPONSE
TO LOOK LIKE AND SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE TO MEET.
AND THAT INCLUDES, TIMELY
RESPONSE AND, AND THE WAY THAT
FOLKS ARE ABLE TO HAVE A NUMBER
TO CALL IN. AND, THE 24 OVER
SEVEN ACCESS REQUIREMENT, SO I
THINK WE HAVE BOTH A REALLY
STRONG FRAMEWORK IN OUR GUIDANCE
, AND WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING A LOT
OF DEDICATED TO ON THIS TOPIC,
SO THE BENEFIT IS STANDARDIZED.
THERE WILL, OF COURSE, NEED TO
BE SOME LOCAL VARIATION AND
INNOVATION JUST TO ACCOUNT FOR
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIES, ETC. AND
IS THIS A MIXTURE OF BOTH JUST
MENTAL HEALTH? IS IT ALL JUST
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE TEAMS OR
IS IT ALSO PARAMEDICINE RESPONSE
TEAMS. YEAH, SO THERE IS A LARGE
ARRAY OF DIFFERENT PROFESSIONALS
THAT ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE ON
THE TEAM IN ORDER TO AGAIN MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS TO OBTAIN
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. AND SO,
PARAMEDICS ARE ONE OF THE
APPROVED TYPES OF PROFESSIONALS.
RYAN, ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT
FROM ELIO, NOTHING TO ADD, BUT
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. NATE
NATE, IS IT NATE WILLIAMS,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING TO
ADD. GREAT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO, NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAM LICENSING
TRUST FUND. ALL RIGHT, SO TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL, THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF 500,000
FOR BUDGET YEAR AND ONGOING. AND
THIS IS FOR THE NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAM OR NP
LICENSING TRUST FUND, AND THIS
REQUEST IS REALLY TO ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO EXPEND ALL THE
AVAILABLE FUNDS THAT WE HAVE
COLLECTED FROM OUR NP LICENSING
FEES, SO WE USE THE FUND REVENUE
TO SUPPORT OUR OVERSIGHT AND
COMPLIANCE MONITORING FOR ALL OF
THE LICENSED ENTITIES. BUT OUR
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT GRANT THE
ONGOING EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
THAT WE NEED TO ACCESS THE WHOLE
FUND, INCLUDING A 10% RESERVE.
AND SO WHEN WE DO EXPERIENCE
THOSE SHORTFALLS BETWEEN WHAT WE
NEED TO SPEND AND THE EXISTING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY, WE HAVE
TO SEEK GENERAL FUND RELIEF. SO
THE PURPOSE OF THIS REQUEST IS
REALLY WE ARE ASKING FOR AN
AMOUNT THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
SUPPORT OUR OUR LICENSING
OVERSIGHT OPERATIONS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE NEEDING TO INCREASE
THE FEES OR ASK FOR MORE. WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING CAREFULLY AT OUR
BUDGETS AND THINK WE WILL BE
ABLE TO OPERATE WITHIN THIS
AMOUNT. SO WE JUST NEED THE
AUTHORITY FOR HOW LONG, THE OUR
ARE ABLE TO OPERATE UNDER THIS
FOR 500,000. FOR HOW LONG? WE
DON'T HAVE. WE HAVEN'T
IDENTIFIED A YEAR AT WHICH THIS
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH AT THIS
POINT. LIKE THIS IS. YEAH OKAY.
RYAN, ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT? WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL, NATE. NOTHING FURTHER
TO ADD. THANK YOU. HOLDING THE
ITEM OPEN. MOVING ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BRIDGE HOUSING PROGRAM FUNDING
SHIFT. ALL RIGHT, SO DUE TO
LOWER THAN PROJECTED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT REVENUES,
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO SHIFT 265
MILLION FROM OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUNDS THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED IN THE 2023 BUDGET
ACT TO THE GENERAL FUND IN 2024,
25, THIS SHIFT WILL ACTUALLY NOT
HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE TIMELINE
FOR DISTRIBUTING THE BRIDGE
HOUSING FUNDS, PENDING BUDGET
APPROVAL, WE HAVE A CURRENT
ROUND OF BRIDGE HOUSING FUNDS
THAT, JUST CLOSED IN THE
BEGINNING OF APRIL. THAT WAS 265
MILLION AVAILABLE THROUGH
COMPETITIVE APPLICATIONS TO
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES. WE WOULD PLAN TO MAKE
THOSE AWARD ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM
THAT 265 MILLION IN JULY 2024,
AND SO THAT WOULD COINCIDE WITH
THE COMING FISCAL YEAR AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE DELAYED
FUNDS, THERE'S ALSO A PROPOSAL
TO DELAY 235 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND ORIGINALLY PLANNED FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR TWO, 25, 26. AND IN
THAT EVENT, WE WOULD, RELEASE
THE NEXT ROUND OF BRIDGE HOUSING
ON A SIMILAR TIMELINE IN 2025.
WE THINK THAT THE PROPOSED
DELAYS ARE REASONABLE IN LIGHT
OF THE BUDGET CONDITION AND THAT
THE FUNDING SHIFT IS REASONABLE
IN LIGHT OF REVISED LOWER
ESTIMATED REVENUES INTO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND.
THANK YOU. NATE WILLIAMS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. CHILDREN
AND YOUTH. YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE FEE SCHEDULE
TBL. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS, PROPOSAL, TO START WITH A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSAL,
THE 2023 BUDGET ACT INCLUDED $10
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE KHÎI
FEE SCHEDULE PROGRAM, IN THE
FALL OF 2023, THE DEPARTMENT
ISSUED A REQUEST FOR INFORMATION
AND SELECTED A VENDOR. WE'VE
PARTNERED WITH CAROLINE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO SERVE IN
THAT CAPACITY, AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CAROLINE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION, LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND HEALTH PLANS TO
STAND UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR THE TPA TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE IN THAT
STATEWIDE CAPACITY, TO SERVE
BOTH THE HEALTH PLANS AND THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. IS
THIS THE THIRD PARTY THAT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER FOR THE LAST?
NO, THAT WAS A DIFFERENT THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE GRANTS.
THIS IS SPECIFICALLY TO SERVE,
THE HEALTH PLANS AND THE LEAS AS
AN INTERMEDIARY FOR
ADMINISTERING THE FEE SCHEDULE
PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY, I'LL TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT
THEIR ROLE IS, BUT THE IDEA IS
TO CENTRALIZE THE HEALTH PLAN
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS INTO A
SINGLE STATEWIDE, INFRASTRUCTURE
OR ENTITY SO THAT, ALL OF THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEE SCHEDULE
PROGRAM WILL GO THROUGH ONE
SINGLE, CENTRALIZED STATEWIDE
ENTITY RATHER THAN MANAGING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH
INDIVIDUAL HEALTH PLAN
SEPARATELY AND SPECIFICALLY THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR IN
THIS ROLE WILL SUPPORT BOTH THE
HEALTH PLANS AND THE LEAS BY
STREAMLINING THE OVERSIGHT AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE FALL TO EACH
HEALTH PLAN. TO SEPARATELY
ADMINISTER THE. WITHOUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE, ONGOING, THE
PARTICIPATING LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEMS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO COORDINATE BENEFITS
FOR ALL STUDENTS RECEIVING SIP
FEE SCHEDULE SERVICES. FIGURE
OUT WHICH PLAN IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR COVERAGE. SUBMIT CLAIMS TO
THE HEALTH PLANS. AND BE SUBJECT
TO DIFFERENT OVERSIGHT PROCESSES
OF EACH PLAN, A SIGNIFICANT
MAJORITY OF THE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND NEARLY ALL OF THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES LACK
ANY PRIOR EXPERIENCE WITH
BILLING, HEALTH PLANS FOR
STUDENT HEALTH SERVICES, AND NOR
DO THEY HAVE THE NECESSARY
BILLING INFRASTRUCTURE AND DATA
SYSTEMS TO MANAGE DIRECT
CLAIMING PROCESSES WITH THE
VOLUME OF PLANS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AS A REMINDER,
THE SIP FEE SCHEDULE PROGRAM IS
A MULTI PAYER OBLIGATION. SO
IT'S THE MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS, THE COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS, OR HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE AND DISABILITY INSURERS
THAT ARE REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ARE ALL OBLIGATED
UNDER EXISTING STATE LAW TO
REIMBURSE SCHOOL LINKED
PROVIDERS FOR THE PROVISION OF
OUTPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
PROVIDED TO A STUDENT IN A
SCHOOL LINKED SETTING, WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS IS WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE LA COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND HEALTH PLANS, IS
THAT THIS IS A SUPREMELY
COMPLICATED INITIATIVE TO STAND
UP. AND AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR,
EWING WAS SPEAKING ABOUT EARLIER
WITH THE FOUNDATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT, AS WELL AS WITH THE STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. WE'VE STARTED TO
INITIATE PROGRAMS THAT BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE HEALTH
PLANS, THE COUNTIES, THE LEAS
AND THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. BUT THESE ARE NEWER
RELATIONSHIPS THAT DIDN'T
PREVIOUSLY EXIST. AND THE, THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION OF THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR IS
REALLY TO SUPPORT BOTH THE
HEALTH PLANS BY TAKING ON SOME
OF THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD EACH
SEPARATELY HAVE TO ADMINISTER,
BUT ALSO TO REALLY SUPPORT AND
FACILITATE THE PARTICIPATION OF
THE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. SO
THAT THEY ONLY HAVE ONE,
OVERSIGHT ENTITY TO NAVIGATE AND
PARTNER WITH, RATHER THAN 100
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES ACROSS THE
STATE THROUGH ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT PAYER SYSTEMS, THIS
WILL YOU KNOW, THIS CAME ABOUT
THROUGH OUR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS. IT CAME UP
THROUGH OUR WORKGROUP AND A
RECOMMENDATION SPECIFICALLY FROM
OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND LÀ PARTNERS THAT, YOU KNOW,
HAVING A STATEWIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD REALLY
SUPPORT AND ENABLE THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE FIRST COHORT OF LEAS.
WE LAUNCHED THIS PROGRAM IN
JANUARY OF 20 24, 47 LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ACROSS 25
COUNTIES, INCLUDING ALL OF THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION,
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
US, CAROL, ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND ALL OF THE HEALTH PLAN
PAYERS TO KIND OF NORMALIZE ALL
OF THESE OPERATIONAL PROCEDURES,
IMPLEMENT ALL OF THE NECESSARY
DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS, AND SET
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
NEEDED. AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
PROPOSAL IS REALLY MEANT TO
SUPPORT THE ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE. EVER SINCE WE
HAD THE INITIAL PILOT FUNDING
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE
PROGRAM, THE IDEA BEHIND THE FEE
IS THAT WE WOULD, USE THAT FEE
BY CHARGING A SMALL, REASONABLE
FEE TO THE HEALTH PLAN PAYERS
SINCE THE TPA WILL TAKE ON THOSE
FUNCTIONS ON THEIR BEHALF. AND
CONTINUE TO FUND THIS CONTRACT
INTO THE LONG TERM TO SUPPORT
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
WE'VE NOT RAISED CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. NATE WILLIAMS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD, SENATOR EGGMAN.
YEAH, I WOULD JUST SAY SO WE
FEEL LIKE IT'S GOING TO WORK
BECAUSE WHEN WE FIRST STARTED
WORKING ON THIS, THE SCHOOL
SAID, WE CAN'T WE CAN'T DO THE
BILLING. AND THE PLANS WERE
LIKE, WHOA, WHAT ARE WE DOING
HERE? SO WE FEEL LIKE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS, WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
COME UP WITH THIS, THIS ENTITY
THAT'S GOING TO DO THE, THE
RIGHT REPORT TO THIS IS ALL
GOING TO WORK OUT. I WE'RE VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS THE BEST
PATH FORWARD, THIS FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEE
SCHEDULE PROGRAM IS REALLY ABOUT
LEARNING. SO WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A
PRETTY INTENSIVE LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE MODEL FOR THE
FIRST COHORT. THAT'S AGAIN
STARTED IN JANUARY. WE PUT OUT
THE APPLICATIONS FOR THE SECOND
COHORT. AND HAD 98 LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES APPLY TO BE A
PART OF THE SECOND COHORT. WE'VE
BEEN MEETING IN NEARLY BIWEEKLY
SESSIONS WITH ALL OF THE
IMPLEMENT PARTNERS TO WORK
THROUGH ALL OF THE OPERATIONAL
COMPLEXITY IS, LIKE I SAID, THIS
IS NEW FOR THE LEAS, THIS IS
VERY NEW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WHO WE'VE
BEEN ALSO WORKING WITH CLOSELY,
AS WELL AS THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS. AND SO WE REALLY THINK
THAT WITHOUT THIS TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE, IT WOULD NOT BE
FEASIBLE FOR MANY OF OUR LA
PARTNERS OR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS BILLING
OPPORTUNITY. AND REALLY, THIS IS
A SUSTAINABLE, LONG TERM,
PERMANENT SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
SUSTAIN SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH AND OUTPATIENT SUD
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS BY HOLDING
THE PLANS ACCOUNTABLE. AND SO
THIS YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
EASY, IT DOES MAKE IT EASIER
THOUGH. AND IT REDUCES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY
SIGNIFICANTLY BY HAVING ALL OF
THIS GO THROUGH ONE ENTITY. SO
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT, THEY
HAVE TO HAVE, YOU KNOW, DATA
EXCHANGE AND THEY HAVE TO UPLOAD
THEIR CLAIMS DATA INTO THIS
SYSTEM. WITHOUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE, THEY WOULD HAVE
TO DO THAT FOR EVERY PLAN THAT
IS A PAIR WITHIN THE SYSTEM. AND
IF YOU THINK ABOUT A COUNTY LIKE
LOS ANGELES, THAT'S A LOT OF
MANY, MANY PLANS THAT EACH LA
WOULD HAVE TO NAVIGATE
SEPARATELY. AND IT AND IT'S
GREAT THAT WE'VE GOT THIS PART
OF IT WORKED OUT. BUT HOW DO WE
HOW ARE WE MEASURING SUCCESS FOR
THE ACTUAL PROGRAM. YEAH. SO AND
TO ANSWER SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU WERE RAISING WITH, TOBY
EWING EARLIER TODAY, THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IS LEADING THE
EVALUATION WORK FOR THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. BROADLY, THEY'VE
CONTRACTED WITH MATHEMATICA TO
CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF ALL 20 WORK
STREAMS OF THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE, INCLUDING THE FEE
SCHEDULE PROGRAM AND THE FIVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE WORKING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS TÔI WORK STREAMS
ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
MATHEMATICA, INCLUDING OUR
DEPARTMENT. SO THINKING ABOUT
THE STRATEGY, SEE IF WE FOCUS ON
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES AND THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACT, WITH THE STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCENTIVE
PROGRAM, OR SB HIP WITH THE CAL
HOPE ACL PROGRAM AROUND SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL LEARNING, THE
WELL-BEING AND MINDFULNESS
GRANTS. AND NOW THIS FEE
SCHEDULE. THIS IS REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL AND BUILDING OUT A
STRATEGY FOR SUPPORTING SCHOOLS
WHO ARE THE ONES WHO ARE SEEING
OUR KIDS MORE FREQUENTLY THAN
THEIR PARENTS ARE, AND IN SOME
CASES, SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
MATHEMATICA ON A RESULTS BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT
WILL INCLUDE SPECIFIC REPORTING
AND DASHBOARD REPORTING SO THAT
WE CAN SAY HOW MANY KIDS ARE
GETTING SERVICES THROUGH THESE,
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS ON, WHEN
WOULD THAT BE LIVE? WELL, SO THE
PROGRAM'S JUST GETTING UP OFF
THE GROUND FOR THE FEE SCHEDULE
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE, BUT WE
WOULD START TO IMPLEMENT THE
DASHBOARD ON A QUARTERLY BASIS.
ONCE WE HAVE DATA THAT WE CAN
POPULATE, AND PROBABLY STARTING
IN EARLY 2025, WE'LL HAVE DATA
THAT WE CAN START TO POPULATE IN
THAT SPACE. BUT WE'D BE LOOKING
AT A VARIETY OF METRICS,
INCLUDING, NOT JUST UTILIZATION
BUT UTILIZATION BY PAYERS. SO
WE'LL KNOW WHICH KIDS ARE
GETTING SERVICES BASED ON
COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS. WE'LL
ALSO KNOW WHO'S GETTING CARE,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION, HOW THEY'RE
BEING PROVIDED SERVICES AND WHAT
TYPES OF SERVICES ARE BEING
DELIVERED TO STUDENTS IN A
SCHOOL LINKED SETTING. SO WE'VE
INCLUDED A BROAD ARRAY OF
SERVICES IN THE FEE SCHEDULE
PROGRAM, INCLUDING A WIDE ARRAY
OF PSYCHOEDUCATION SERVICES,
TREATMENT SERVICES, AND
SCREENING AND ASSESSMENT AND
CARE COORDINATION. SO THAT WE'RE
REALLY SUPPORTING WHAT SCHOOLS
ARE ALREADY DOING AND PROVIDING
AND THAT'S AND THAT ALSO THAT
DATA STREAM GOES TO TOBY AS
WELL. RIGHT. BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE MEASURING OR
ACCOUNTING FOR ALL THE MONEY
THAT GOES INTO MENTAL HEALTH IN
EVERY COUNTY, NOW. SO I MEAN,
THE DASHBOARD AND THE EVALUATION
WILL BE PUBLICLY REPORTED. BUT
YES, WE DO WORK WITH MENTAL
HEALTH OR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. OUR ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. AND LIKE I SAID, I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT IS THE STRATEGY BEHIND ALL
OF THE SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
INVESTMENTS AND HOW WE CAN SHOW
ALL OF THESE PARTNERSHIPS,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, THE MHSA AND SB
HIP, ARE FOUNDATIONAL TO THE
WELL-BEING AND MINDFULNESS
GRANTS ARE FOCUSING ON REALLY
THAT PRIMARY PREVENTION FOCUS
AROUND WELL-BEING, MINDFULNESS,
WELLNESS CENTERS IN SCHOOLS, AND
THEN THE FEE SCHEDULE LAYERS ON
TOP OF ALL OF THAT TO PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF ONGOING
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE HEALTH
PLANS FOR THEIR ENROLLED
MEMBERS, TO THE SCHOOLS
DIRECTLY. SO THAT'S NOT ALL
COMING THROUGH THE STATE TO FUND
IN THE LONG TERM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY. MOVING ON
TO DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
. WE MAY MAKE IT BY TWO. I HOPE
SO I HAVE A FLIGHT I GOT A RIDE
TO. I HAVE A RIDE AT TWO AS
WELL. OH YOU DO. SO IF IT GOES
LONG I'LL RELIEVE YOU FOR THE
RESTROOM BEFORE I TAKE OFF.
THAT'S WE'RE GOING TO KICK OFF
WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW. BRIEF
BRIEF. I'LL KEEP IT REALLY
BRIEF. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
STEPHANIE CLENDENNEN, DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS MANAGES THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM
. DSHS MISSION IS TO PROVIDE
EVALUATION AND TREATMENT IN A
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE MANNER BY
LEADING INNOVATION AND
EXCELLENCE ACROSS THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE AND SETTINGS. WE OPERATE
THE FIVE STATE HOSPITALS LOCATED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. A
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM,
WHICH IS A SYSTEM OF COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES THAT'S OPERATED
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND PRIVATE PROVIDERS, AND THIS
IS DESIGNED TO TRANSITION
PATIENTS BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. FOLLOWING A FORENSIC
COMMITMENT TO DSH. AND WE ALSO
HAVE PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS,
PRIVATE PROVIDERS AND COUNTY
SHERIFFS TO PROVIDE COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION, DIVERSION
OPPORTUNITIES, JAIL BASED
TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT AS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL. THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE SERVED BY OUR SYSTEM
ARE MANDATED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT BY EITHER THE CRIMINAL
OR CIVIL COURT JUDGE OR THE
BOARD OF PAROLE OR PAROLE
HEARINGS, AND THE MAJORITY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE ARE
EITHER FORENSIC COMMITMENTS THEY
HAVE EITHER COMMITTED OR HAVE
BEEN ACCUSED OF COMMITTING
CRIMES LINKED TO THEIR MENTAL
ILLNESS, AND THEN WE ALSO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONSERVED
THROUGH THE CIVIL COURTS UNDER
THE LANTERMAN-PETRIS-SHORT ACT,
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR FISCAL YEAR 2425 TOTALS 3.4
BILLION, WHICH IS A DECREASE OF
85.3 MILLION. AND WITH 12 NEW
PROPOSED POSITIONS IN BUDGET
YEAR, THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROJECTING A CENSUS OF 8163 BY
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR, 9267
ACROSS ITS PROGRAMS. BY THE END
OF FISCAL YEAR 20 2425, AND THAT
INCREASE IS PRIMARILY RELATED TO
EXPANDING CAPACITY FOR THE
TREATMENT OF INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL INDIVIDUALS,
PRIMARILY THROUGH THE EXPANSION
OF COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
AND DIVERSION, WITH SOME SMALL
INCREASES IN CAPACITY AND CENSUS
PLANNED AT OUR STATE HOSPITALS.
AND J.B. CGRTS, I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS JUST TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT. I KNOW
THAT THIS HAS BEEN A BIG ISSUE,
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ON
THAT LIST AND BEING INNOVATIVE
AND GOING DOWN TO THE JAIL LEVEL
AND NOT WAITING FOR EVERYONE TO
GET, I THINK IT'S JUST IT'S
CERTAINLY SHORTEN THE LIST.
THANK YOU. I HAD, SIDE WELL,
IT'S RELATED, BUT I WANTED TO
KNOW ABOUT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
IN REGULAR PRISONS WHO ARE
DIAGNOSED. I'D AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT MAYBE IT'S I KNOW
IT'S A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT AND
THIS IS THERE A MAYBE THERE'S AN
ASSUMPTION THAT PERHAPS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS AN
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY, AT MINIMUM, IS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
WOULDN'T THAT ALONE DIVERT THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO GO NOT TO A
REGULAR PRISON, BUT TO A STATE
HOSPITAL, GOOD QUESTION. SO AS
IT RELATES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
IDD, THE, THERE IS A SEPARATE,
STRUCTURE WITHIN THE STATUTE FOR
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL, SO
WE THE STATUTE THAT RELATES TO
THE STATE HOSPITALS, PRIMARILY,
IS RELATED TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS, BUT
THERE IS A, A STRUCTURE AND A
STATUTORY CONSTRUCT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH IDD AND THAT,
AND THAT THEN IS TIED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. HOWEVER, SOME
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE REFERRED TO
THE DEPARTMENT. OKAY. AND THEN
HOW ARE OUR DIVERSION PROGRAMS
GOING? ARE WE SEEING A LITTLE
SUCCESS? I KNOW THERE IS A BIG
SHIFT. RIGHT? I JUST WANT TO
KNOW IF WE HAVE ANY EARLY DATA
ON HOW MANY WE'RE ABLE TO DIVERT
AWAY. GOOD QUESTION. I AM NOT
SURE I HAVE THE DIVERSION
STATISTICS WITH ME, BUT WE HAVE.
LET ME SEE. LET ME TAKE A LOOK
REAL QUICK WHAT I HAVE IN MY
LITTLE PACKET, BUT WE HAVE,
CURRENTLY ONLY, THE AS FAR AS
DIVERSION IS CONCERNED, WE HAD
THE PILOT PROGRAM AND THEN WE IN
THE IST SOLUTIONS THAT HAS BEEN
FUNDED TO, TO MAKE THOSE
PROGRAMS PERMANENT AND TO EXPAND
THEM, AS FAR AS IT RELATES TO
THE PILOT PROGRAM, WE'RE STILL
WITHIN THE PILOT PROGRAM AND
JUST FINISHING UP THE PILOT
PROGRAM. I THINK WE HAVE 29
COUNTIES THAT ARE PARTICIPATING
IN DIVERSION, AND THAT, PILOT
PROGRAM WAS, PROPOSED TO FUND UP
TO I THINK IT WAS, OH, 700 OR
800. LOOKING BACK TO MY, MY CREW
BACK THERE, THE, THEY'RE NOT
COMING TO SAVE ME TODAY, BUT
THE, IT WAS SEVERAL HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS TO BE TO BE DIVERTED
THROUGH THE PILOT PROGRAM, AND
THAT IS LARGELY COMING TO
COMPLETION. WE DO HAVE WITHIN
OUR BUDGET ESTIMATE BINDER, A
REPORT ON THE OUTCOMES, TO DATE,
BUT I DON'T HAVE THOSE HANDY AT
MY HAND, BUT IT'S A PILOT, SO
IT'S GOING TO END. IT IS GOING
TO END. BUT WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
FUNDED FOR THE ONGOING PROGRAM.
SO THE IST SOLUTIONS INCLUDED
FUNDING FOR US TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION AND
DIVERSION AND ALSO INCLUDED
FUNDING FOR US TO EXPAND AND TO
PROVIDE ACTUALLY INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE UP TO 5000
BEDS. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FOUND WITHIN
THE PILOT PROGRAM WAS ACTUALLY
THE ABILITY TO FIND HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS SO THAT WE ARE NOT
COMPETING WITH THE HOUSING STOCK
THAT ALREADY EXISTS. THE IST
SOLUTIONS PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND HOUSING
PER WITH A FOCUS ON FELONY
ARRESTS. AT WHAT POINT DO WE
HAVE IN THE DEPARTMENT AN
INTERNAL TIMELINE TO LOOK AT HOW
CARE CORPS IS GOING TO IMPACT
THE CAPACITY AT OUR STATE
HOSPITALS, DO WE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT INTERNALLY, WE'RE LOOKING
LIKE THIS IS HAS REALLY IMPACTED
THE OR DETERRED A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM COMING INTO STATE
HOSPITALS? YEAH GOOD QUESTION.
THE, YOU KNOW, CARE COURT IS
DESIGNED TO REALLY SERVE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SEE,
LARGELY, THAT ARE COMING INTO
THE DEPARTMENT AS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL, INDIVIDUALS THAT,
YOU KNOW, ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND HAVE SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS, YOU KNOW, THE
THAT WILL TAKE TIME FOR US TO,
TO REALLY BE ABLE TO SEE THE
IMPACTS. BUT IT IS LARGELY, THE
DESIGNED TO TREAT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE HAD BEEN
SEEING OVER THE RECENT YEARS,
THE, YOU KNOW, THE INCREASE IN
REFERRALS TO THE DEPARTMENT. AND
MAYBE I MISSED THIS. I APOLOGIZE
, GUYS, HOW ARE YOU KNOW, I SEE
THE NUMBERS ARE OVER FIVE
HOSPITALS. HOW ARE CAPACITY IS
WOULD YOU SAY THIS IS A GOOD
AMOUNT THAT WE HAVE OR IT LOOKS
LIKE IT APPEARS THAT THE RATIO
TO PERSON TO STAFF SEEMS PRETTY
GOOD, BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
COMPARING IT TO, YEAH. YOU TELL
ME MORE ABOUT HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE YOUR CAPACITY LEVELS
AND, AND YOUR RATIOS TO STAFF
TO. YEAH. INDIVIDUAL IN THERE.
SO A COUPLE OF THINGS I CAN
TOUCH ON. FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE
OVER 6000 INPATIENT BEDS IN THE
SYSTEM. AND OVERALL YOU KNOW
INSTITUTIONALIZATION IS NOT WHAT
WE WANT FOR OUR CALIFORNIANS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
HOWEVER, WE DO HAVE A LIKE I
SAID, 6000 BEDS. I WOULD SAY IF
YOU ASK ME THAT QUESTION SEVERAL
YEARS AGO, I WOULD HAVE SAID WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH BECAUSE WE
WERE, YOU KNOW, HAD THESE VERY
LARGE WAIT LISTS. AND, AND WE
WERE REALLY STRUGGLING TO
PROVIDE SERVICES, TODAY, YOU
KNOW, WE THROUGH THE EXPANSION
OF THE, OF THE WITH THE
EXPANSION OF OUR CAPACITY
OUTSIDE OF OUR STATE HOSPITAL
WALLS THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION AND DIVERSION
PROGRAMS, THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OUR WITH OUR SHERIFFS AND THEIR
JAILS AND OUR OUR COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION AND DIVERSION
PROGRAMS, AS WELL AS PRIVATE
PROVIDERS. WE ARE ALSO
CONTRACTING FOR SERVICES IN
COMMUNITY AND PATIENT FACILITIES
AS WELL. WE HAVE YOU KNOW, A
VERY ROBUST NOW CONTINUUM OF
CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS, TO KIND OF
MEET THE NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE.
AT VARYING DIFFERENT LEVELS
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. SO AS FAR AS
CAPACITY, WE'RE DOING FAIRLY
WELL NOW, AND WE STILL HAVE
FUNDING TO BUILD OUT THOSE 5000
BEDS FOR COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION AND DIVERSION, SO
QUITE A BIT OF CAPACITY THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US, BUT NOT
ALL OF IT. NOW IS WITHIN THE
STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM. AND THEN
I WOULD SAY WITH RESPECT TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT LIKE STAFFING AND
THE STAFF TO PATIENT RATIOS, SO
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED STAFF TO
PATIENT RATIOS FOR, OUR CLINICAL
PROVIDERS AND OUR NURSING STAFF
AS IT RELATES TO THE LEVEL OF
CARE THAT AN INDIVIDUAL HAS
WITHIN IS, WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
SO, YOU KNOW, OUR ACUTE,
PROGRAMS GENERALLY RUN AROUND
THE 1 TO 15 WHERE OUR ICF
PROGRAMS ARE RUNNING ABOUT ONE
TO I THINK IT'S 25 TO 30, IN,
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
COMMITMENT, FOR OUR, FOR OUR
HOSPITAL PROGRAMS, THE AND THEN
NURSING HAS THEIR OWN RATIOS. WE
RECENTLY AND I THINK, IN THE
NEXT ITEM WE'RE GOING TO TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ON THIS. BUT WE DID
RECENTLY GO THROUGH A MISSION
BASED REVIEW, PROJECT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, AND THAT
RELOOKED AT OUR RATIOS, TO
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT, IF WE HAD
ADD, ENOUGH, ALLOCATION OF
STAFFING TO MEET THE, THE
PATIENT'S NEEDS AND BASED ON THE
CHANGING POPULATION THAT WE HAD
OVER, YOU KNOW, THE RECENT
YEARS. AND SO, THAT DID MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR RATIOS, AS IT
RELATES TO THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE FOR THE PATIENTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MY LAST QUESTION IS
RELATED TO I'M TRYING TO CHOOSE
THE CORRECT WORD, BECAUSE I
WOULDN'T SAY SUCCESS RATE FOR
THE IST PART, BUT IF YOU COULD
SHARE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
TRYING TO FIND A DIFFERENT WORD,
HOW LONG PERHAPS IT TAKES FOR
US, AT THE STATE HOSPITAL TO
THEN ALLOW THAT PERSON TO BE
COMPETENT, TO STAND TRIAL AND GO
CONTINUE IN THEIR PROCEDURE, HOW
OFTEN ARE WE ARE WE GETTING TO A
POINT, OR IS THERE A POINT WHERE
WE SAY, HEY, THIS PERSON REALLY
CANNOT, AND WHAT'S THE RATIO
THERE? IS IT MORE WE'RE ABLE TO
BRING THEM BACK TO COMPETENCY OR
NOT? YEAH, ALL GOOD QUESTIONS.
AND SO, THE LENGTH OF STAY ARE
GOING TO DEPEND ON THE PROGRAM
THAT THEY'RE IN. SO WITHIN THE
STATE HOSPITALS GENERALLY OUR
LENGTH OF STAY RUNS AROUND ABOUT
150 DAYS ISH. MARK THAT IS,
GENERALLY, LET ME BACK UP. SO
THE STATE HOSPITALS RUNS AROUND
ABOUT 150 DAYS. ARE OUR JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS RUN LESS THAN THAT?
THAT'S BECAUSE GENERALLY WE ARE
IDENTIFYING FOR PLACEMENT IN
THOSE PROGRAMS, INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE LIKELY TO RESTORE FASTER,
AND INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE THE
HIGHER NEEDS TO COME INTO THE
STATE HOSPITALS. AND THEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAMS, THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
MUCH LONGER. THOSE ARE DESIGNED
TO BE COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME, AND
THEN CONNECTION TO ONGOING
TREATMENT AFTER THEY'RE
RESTORED. SO ULTIMATELY, THOSE
TIMES ARE GOING TO REALLY DEPEND
ON THE PROGRAM THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL'S MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND THE, AND KIND OF WHAT AND
WHAT SERVICES THEY'RE GOING
INTO. IT'S ALSO SEVERITY OF, OF
CRIMINAL OFFENSE AS WELL, THAT
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY PLAY
INTO. WELL, IT DOES. YES. IT
DOESN'T PLAY INTO THEIR
RESTORATION, BUT IT WILL PLAY
INTO THEIR MAXIMUM COMMITMENT
TIME. RIGHT. SO IF SOMEBODY SO
THE MAXIMUM COMMITMENT FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS COMMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT, IS TWO YEARS.
BUT IF THEY'RE THE EQUIVALENCY
OF THE TIME THAT THEY WOULD GET
FOR THEIR CHARGES WAS LESS THAN
THAT, THEN THEY COULD HAVE A
SHORTER TERM WITH US, SO IT'S UP
TO A MAXIMUM OF TWO YEARS. AND
THEN GENERALLY WE RESTORE A HIGH
RATE. I THINK IT'S ABOUT 95% OF
INDIVIDUALS GET RESTORED, THERE
ARE SOME INDIVIDUALS THAT JUST
REACH MAXIMUM COMMITMENT. AND WE
WERE STILL CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THEM, BUT THEY DID REACH THEIR
MAXIMUM COMMITMENT TIME WITH US
AND THEY MAY HAVE RESTORED WE
DON'T KNOW, BUT THEY DID REACH
THE MAXIMUM COMMITMENT. AND THEN
THERE ARE FEW INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE DO RETURN TO THE COURTS AS,
AND WITH NO SUBSTANTIAL
LIKELIHOOD THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO RESTORE THEM. OKAY. THANK
YOU. WELL, ANY FURTHER COMMENT
ON THAT? WELL, NEVER MIND. IT'S
INFORMATIONAL. NEVER MIND. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR YOUR COMMENTS.
EXACTLY HOW YOU PROGRAM AND
CASELOAD UPDATES.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, BRANT HAUSER,
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS, BEFORE SPEAKING
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO. I JUST
WANTED TO GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ON THE QUESTION OF
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS WERE
DIVERTED. APOLOGIES DIRECTOR.
BETTER LATE THAN NEVER. BUT THEY
DID COME TO SAVE YOU OVER 1500
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
DIVERTED SINCE THE PROGRAM. AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S INCREASING WITH
ALL THE RECENT INVESTMENTS. SO
THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR THAT. ALL
RIGHT. GOING BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO, THERE ARE SIX
PROGRAM CASELOAD AND UPDATES
LISTED IN THE AGENDA. I'LL COVER
MOST OF THOSE AND THEN
TRANSITION OVER TO THE DIRECTOR
TO SPEAK TO THE INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL SOLUTIONS. MORE
SPECIFICALLY BEGINNING WITH THE
DSH METROPOLITAN INCREASE SECURE
BED CAPACITY PROJECT, DSH IS
REFLECTING A ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
9.6 MILLION. GENERAL FUND IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. THIS IS THIS
PROJECT WAS ORIGINALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH A CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECT IN 2016 TO BUILD
SECURITY FENCING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND AN
EXISTING BUILDING SO THAT WE
COULD ADD CAPACITY AND UTILIZE
THAT BUILDING TO SERVE FORENSIC
PATIENTS. THE PROJECT CONTINUES
TO EXPERIENCE DELAYS IN THE
ACTIVATION WITH THE REMAINING
TWO UNITS OUT OF FIVE TO SERVE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
PATIENTS WITH A TEN MONTH DELAY,
WHICH IS YIELDING THE $9.6
MILLION OF SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH PERSONAL SERVICES FOR THE
NEXT CASELOAD ADJUSTMENT
ADJUSTMENT. THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
INITIATIVE SPECIFIC TO DIRECT
CARE NURSING AND TREATMENT TEAM,
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE
DEPARTMENT IS REFLECTING A
SAVINGS OF 15.6 MILLION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED IN ISSUE ONE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO, DSH INITIATED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO EVALUATE OUR
STAFFING PRACTICES WORKLOAD
ACROSS THE STATE HOSPITALS AND
REVIEWED 24 HOUR CARE NURSING
SERVICES AND TREATMENT PLANNING
AND DELIVERY. AS A RESULT OF
THIS PROCESS, THIS PROPOSED
STAFFING METHODOLOGIES WERE
ADOPTED AND IMPLEMENTED IN
POSITION REQUESTS, YET LED TO
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ACROSS
NURSING AND TREATMENT. TÍNH
CLASSIFICATION ACTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN AUTHORIZED AND PHASED IN
OVER A MULTI-YEAR PERIOD. THE
SAVINGS ARE REPORTED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AS A RESULT, TO
DELAYS IN HIRING THOSE NEWLY
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS AND
CHALLENGES EXPERIENCED IN
FILLING THOSE POSITIONS FOR THE
PATIENT DRIVEN OPERATING
EXPENSES AND EQUIPMENT. UPDATE
DSHS REQUESTING $10.8 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND ONGOING TO
SUPPORT INCREASES IN PATIENT
DRIVEN SUPPORT COSTS WITHIN THE
DSH SYSTEM. THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
INCREASES AND COSTS FOR
UTILITIES, PHARMACEUTICALS AND
FOODSTUFFS. THE BUDGET ACT OF
2019 ADOPTED A METHODOLOGY, Kò,
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THESE
PATIENT RELATED ITEMS BASED ON
UPDATED CENSUS FIGURES, AS WELL
AS AN UPDATED PER COST PER
PATIENT. THE REQUEST IS AS A
RESULT OF INCREASES DUE TO
INFLATION FOR ESSENTIAL PATIENT
RELATED BASIC ACTIVITIES AND A
PROJECTED CENSUS INCREASE. MY
LAST UPDATE BEFORE HANDING IT
OVER TO THE DIRECTOR IS ON THE
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM FOR
NON SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS,
DSH ASSUMES A ONE TIME SAVINGS
OF $599,000 IN THE CURRENT YEAR,
AS A RESULT OF DELAYED
ADMISSIONS IN ONE OF OUR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
TRANSITIONAL RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM, SAVINGS ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO TEMPORARY PAUSING
ADMISSIONS TO ALLOW FOR FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT PROGRAM, BUT
WE HAVE SINCE RESUMED ADMISSIONS
FOR THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM. AND
I'LL HAND IT OVER TO THE
DIRECTOR TO SPEAK TO THE UPDATES
ON INCOMPETENCE AND TRIAL
SOLUTIONS. WITH RESPECT TO THE
IST SOLUTIONS, WE ARE REPORTING
A SAVINGS OF 58,573,000 IN THE
CURRENT YEAR, AND THESE SAVINGS
ARE RELATED TO OUR JAIL BASED
COMPETENCY TREATMENT PROGRAMS,
COMMUNITY INPATIENT FACILITIES
AND EARLY ACCESS AND
STABILIZATION SERVICES. THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO REQUESTING
TWO POSITIONS. THIS IS JUST
POSITION AUTHORITY ONLY TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS RELATED TO THE
GROWTH CAP IMPLEMENTATION. AND
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND, OVER THE
PAST DECADE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HAS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL ON FELONY CHARGES
AND WERE REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR COMPETENCY
RESTORATION. WITH YEAR OVER YEAR
GROWTH IN IST REFERRALS THAT ARE
OUTPACING THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO CREATE SUFFICIENT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY. UNTIL
RECENTLY, DESPITE OUR EFFORTS TO
EXPAND TREATMENT CAPACITY,
ESTARÁ REFERRALS OUTPACED OUR
EFFORTS AND RESULTED IN AN
ONGOING WAITLIST FOR INDIVIDUALS
NEEDING RESTORATION OF
COMPETENCY SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY, AS A RESULT OF THE
IMPACTS OF THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC
AND THE NECESSARY INFECTION
CONTROL MEASURES THAT WE HAD TO
IMPLEMENT AT THE STATE HOSPITALS
DURING THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
THE PANDEMIC, THE WAIT LIST AND
WAIT TIMES INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY, AND THEN AS A
RESULT OF THE 2015 LAWSUIT BY
ACLU REGARDING THE TIME THAT IST
DEFENDANTS WERE WAITING IN JAIL
TO BE TRANSFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT'S TREATMENT PROGRAMS,
THE COURT ORDERED THE DEPARTMENT
TO INITIATE SUBSTANTIVE SERVICES
WITHIN 28 DAYS. FOR IST
DEFENDANTS. THE COURT SET A
DEADLINE FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
ACHIEVE THE 28 DAYS, WHICH WAS
ORIGINALLY FEBRUARY OF 2024, AND
ALSO SET INTERIM BENCHMARKS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO ACHIEVE
TOWARDS MEETING THE FINAL 28 DAY
DEADLINE BY LAST FALL.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE DEPARTMENT, THE
COURT RESET THE DEADLINES AND WE
ARE NOW TO ACHIEVE THE 28 DAYS
BY MARCH 1ST OF 2025, 2025, AND
INTERIM BENCHMARKS HAVE BEEN SET
FOR 60 DAYS BY MARCH 1ST OF THIS
YEAR, 45 DAYS ON JULY 1ST OF
THIS YEAR, AND 33 DAYS BY
NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR. THE 2022
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED. DID WE MAKE
THE 60 DAY? WE DID, WE DID, WE
DID. SO WE JUST, RECENTLY
PROVIDED A REPORT TO THE REPORT
TO THE COURT ON OUR PROGRESS.
AND THE REPORT REFLECTED,
REFLECTED THAT THE AVERAGE TIME
TO INITIATING TREATMENT FOR ISTS
IN FEBRUARY 2024 WAS JUST 12
DAYS, AND WE HAD 98% OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVED
TREATMENT WITHIN 60 DAYS, AND
90% WERE RECEIVING TREATMENT IN
UNDER 28 DAYS. AS OF THAT
FEBRUARY, UPDATE, SO THE AS IT
RELATES TO IST SOLUTIONS, IT
ENCOMPASSES A SUITE OF PROGRAMS
AND STRATEGIES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IMPLEMENTED TO
EXPAND THE CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
ISTS AND PROVIDE TIMELY ACCESS
TO SERVICES, AND TO PROVIDE JUST
AN UPDATE ON THE FOR IST
SOLUTIONS THAT WE ARE PROJECTING
SAVINGS OR HAVE A REQUEST IN THE
IN OUR FOR THE FOR THE BUDGET,
THE FIRST WAS THE EARLY ACCESS
AND STABILIZATION SERVICES,
WHICH IS BEING IMPLEMENTED IN
THE JAILS UNDER THIS PROGRAM.
IST INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
STABILIZATION AND TREATMENT
SERVICES IN THE EARLIEST POINT
POSSIBLE IN JAIL. WHILE WE WORK
TO COORDINATE PLACEMENT TO THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE TREATMENT
SETTING AVAILABLE WITHIN OUR IST
CONTINUUM. AS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, WE HAD IMPLEMENTED ESE
PROGRAMS IN 44 COUNTIES, AND
DESPITE THE RAPID IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROGRAM, THERE ARE STILL
SEVERAL LARGE COUNTIES PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ANTICIPATED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE FUTURE. THUS,
THERE IS A ONE TIME ESTIMATED
SAVINGS OF ABOUT $20 MILLION IN
THE CURRENT YEAR FOR THIS
PROGRAM, NEXT WE HAVE BEEN
EXPANDING JAIL BASED COMPETENCY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SHORT TERM TREATMENT
CAPACITY. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
424 JRB K¾T BEDS ACROSS 24
COUNTIES, AND WE ARE REPORTING A
NET SAVINGS OF 8.6 MILLION IN
2324 FOR THIS PROGRAM. AS A
RESULT OF UPDATED TIMELINES
ASSOCIATED WITH FINALIZING
CONTRACTS FOR NEW AND EXPANDING
K¾T PROGRAMS. AND THEN WE ARE
UTILIZING COMMUNITY AND PATIENT
FACILITIES. I, AS I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY, AND THIS IS TO
PROVIDE RESTORATION OF
COMPETENCY AND STABILIZATION
SERVICES. AND AS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, WE HAD
CONTRACTED WITH FIVE COMMUNITY
FACILITIES FOR A TOTAL OF 183
BEDS. AND THEY ARE LOCATED IN
ANAHEIM, BAKERSFIELD, LOS
ANGELES, SACRAMENTO AND YUBA
CITY. WE HAVE ALSO EXECUTED A
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT WITH
CRESTWOOD BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR
THE ACTIVATION OF A 36 TO 40 BED
MRC LOCATED IN FRESNO COUNTY.
BUT DUE TO THE LENGTHY
NEGOTIATION PROCESS REQUIRED TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL CONTRACTS, WE
ARE CURRENTLY PROJECTING A ONE
TIME CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS OF 30
MILLION FOR THE COMMUNITY
INPATIENT FACILITIES PROGRAM,
AND THEN LASTLY, WE ARE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING THE FELONY IST
GROWTH CAP PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE INCREASING
REFERRALS TO THE DEPARTMENT BY
ESTABLISHING A BASELINE NUMBER
OF IST DETERMINATIONS FOR
COUNTIES, BASED ON THE 2122
RATES, AND ASSESSING A PENALTY
IN THE COUNTY, IF THE COUNTIES
EXCEEDS THE REFERRAL LEVEL BY A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD. LAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT WORKED WITH COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES TO FINALIZE THE
PARAMETERS FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
HAS ISSUED BASELINE IST NUMBERS
FOR EACH COUNTY. FINAL IST DATA
FOR 20 2223 AND, THE FINAL IST
DATA WITH THE COUNTIES IS IN
PROCESS OF BEING RECONCILED.
AND, BASED ON THE 22 2023
REFERRALS ARE POTENTIALLY 11
COUNTIES THAT MAY BE ISSUED
PENALTIES RANGING FROM $34,500
TO 13.6 MILLION FOR EXCEEDING
THEIR BASELINE REFERRAL LEVELS
AND WE'RE REQUESTING POSITION
AUTHORITY ONLY FOR TWO POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT THE SIGNIFICANT DATA
NEEDS TO OPERATE. ANALYZE THE
FELONY IST GROWTH CAP PROGRAM
THAT WAS NOT CONTEMPLATED DURING
THE INITIAL DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ORIGINAL IST BUDGET SOLUTION,
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR UPDATES
WITH RESPECT TO THE ESTIMATES.
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. DEPUTY DIRECTOR? YES.
IS THAT. NÓ YES, CHIEF. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. CHIEF DEPUTY. I'M
SORRY. I GOT TO GET IT RIGHT,
CHIEF, FOR CONREP THE PROGRAM
YOU MENTIONED, YOU SAID THAT YOU
STARTED ACCEPTING PEOPLE ALREADY
TO YOUR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
STRIP FACILITY CAPACITY AT 20.
IS IT FILLED NOW? BECAUSE THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS. I DON'T HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS READILY AVAILABLE. BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING WE COULD FOLLOW
UP. DO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
STARTED, ALLOWING TRANSFERRING
PEOPLE TO THAT LOCATION? I DO
NOT HAVE THOSE DETAILS, BUT I
CAN WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH WITH
YOUR STAFF ON THAT. THANK YOU. I
WAS JUST ASKING BECAUSE I'M
WONDERING IF THERE WAS A BACKLOG
BECAUSE THAT SAVINGS WAS FROM A
BACKLOG. IF WE WERE WAITING FOR
THAT FURTHER CONSTRUCTION, THAT
I THINK IS. SO THE SAVINGS ISN'T
RELATED TO A BACKLOG. THE
SAVINGS WAS RELATED TO THE BEDS
WEREN'T FILLED. SO AND THE
BECAUSE WE HAD TO PAUSE
ADMISSIONS WITH RESPECT TO THAT
PROGRAM DUE TO SOME STAFFING
CHALLENGES. AND SO WE DID RESUME
ADMISSIONS JUST DON'T HAVE THE,
CURRENT CENSUS, BUT WE ALSO ARE
PLANNING TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE IN
MAY. REVISION AS WELL. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MADAM
DIRECTOR, MAYBE YOU COULD
REFRESH MY RECOLLECTION A LITTLE
BIT. I APOLOGIZE, I DIDN'T DO MY
HOMEWORK ON THIS PARTICULAR
SUBJECT, BUT I SEEM TO RECALL
SOME CONCERN FROM DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE CAP AND THE
WAY THE ESTATES WERE COUNTED. AM
I HAVING A FAILURE TO WE. THERE
WAS DEFINITELY CONCERNS RAISED
AROUND THE GROWTH CAP AND WE
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME LAST
SUMMER AND EARLY FALL WITH THE
COUNTIES WORKING THROUGH THE
GROWTH CAP METHODOLOGY AND
REVISE THE GROWTH CAP
METHODOLOGY. Kò, AND THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCED DOWN THE
LEVEL OF THE PENALTIES. THAT IS
GOING TO BE, POTENTIALLY, SENT
TO THE COUNTIES, AND BUT THEIR
WORK DEFINITELY CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THE GROWTH CAP, BUT
THOSE HAVE BEEN THOSE HAVE BEEN
MITIGATED. AND I WOULD SAY THAT
WE'VE DEFINITELY WORKED WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS WITH HOW THE GROWTH CAP
PENALTY HAS BEEN. LIKE I SAID,
CALCULATED AND DEVELOPED. BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT COUNTIES STILL
ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT THE GROWTH
CAP PENALTY. SO I WOULD SAY
THERE'S STILL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
GROWTH CAP EXISTING, AND STILL
REQUESTS FOR, YOU KNOW, IS THERE
OTHER ADJUSTMENTS WE CAN MAKE TO
THE, TO HOW WE ARE CALCULATING
THE PENALTY, BUT OVERALL, I
WOULD SAY THERE ARE QUITE A BIT
LESS THAN WHAT THEY WERE EARLIER
. I DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY CALLS IN
IN ADVANCE OF THIS HEARING.
MAYBE I'LL GET THEM AFTERWARD
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION. BUT I APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPONSE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT, JOSEPH
DAWSON, FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. WELL, ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON WILL OAN
LEÓN NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN. MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE, INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PREVENTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON. BRANT HAUSER
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS. AGAIN, I'M ALSO
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE, MEDICAL
DIRECTOR DOCTOR KATHERINE
WARBURTON, TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE, SPECIFIC TO THIS
AGENDA ITEM, THE DEPARTMENT'S
REQUESTING 25.9 MILLION AND 24,
25 AND 7.7 MILLION AND ONGOING,
FOR EXPENDITURES RELATED TO
INFECTION CONTROL MEASURES TO
CONTINUE TO PROTECT DSH PATIENTS
AND STAFF. ADDITIONALLY, DSH
REQUESTS PERMANENT FUNDING AND
POSITION AUTHORITY FOR TEN
LIMITED TERM PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
POSITIONS IN 24, 25 AND ONGOING
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH RELATED GUIDELINES AND
REGULATIONS. DURING THE ONSET OF
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC, DSH
IMPLEMENTED A RESPONSE PLAN
ACROSS ITS SYSTEM AND ADJUSTED
THIS PLAN ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
ALTHOUGH THE CALIFORNIA STATE OF
EMERGENCY ENDED IN FEBRUARY OF
2023 AND THE FEDERAL STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN MAY OF 2023, WE
STILL DO HAVE AN ONGOING
RESPONSIBILITY AND REQUIREMENTS
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR STAFF AND PATIENTS FROM
AEROSOL TRANSMISSIBLE,
TRANSMISSIBLE DISEASES, BASED ON
THE CHANGES IN OPERATIONS MADE
BY DSH IN ACCORDANCE WITH
OVERSIGHT ENTITIES SUCH AS THE
CDC, CDPH, CAL OSHA AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE, WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO SUPPORT INFECTION
CONTROL MEASURES POST PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY, WHICH IS INCLUDED BUT
IS NOT LIMITED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OF VACCINE AND
EDUCATION ON CONTINUED PROVISION
OF PPE, ISOLATION AND QUARANTINE
GUIDELINES, CONTINUED SANITATION
PROTOCOLS AND TESTING PROTOCOLS
WHEN NECESSARY. OUR REQUEST IS
LOWER THAN PRIOR YEARS,
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE ONGOING
CHANGES IN REDUCTION IN
REQUIREMENTS BY CDC AND CDPH
OVER TIME, AS WELL AS CHANGES IN
THE SEVERITY OF THE VIRUS, WHICH
HAS, RESULTED IN LESS OUTSIDE
HOSPITALIZATIONS, THE NUMBER OF
ISOLATION UNITS WE NEED, AND WE
NO LONGER NEED TO UTILIZE THESE
ADMISSION OBSERVATION UNITS THAT
CONCLUDES TESTIMONY ON ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. AND DOCTOR WARBURG
AND I ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. NO THANK
YOU, DOCTOR CHIEF. THANK YOU.
WILL ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT?
WILL. OAN DELYLAH. WE HAVEN'T
RAISED CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. IAC SOLUTIONS FOR TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
IS IT ON? YES. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
EDENS, CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
PROGRAM SERVICES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
I'LL BE HANDLING ISSUE FOR THE
IST TRAILER. BILL THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL RELATED TO
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
SOLUTIONS. THE TRAILER BILL
ADDRESSES ISSUES THAT WILL HELP
IMPROVE PROGRAM EFFICIENCIES IN
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE IST
WAITLIST AND UTILIZATION OF
TREATMENT PROGRAM BEDS. THE
PROPOSED CHANGES WILL DO SEVERAL
THINGS, INCLUDING CLARIFYING THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITAL'S
RECORDS, ACCESS TO REDUCE
ADMISSION BARRIERS, ESTABLISH A
WAIT A WAITLIST MANAGEMENT
PROCESS FOR IST INDIVIDUALS
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT BUT
WHO ARE NOT AVAILABLE FOR
ADMISSION BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IN THE SHERIFF'S
CUSTODY. CLARIFY WHY, WHEN IST
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE REGAINED
COMPETENCY CAN REMAIN AT THE
DEPARTMENT WHEN IT IS NEEDED TO
MAINTAIN THEIR COMPETENCY,
ESTABLISH AUTHORITY FOR THE
COURT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
INVOLUNTARY MEDICATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT REMAIN AT DSH.
FOR PURPOSES OF MAINTAINING
THEIR COMPETENCY. THIS WOULD BE
UNDER PENAL CODE 1372,
SUBSECTION Â EXTEND DSH
AUTHORITY TO BILL FOR
INDIVIDUALS RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY OR WHO REMAIN IN
STATE HOSPITAL TREATMENT BEDS
AFTER TEN DAYS, TO OTHER DSH
FUNDED PROGRAMS. ALLOW DSH TO
ASSIST DISCHARGING PATIENTS WITH
OBTAINING CALIFORNIA ID CARDS TO
SUPPORT SUCCESSFUL TRANSITIONS
TO THE COMMUNITY. AND LASTLY,
THE PROPOSED BILL WOULD UPDATE
THE DATA REPORTING TIMELINE FOR
COUNTY OPERATED, DSH FUNDED
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FROM
QUARTERLY TO MONTHLY SUBMISSIONS
. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS?
YES. CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE,
CLARITY ON REMOVING FROM THE ICY
WHITE LIST OF THE INDIVIDUALS
OUT OF THE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
CUSTODY? DOES THAT MEAN WE JUST
LOST THIS INDIVIDUAL? NO, NO.
SOME OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
IST ON FELONY CHARGES JUST MAY
BE RELEASED FROM JAIL OUT ON
THEIR OWN RECOGNIZANCE, OR MAYBE
HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR BAIL. AND
SO THEY'RE OUT OF THE SHERIFF'S
CUSTODY. SO THEY'RE ACCOUNTED
FOR. THEY'RE JUST NOT NO LONGER.
OKAY. YEAH, AND THEN WHAT IS THE
CLARITY REGARDING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH AN
INDIVIDUAL RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY CAN REMAIN AT DHS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF MAINTAINING
COMPETENCY? WHAT? SO PENAL
CODES, PENAL CODE 1372,
SUBSECTION Â, IS WHEN WE'VE
WE'VE RESTORED THE INDIVIDUAL TO
COMPETENCY. BUT OUR DOCTORS HAVE
DETERMINED THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE ONGOING TREATMENT TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUAL WILL
MAINTAIN COMPETENCY UNTIL THEIR
SORT OF PROCEEDINGS COMMENCE.
AND THEY AND THAT THEY, SORT OF
MAKE IT THROUGH THE TRIAL
PROCESS, AND SO WE MAY MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COURTS TO
RETAIN THAT INDIVIDUAL, TO
MAINTAIN THEIR COMPETENCY, THE
LAW AS IT STANDS, IS NOT CLEAR
AS TO THE POINT IN WHICH WE WERE
TO ADVISE THE COURT THAT THE
PERSON MAY NO LONGER NEED TO BE
IN A STATE HOSPITAL LEVEL OF
TREATMENT TO MAINTAIN THEIR
COMPETENCY. SO THIS IS REALLY
CLARIFYING THAT PROCESS. IT IS
ALSO CLARIFIED LYING, WHEN A
COURT CAN OPINE ON, ON EXTENSION
OR, RENEWAL OF AN INVOLUNTARY
MEDICATION ORDER. OKAY. AND THEN
MY FINAL QUESTION IS REGARDING,
THE IST WORKGROUP AND THEN THE
BED CAPACITY, STRATEGY, NOT JUST
OUR STATE BUT COMMUNITY BED
CAPACITY AND SO FORTH, AND
UPDATE ON THAT AND HOW THAT'S
GOING. OH YEAH. THE, SO THE, THE
DIRECTOR TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR DIVERSION PILOT
PROGRAM. CURRENTLY, WE'VE GOT
ABOUT 29 COUNTIES THAT ARE
OPERATING. WE'VE DIVERTED OVER
1500. THAT'S ACTUALLY DATA AS OF
JUNE OF LAST YEAR IN TERMS OF
PERMANENT PROGRAMS, WE'VE
CURRENTLY TRANSITIONED ONE OF
OUR PILOT PROGRAMS, LA COUNTY,
TO PERMANENT PROGRAM. THAT IS WE
IN LAST SUMMER HAD, EXECUTED A
CONTRACT WITH LA COUNTY FOR OVER
ABOUT A 4 TO 5 YEAR PERIOD. WE
WILL BE EXPANDING THAT PROGRAM
TO OVER 1400 BEDS, IN TERMS OF
THE SUBACUTE BEDS IN THE
COMMUNITIES NÓ, THOSE ARE. WELL,
IT'S A COMBINATION OF BEDS,
MOSTLY. THEY'RE RESIDENTIAL,
RESIDENTIAL UNLOCK SECURED
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS. THERE ARE
SOME SUBACUTE BEDS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE LÀ CONTRACT, AS WELL
AS SOME ACUTE BEDS. THEY HAVE
SORT OF A FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE
IN LA COUNTY, WITH MOST OF THOSE
BEING RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS. SO
THE SO, SO WORK IS STILL
CONTINUING. WE'RE STILL WORKING
WITH COUNTIES TO BUILD THOSE
SUBACUTE BED CAPACITY. AND SO
FORTH. RIGHT. WE'RE IN THE
EARLIER STAGES FOR THE COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS ARE ARE REALLY OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS WAS WAS
FOCUSING ON THE WAITLIST AND THE
SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS. AND THAT
WAS PRIMARILY OUR JAIL BASED
PROGRAMS. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT? NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
THANK YOU. NOTHING FURTHER TO
ADD. OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON TO OUR
LAST ISSUE, ISSUE NUMBER FIVE,
ON THE CENTRAL UTILITY PLAN
REPLACEMENT AT THE METROPOLITAN
LOCATION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON, SEAN HAMMER,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR, ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES, DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. HERE TO PRESENT ISSUE
FIVE, THE DSH METROPOLITAN
POLITAN CENTRAL UTILITY PLANT
REPLACEMENT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS REQUESTS 50.5
MILLION IN PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE
METROPOLITAN CENTRAL UTILITY
PLANT REPLACEMENT PROJECT. THIS
PROJECT WILL REPLACE THE
EXISTING CENTRAL UTILITY PLANT
LOCATED AT DSH METRO, THAT
CURRENTLY SUPPLIES STEAM FOR HOT
WATER AND CENTRAL HEATING, AS
WELL AS CHILLED WATER AND AIR
CONDITIONING TO 32 PATIENT
HOUSING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BUILDINGS. DSH RETAINED AN
ARCHITECTURE AND ENGINEERING
FIRM TO DETERMINE THE BEST
ALTERNATIVE FOR REPLACING PART
OF THE AGING AND OBSOLETE
CENTRAL UTILITY PLANT,
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WAS IDENTIFIED
WAS A CENTRALIZED OPTION AND
THIS PROJECT WILL INCLUDE
REPLACEMENT OF CHILLERS, BOILERS
AND PUMPS, THE REPLACEMENT OF
PIPING AND INSTALLATION OF WATER
LINES THROUGHOUT THE PROJECT
WILL IMPROVE THE OVERALL
INFRASTRUCTURE, MOVE THE
FACILITY AWAY FROM STEAM
GENERATION AND TRANSITION TO HOT
WATER BOILERS VIA A COMMERCIAL
DUTY SYSTEM WITH LOW EMISSION
EQUIPMENT, AND IT WILL ALSO
ALLOW FOR MAXIMUM EFFICIENCY.
THIS CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY, BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I
PLAN TO VISIT THE SITE SOON, SO
I HOPE I SEE ALL THOSE UPDATES
WHEN I GO, ONLY I GUESS. I MEAN,
IT'S 50 MILLION. LIKE HOW BAD DO
WE NEED IT NOW? I MEAN, IT'S
WELL, THE ORIGINAL PIPES THAT
ARE THERE, WERE PUT IN IN 1915,
AND THE LAST TIME THE SYSTEM WAS
UPDATED IS 1988. SO WE LOSE
ABOUT 20, TO STEAM LEAKS, 20% OF
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY. AND THIS
IS COMING OUT OF NOT THE GENERAL
FUND, RIGHT? NO IT'S PUBLIC
BUILDINGS, CONSTRUCTION FUNDS.
OKAY OKAY. IS THAT WELL, HE
LOOKED LIKE HE WANTED TO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE HOW MUCH WILL IT
COST IF WE DON'T DO IT? HELLO?
MATT SCHULER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OF COURSE, EVERY YEAR
DELAY, IT'S GOING TO COST A TAD
MORE. BUT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
109 YEAR OLD PIPING AND 36 YEAR
OLD SYSTEM, THEY'RE UPKEEP IS
VERY DIFFICULT. IT'S EXPENSIVE.
AND WE SEE IT AS A AS A PATIENT.
SAFETY ISSUE, POTENTIALLY AT ANY
DAY, ANY TIME. MY HOUSE WAS
CONSTRUCTED IN 1913. YEAH I KNOW
ABOUT OLD PIPES. AM I GOING TO
SEE A BCP FOR YOUR HOUSE? OKAY,
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN. THAT CONCLUDES ALL OUR
ISSUES. MOVING ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IS THERE TIME TO COME
UP?
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. JOLIE ONODERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, REPRESENTING 50, ALL
58 COUNTIES, HERE TO COMMENT ON
THE FIRST ISSUE THAT WAS
PRESENTED ON THE PROGRAMMATIC
AND FISCAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT,
AS WAS WELL ARTICULATED BY THE
PANELISTS, THERE IS A LOT OF
IMPORTANT WORK TO BE DONE. THAT
LAYS AHEAD, THAT WILL BE
CRITICAL. TO INFORMING HOW THE
PROP ONE, IS, IS IMPLEMENTED AND
HOW IT WILL IMPACT COUNTIES. AND
IMPORTANTLY, HOW IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT BEING SAID, COUNTIES ARE
COMMITTED TO FULLY IMPLEMENTING
THE PROPOSITIONS PROVISIONS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH YOU. THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE COMMISSION,
AND ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ON
ALL OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CRITERIA, AND GUIDANCE THAT ARE
EXPECTED AND WILL BE NEEDED TO
ROLL THIS OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SELENA LU RAPHAEL,
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES, CBA REALLY
ARTICULATED WELL SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. SO I WANTED
TO FOCUS ON BISHOP, CHAIRMAN
GUEVARA, YOU ASKED IF IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. MANY OF OUR MEMBER
ORGS HAVE BEEN AWARDED THE
GRANTS, BUT HAVE HAD A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY ACCESSING ANY OF THE
FUNDS. MANY OF THEM HAVE HAD TO
EXPEND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN LAWYERS ARCHITECTURE
FEES, CONTRACTUAL FEES. AND
THERE'S 18 PLUS STEPS WITH
MULTIPLE SUB STEPS THAT WEREN'T
NECESSARILY, OPEN BEFORE. WE'VE
BEEN PARTNERING WITH DCS TO TRY
AND EXPAND THOSE, GET THOSE
FUNDS OUT SO THAT OUR CBOS DON'T
GO UNDER FROM HAVING TO EXPEND
ALL OF THESE FUNDS AHEAD OF
TIME. SO WE CONTINUE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
DCS TO MAKE SURE THESE FUNDS GET
OUT TO OUR CBOS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI. THANK YOU. CHAIR,
COMMITTEE AND STAFF, RYAN
MAUMENEE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AS
WELL. BUT HERE ON A DIFFERENT
ISSUE AS IT RELATES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
INCOMPETENT STAND TRIAL GROWTH
CAP AND PENALTY PROGRAM. FIRST
AND FOREMOST, WE WOULD LIKE TO
SAY WE WERE DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT AND ONGOING
INVESTMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF ADMINISTRATION THÀNH TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THE GROWING ESRD
POPULATION. THAT SAID, WE REMAIN
CONCERNED, AS DIRECTOR CLENDENEN
NOTED, AS IT RELATES TO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM. AND
PHIL, IT'S A BIT MISGUIDED AND
KIND OF ASSUMES THAT COUNTIES
HAVE FULL CONTROL OVER THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DEEMED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. THAT SAID, AGAIN, WE'RE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AND HOPE
WE CAN REVISIT FOLLOWING YEAR
ONE IMPLEMENTATION. TAKE A LOOK
AT THE DATA AND CONTINUE TO
MONITOR HOW THESE INVESTMENTS
PLAY OUT LOCALLY IN THE
COUNTIES. BUT AGAIN, APPRECIATE,
YOU KNOW, YOU ALL FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. AND THEN
DEFINITELY THE DEPARTMENT'S
PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU. NORA LIN
WITH CHILDREN NOW, SPEAKING TO
THE FIRST ISSUE THAT WAS
PRESENTED TODAY, WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MANY OF THE MEMBERS
HERE TODAY WHO WORKED WITH
CHILDREN'S GROUPS LAST YEAR TO
PRESERVE FUNDING FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH UNDER THE PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION CATEGORY.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THE PASSAGE
OF PROP ONE, WE'VE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL COUNTY PARTNERS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REDUCE
THEIR FUNDING FOR SERVICES FOR
IMPACTED CHILDREN. WE URGE THE
STATE TO PROVIDE CLEAR GUIDANCE
ON THE RESPONSIBILITY COUNTIES
HAVE TO PROVIDE 51% OF THEIR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES,
SUPPORT DOLLARS TO EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. ADDITIONALLY, WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MONITOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
REQUIREMENT CLOSELY IN THE
UPCOMING YEARS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, ROBERT
HARRISON, ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA, WE AGREE WITH WHAT
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR
SAID IN ONE SPECIFIC INSTANCE
FOR THE PF CONNECT WAIVER AND
THE WORKFORCE TRAINING, IT
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MONEY. THEN A SECOND THING IS
JUST A GENERAL COMMENT. AS WE
TRY AND INTEGRATE SYSTEMS AS
THEIR EXPERIMENTAL PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITY FIND PROGRAMS FUNDED
BY PROP 64, WHICH WE AREN'T
PAYING ATTENTION TO, AND WE
OUGHT TO SEE IF THERE'S OVERLAP.
AND SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS COULD
WORK AND BE TRANSFERRED IN. SO I
BROUGHT THIS UP BEFORE TO TOBY
AND TO DEPARTMENT. BUT I THINK
IT'S UP TO YOU PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THEY DO THAT
BECAUSE LIKE THESE PROGRAMS
COULD BE TRANSFERRED BEALL OR WE
CAN LEARN SOMETHING FROM THEM.
AND THIS ISN'T ALL JUST IT'S
ALSO THE COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT
GRANTS. OR IN THAT PROP 64 MONEY
THAT'S WORTH LOOKING AT AND HOW
HOW THEY WORK TOGETHER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BROKE THE RECORD
ON THE SHORTEST AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT EVER WITH THAT BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES HAS
CONCLUDED. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
EVERYONE